quoi
ouais tu es tu es impatient
euh bon écoute oui enfin écoute c'est un
peu sans se mentir c'est un peu spécial
et dur de se passionner et d'être à fond
fond fond les circonstances dans
lesquelles on est mais écoute vu que ça
a lieu on fait ça au mieux et puis euh
et puis on va essayer de passer un bon
moment ouais donc aujourd'hui pas
d'émission
F malheureusement non mais je crois
qu'il y aura une autre émission non
ouais une émission très qualitative
du coup le nom de
l'émission Ça fait trop ce truc en
[Rires]
fait
salut sal sal salut
salutouourout y
esto
ah attende de prendre le chat fenêtré
euh tu peux rester sur mon écran au cas
où tout moment tu peux aller sur Chat
fenêtré je quitte les paramètres
modérateurs non parce que je suis
modérateur ici mais pas sur blit stream
non sur blam
non je suis un nobody sur les stream
ouais sur chesscom là oui on streame sur
chesscom et on se sent quelqu'un ah je
me sens streamer là à fond et en plus il
a écrit grand maître
sur tu écrit grand maître audessus de
ton nom quoi du coup on est sur chesscom
et on se sent grand maître mais c'est
dommage que ça soit pas écrit
fa je pas je qui c'est s Fabien
libizevski quoi enfin
c'est mieux que Libye non ouais ça SNE
mieux
fa liby enfin il y a il y a trop de trop
de trop de voyal quoi ça être
fantastique le prochain tournoi rapide
que tu fais ou quoi après le confinement
tu arrives dans le
toural non je pense viment si vous jouez
aux éche vous croyez F faut vraiment
gueul les femm à fond quoi mais même
c'est ma mère non ou mon beau-père qui
t' dit ça que tu croisais à can à je les
ai croisé dans la rue salut Fab bon ils
ont pas fait Fab mais ils ont fait salut
Fab quoi
et et moi en fait je les connaissais pas
quoi tu vois je merde mais qui c'est
quoi qui c'est C type non ça va ma vite
dit oui je suis la maman de Kevin et
Machin et voilà oui je regarde tes
stream je connais je te connais mieux
que tes propres parents enfin mais ma
mère elle doit être en train de regarder
là c'est sûr elle est confinée elle met
le truc sur la télé elle regarde à fond
mais là elle a pris Netflix ah mais très
bien bravo du coup si tu as des des
conseils séries on on en dira tout à
l'heure quoi je vais on va attendre
pe-être pour être sûr qu'elle soit
connectée quoi je bonjour ta maman au
cas où et le chien est là aussi elle
elle a le droit de sortir avec le chien
le soir quoi ah ben enin même n'importe
quand non pas que le soir ouais mais
nous le soir après 18h je crois qu'on a
plus le droit de sortir hein ah
bon dis un couvrefeu enfin je sais pas
couvrefeu enfin il y a du feu tu le
couvres quoi enfin ouais c'est vrai
c'est génial en couvrefeu tu fais feu de
tout
bois c'est
beau ça c'est quand tu étais allé aux î
c'était fantastique conversation avec
Lena ah oui ouioui quand on était il y
av les bateaux et tout là ouais oui tu
tu vas du tu vois du bois tu fais du feu
quoi
euh chaque fois que tu veux sortir euh B
je crois Mog ouais en tout cas chaque
jour c'est
sûr mais normalement tu coches la la
raison
ouais toi tu caches tu coches quoi comme
raison quand tu sors ou tu ne sors ah je
suis pas encore sorti moi donc bon en
fait je coche rien du tout et moi non
plus je suis pas encore sorti
non mais
bon je sortirai pour aller faire des
courses je pense moi demain je
sors il y en a marre alors tu sais que
tu vois quand on parle un peu tous les
jours des frelons des machins alors
aujourd'hui il y a une abeille qui est
venue ah donc fait tu vois je suis passé
du frelon asiatique au bourdon bourdon
puis là il y a l'abeille alors
beaucoup plus intelligente en fait enfin
elle est resté pendant 20 minutes elle a
cherché dans toutes les fleurs elle
était de partout mais après éta un peu
dégoûtée quoi elle a pas trop trouvé de
quoi blutiner et ben du coup après elle
est parti où les feuilles étaient
tombées pour voir enfin elle a cherché à
fond quoi elle s'est bien battu quoi oui
enfin va voir l'autre arbre quoi bon
elle est partie voir l'autre arbre enfin
elle a rien trou elle est revenue elle
est allé par terre ou avec les fleurs
qui étaient tombées et puis bon elle est
reparti un peu d'g quoi il faut que tu
lui dises de ENF faut faire ga au frelon
asiatique quand même quoi ah il y aurait
eu le frelon je me serais battu contre
le frelon pour la sauver he ouais parce
que les frelons sont très fort contre
les abeilles quoi doivent se mettre très
nombreuses pour lutter contre un frelon
quoi ouais tu envoyé la vidéo quoi elles
se mettent au tour ell volent à fond
ça se joue à 3 degrés près quoi
l'histoire par qu'en fait elles font
elles font chauffer la température à
fond et elles sont un peu plus
résistantes que le frelon à la chaleur
de pas beaucoup quoi mais de de 3 degr
donc le frelon meurt quoi mais bon elle
se sacrifie à à beaucoup
enfin frelon doit être complètement
dégoûté quand même qui c'est ces cons
qui me tourne autour des comment elles
ont pu trouver ce système de défense et
puis je sais pas ell arent à communiquer
à se le dire un petit coup un petit coup
de téléphone c'est c'est ça aussi qui
est beau c'est comment ell se le disent
que bon tu as des av sont là
je trouvé une nouveuté théorique tout le
monde le sait mais bon j'espère que
votre ruche aussi est au courant
quoi c'est vraiment une ruche la ruche
Navara quoi ils sont tous morts très
rapidement je n'aurais pas pensé
autrement quoi ils sont vraiment très
cons c'est beau quoi une ruche Navara
quoiêche marlus tu dit que je suis un
peu flou bon ouais tuas un poil flou
mais c'est j'ai peur avec la connexion
fouous que si on ouvre tout ça bug je
préfère regarder un poil de flou et que
ce soit fluide bah tant que c'est
audible non mais c'est très le le la
qualité du son est parfaite c'est quand
même ça le plus important je pense ouais
complètement j'ai pas envie de risquer
hier avec roman on a un peu essayé il
était déjà un peu flou on a voulu
améliorer on a tout fait péter les
micros marchaient plus plus rien marché
donc euh cétait Cauchemar en Cuisine
quoi ouais céit Cauchemar en Cuisine C
cette abeille n'appartient pas à cette
ruche elle s'est à peine butiné une
fleur
bien ce que je
[Musique]
disais c'est marrant je peux imaginer
vraiment Vlad dans n'importe quelle
situation il parlerait pareil quo c'est
beau
quoi ça commence à midi c'est ça dit
herogamal exactement
exact euh un peu fou vous êtes restreint
en débit à Paris il est pas il est pas à
Paris
bitumix commence par lui parler poliment
s'il te plaît quoi j'ai bien aimé
l'article là du jour du Nouvel Ops non
pensait pas que cétait aussi con bon ben
en fait si mais c'est tellement
marrant on pensais pas que cétait aussi
con çait quand même beaucoup de temps
qu'on le dit nous quoi et Nico il
demande si les candidat on é testés par
le coron bah deux fois par jour même et
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs hier il s en su
avec carwana parce que bon il se lève il
lui prenneent sa température bon il a 37
bon rieninquiétant là si attention euh
ou c'est un peu beaucoup du coup ils
l'ont refait passer un test après et
cetera et cetera quoi et nous avec Fab
on voudrait qu'il donne les modalités de
la prise de température parce que je
crois qu'on a des idées quand même très
intéressantes attends il a juste la télé
à côté qui tourne à fond je vais faire
la baisser j'arrive he vas-y vas-y vas-y
non parce qu'en fait juste pour raconter
hier avec Fab donc on parle ensemble un
peu avant l'émission Fab de la
température et puis je dis à fa mais
comment il la prennent parce que pour
être bien sûr de la température que tu
as il y a enfin à mon avis il y a qu'une
manière quoi enfin je sais pas du coup
du coup on se disait que pour faire
chier les joueurs non russes il pourrait
leur prendre la température 8 fois par
jour quoi on n pas sûr que c'est pas
augmenté
quoi du coup ce sera un moyen
psychologique de mettre la pression quoi
pendant la partie viens je te prends la
température fait très attention bon je
sais pas ça nous fait
marré al esali firouja est pas considéré
comme un joueur français alors qu'il a
char je sais pas est-ce que quand
j'abite en Russie je suis devenu russe
papieramens je ne crois pas je ne crois
pas bah à l'ancienne oua tanidual la
seule manière qui vaille quoi à
l'ancienne
et rogabal il dit que dans les que dans
les oreilles ou dans la bouche c'est
assez fiable chez les adultes c'est mon
de quoi j'aiam il dit je crois que dans
l'oreille ou dans la bouche c'est assez
fiable chez les adultes moi je te dis
NON je dis Russie non en Russie on te
dit non Poutine d'ailleurs vient de
faire un décret on va prendre la
température 40 fois par jour tu vas être
heureux
quoi ça serait genre de maîre Yoda quoi
Aï aïe
aïe bon alors bon dans 5 minutes
quoi papy ramen se se demandait si si on
pouvait dire se dire que firouja était
français parce qu'il habitait à chartre
je lui dit nul non
quoi quoi il a demandé est-ce qu'on
pouvait considérer firuja comme un
joueur français comme il habita à
chartre je lui dit non bah pour
l'instant c'est comme je dis moi
j'habite en Russie je suis pas russe
enfin parce que Neymar est français quoi
ah oui bah il joue PSG donc forcément il
est français quoi donc
estce que Zidane encore français je
crois qu'il est espagnol Zid Zidan est
devenu espagnol mat tuidi italien
d'ailleurs c'est extraordinaire
bizarrement joue pour l'équipe de France
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il y a un vis
dans le dans truc c'est beau plus trop
quoi
B je l' dis qui ça crois sur les
chapeaux de rou au live bah ouiant 2
jours on faisait des lives très sérieux
ça duré très longtemps bon bah là il y a
il y a F qui est venue ça y est quoi on
est
bienautre ça fait marrer
bizarrement ludwiig dit j'habite à
Munich suis-je allemand h ben je crois
de par Dieu est international de par
Dieu est russe
hein
donc il y a donc h rus au tournoi des
candidats
euh donc salut k salut
Fab si mvel jouer une grenfeld je me
saoule ouais franchement j'espère qu'il
y aura pas de greenfeld aujourd'hui hein
bah si enfin s'il y a des cas tuuras
greenfeld ça dit juste tuur pas des4
donc il y aura sûrement pas def mais il
y aura sûrement
C4 non je pense ou qu' F3 C4 ouais comme
ça il pousse C5
et donc début de tournoi rêvé pour mvl
est-ce que tu es d'accord ou pas
euh oui oui oui
complètement bah contre carwana c'était
pas la partie rvée mais bon nul c'est
logique et puis Victor coming c'est
c'est excellent quoi et après une petite
question est-ce que tu as du mal à te
réjouir du début du
tournoi à cause de enfin de Ding qui en
met forme avec le le le corona et de
tous les problèmes non mais ça fait un
truc complètement hors du temps en fait
tu as des milliers de morts chaque jour
dans le monde on est tous confinés chez
nous enfin c'est un l'ambiance est
spéciale quoi donc j'ai du mal à être
emballé à fond et à sauter partout pour
pour une partie d'échec mais euh bon
après tant mieux si ça se passe bien
mais juste tu vois j'ai pas la même joie
naturelle que en temps
normal mais moi
aussi j'ai envie de j'ai envie de j'ai
envie de te dire
justement tu as du mal tu as du mal à
être autant en joie quand tu as tous les
tous les problèmes autour
ouais bah tu es tu étais pas dans ton
état d'esprit normal quoi bon voilà
après bon bah Ding pas en forme même
c'est triste pour lui j'ai envie de dire
c'est un peu comme un sportif qui AR
blessé c'est génial lkenard qui il met
un petit cap donc c'est un troll mais il
dit Ding n'a aucun mental qu c'est ça tu
es nul quoi tes parents Meur tu tu es
affecté
connard non mais écoute non mais après
façon les joueurs ce qui arriv à faire
abstractionçon qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire d'autre façon tu es là-bas tu dois
jouer bah tu joues donc aucun reproche
en fait non ça c'est
sûr
vous avez vu sur le Twitter de qui dort
l'arbitre qui le réveille puis il se
rendor ça j'ai pas vu sur le Twitter
mais oui il a dit qu' dormi la partie
hier mais je pensais que c'était TR peu
il Dorma pas
réellement avait dormi une heure la nuit
il a vraiment dormi en
faitain il oui Vlad Vlad avait fait
beaucoup mieux que moi il avait perdu
autant dormant je n'ai pas encore
atteint ce de
perfectionnisme c'est beau aussi court
que flat ah bah ils sont pas cés pendant
si longtemps pour rien c'est beau quand
même c'est
beau c'est génial d tu n qu'un humain
avec des sentiments tu me
dégoûtes mais Vlad a perdu autant en
s'endormant Vlad vraiment vraiment
vraiment Vlad l'bite l'a réveillé lui a
dit non laisse-moi dormir
ê réveillé n'appartient pas à ce jour
ouis mais c'est beau quand même de enfin
c'est extraordinaire he de perdre une
partie en dormant quand même c'est
ouais non tout le monde dit que ma
caméra est flou ouais bon on sait mais
bon ben en même
temps pas faire grandchose
tu es flou c'est un flou artistique donc
ça va non mais en plus c'est c'est
semifou c'est semiflou enfin on est sur
du semiflou mais bon on rappelle que Fab
devait normalement être chez moi en ce
moment même justement pour être bien sûr
qu'on est bien la la connexion mais avec
les problèmes actuels ben on a décidé de
faire par internet bon au aurions n nu
aurions-nous dû prendre des risques pour
la santé de tous nos concitoyens pour
que la caméra ne soit pas flou on ne
sait pas Fab finalement bon ben je pense
qu'on a bien fait nous mais bon ah
peut-être tu viens Fab vient demain
je viens à can je viens à can non c'est
beau si je fais un petit certificat et
je coche une une case en plus je ne veux
pas avir la caméra floue tu te fais la
vidéo quoi je serais pas seul d'ailleurs
je viens avec mes 120 kg suis avec des
amis
sérieux serait tellement beau quoi je
viens
can pour que tu me casses pour que tu me
passes le corona tu l'as dit j'ai Captur
écran sont chez mon avocat quoi très
énervé
quoi et vous allez me voir dans la rue
il va pas avir va va falloir me crier
F je viens sans masque je suis un
samouraï vous êtes vraiment élitistes
les
mecs on a même pas parlé des parties du
jour d'ailleurs non on va parler pendant
6h donc ça
va alors on dit c'est commencé bah
écoute on va pour remettre les parties
alle c'est
parti bah
ouais alors D4 cavalier F6 C4 G6 k C3 D5
ah puis on prend puis on prend et k
prend et fout D2 ah fout D2 ouais bon
fout D2 l'idée c'est quand les Noirs
prendront C3 tu vis prendre du Fou et
pas de et pas d'ion c'est pas grave
comme coup c'est pas principal mais
c'est pas idiot donc sur fou G7 l'idée
c'est de faire E4 attends je montre
l'idée de la grenfel 2 secondes donc D4
cavalier F6 empêche E4 donc pour pas
laisser les blancs mettre de pions au
centre C4 G6 bon de toute façon tu
voulais pas faire E4 C3 bon là tu me
mettre les P au centre D5 je t'empêche
ouais mais manière passagère du coup je
te prends tu prends et là passagère tu
peux faire E4 Fab oui ben c'est le coup
d'ailleurs principal et il y a aucun
problème à le faire juste l'idée noir
donc c'est d'échanger de faire fou G7 et
de dire ok je vous ai laisser prendre le
centre mais je vais du coup vous
l'attaquer en faisant C5 en faisant C C6
bon on va rocker on va enlever la dame
mettre une tour en D8 et mettre toute la
puissance de feu sur le centre blanc
voilà donc il a il y a des BAT
là-dessus c'est c'est une ligne
complètement possible et il y a plein de
setup pour les blancs et pour les Noirs
aussi mais ça peut faire un genre de
placement de pièce comme je mets juste
un placement de pièce ou vas-y fais donc
en gros c'est pas du tout théorique ou
quoi mais genre de placement de
pièce mais euh Ji du coup il a fait fou
D2 ouais donc l'idée c'est que donc sur
fou G7
E4 prend C3 c'est plus prendre du pion
mais du Fou du coup tu as beaucoup plus
de mal à attaquer le centre parce que
sur un coup comme C5 tu peux prendre
d'habitude tu as un pion en C3 il a F
prend C3 en fait
ouais mais là tu as un fou en là IL3 tu
envie mais on garde le pion de plus et
cetera enfin en gros c'est l'idée c'est
un peu l'idée ouais voilà et et voilà et
il y M6 qui est-ce que E3 est possible
plutôt que4 alors tout est possible on
peut jouer avec E3 mais du coup c'est
tout de suite moins ambitieux mais c'est
possible que les noirs des fois les
Blancs jouent comme ça pour blinder le
centre et cetera mais du coup ils ont
pas pris le centre ce qui reste
normalement leur leur idée quoi mais il
y a plein de schémas jouaable en fait
c'estd sur D5 au 3è cou on est déjà même
pas obligé de le prendre ce P on peut
faire cavalier F3 on peut faire F F4 on
pe faire G5 on peut faire E3 E3
directire on pe faire H4 d'ailleurs
enfin ouais et on peut même faire H4 au
coup d'avant d'ailleurs
oui bah comme gritchou qui av joué plein
de fois et donc et donc fou d de et B
c'est une petite vente mais pas si
petite je veux dire ça il y a quand même
des milliers de parties dessus et je
sais que les no m très souvent en fait
n'échang même pas en C3 et partiront en
B6 avec le
cavalier peutêre le fou VI en E3 du coup
c'est ça les blanc ont perdu un temps
mais du coup tu as moins de problèmes
sur ton C cent aussi voilà donc c'est
c'est un autre type de position mais
quand même assez typique des des
grenfeld quoi on n demande est-ce que
vous pensez que Guiry a trouvé une
nouveauté contre Maxime dit Natsu 153
bah c'est clair qu'il est venu avec une
idée quoi il s'est il s'est levé ce
matin il s'est pas dit je vais faire
bûcheron quoi enfin non il a une idée il
une idée c'est sûr mais après laquelle
bah ça j'en sais rien et laquelle dur
dire mais d'ailleurs en fait c'est
bizarre qu'il est pas du coup tenté
cette idée dès la première rond contre
NPO à moins qu'il se souhaite bon NPO
peut-être pour les candidats il a eu 3
mois de prépa il a changé on sait pas ce
qu'il va jouer mais sur des4 ce sera pas
une greenfeld ouendre la surprise en
premier donc je vais plutôt faire le
truc alors que Maxime comme il a bon ben
lui on sait mais ouais c'est pas ça il
s'estêre dit ouais npau je le drible et
d'ailleurs il a bien driblé puisque dans
l'ouverture il était bien bon après
as-tu le niveau pour jouer les candidats
c'est la question qu'on se pose quoi non
mais pour le coup je crois que Guir il
joue moins bien que son niveau normal
pareil il est assz affecté aussi je
pense par un peu navaresque non comme
partie de sa part bah il a fait une
super prépa puis après niveau de jeu ça
a descendu
descendu comment peut-on jouer à ce
niveau mais oui il est affecté à mon
avis aussi par mais il y a pas mal de
joueurs à mon avis qui sont qui ne sont
pas affectés mais Maxime pour le moment
lui il a il a un mental d'acier non
Maxime il est bien et un autre joueur
que je trouve qui est complètement son
niveau c'est carwana ouais malgré les
difficultés qu'il a eu pour se déplacer
kwana a l'air dans son Maxime très bien
NPO je le trouve normal c'est que le
premier jour il a fait une super partie
c'était son type de position hier il a
un peu plus galéré contre gritchou mais
justement c'est le gen de position qui
joue moins bien en général
donc par contre car quand ils onont
commencer à lui prendre la Fiè 3 fois
par jour il va avoir flou hein non mais
c'est c'est un peu chiant si 37 il
trouvve que c'est
beaucoup mais 37 c'est pas juste normal
en vrai bah je pense quei donc il y a
des coups jou ouais bon c'est donc il va
prendre du fou mais donc c'est Maxim qui
l'a choisi c'est un truc complètement
normal aussi de jouer comme ça il va
attendre qu' F3 pour faire un fou G4
sûrement et et puis malgré tout presser
le
centre il va voir aussi flou que la cam
de de Fab bah oui c'est les Fabes quoi
donc ils vont voir fou tous les deux
quoi non mais tu commences à voir fou si
on vient de prendre la température tout
le temps enfin non mais en plus ça
t'inquiète ahah outre le côté chiant on
prend la température une fois deux fois
enfin ça va laissez-moi me préparer
laissez-moi dormir laissez-moi faire ce
que je veux
quoi laissez-moi vivre non mais en fait
je sais pas enfin faudrait juste qu'ils
a un test euh tu sais si tu as le corona
si tu l'as pas après tu peux avoir de la
température sans avoir le corona aussi
il faut ça existe
quoi tu peux juste être malade normal
quoi d'avoir une Rino un je sais pas moi
un truc est-ce que tu peux vérifier un
truc dans tes options sur ton micro s
change pas de dans le zoom si ton bah là
il est mise no là ouais non non pas ça
mais est-ce que tu peux aller voir dans
les dans les paramètres audio s'il
change s s'il se règle pas
automatiquement parce que j'ai
l'impression que parfois il augmente de
volume et il en baisse et paramètres
audio ok je suis dessus tu vas dans
microphone ouais je vois euh donc j'ai
tester le micro bon c'est le snowball et
j'ai le volume il est à fond ouais et il
ajuster automatiquement le volume ouais
ouais ça tu l'enlèves j'enlève ok BIM ok
nickel merci bah de rien euh ouais donc
sur fend C3 en général les noir
roin et donc genre C F3
logique bon ben pour se développer alors
on peut peut-être attendre faire fou de
d'abord ou justement on pe pas se
prendre fou G4 là c'est peut-être un
moment important d'ailleurs où il y aura
des des subtilités mais en gros ouais
donc sur Cali F3 les Noirs vont
développer le fr G4 et ensuite essayer
de jouer C5 quand même et cetera assez
classique euh pour le coup je suis pas
sûr que G va jouer avec K F3 il va
peut-être jouer un fou de un dame D2
n'importe quel coup qui qui contre un
peu ce genre d'idée ou peut-être un H4
ouais mais sûrement H4 c'est5 hein les
Noirs vont pas se laisser faire ils vont
vite jouer non mais gen peut-être qu'il
y a un H4 qui fait partie de la prépa
c'est plutôt ça oui un jour ou l'autre
tout à fait parce que genre tu peux
faire D5 fou bouff puis on bouffe et ok
ça peut représenter un danger quand même
non tout à fait là faudra jouer vite du
dame à 5 6 et réagir au centre parce que
si tu te laisses piétiner ça se passe
mal quoi mais ça peut faire partie de la
prépa non non mais gu de toute façon est
bien préparé et ça peut être dangereux
ce qu'il fait alors après il peut aussi
juste faire un test de mémoire et que ce
soit une nulle rapide si Maxime joue
tous les bons
truc C5 direct ouais
ok avait déjà été joué trois fois sur la
base de données de dragono 92 attends
ben je peux te dire c'est 5 direct moi
je l'ai 306 fois
donc il joué par Maxime lui-même en 2010
deux fois contre et contre
gratchef
euh gritu a joué avec les noirs carakin
a joué avec les Noirs Kazim douudda en
novembre dernier donc c'est un coup bon
c'est beaucoup moins populaire que Peac
mais c'est un
coup et en général les blancs font des5
ouais ça paraît logique d'échanger
d'échanger les fous hein bah de toute
façon là déjà ton pion des4 est attaqué
donc faut décider euh alors peutêre par
que des prend C5 le problème en fait
c'est qu'après
genre non mais ça paraît bizarre 3 prend
tu as juste les pion très
faibl juste ouais par exemple donc des
frçais c'est pas tellement une
option non mais D5 c'est juste
normal5 gen pr c j'imagine B pr alors
s'il y a ro ça va peut-être juste tomber
dans un truc normal mais peut-être qu'il
veut délayer le RO je sais
pas on va voir on va voir ce que
répond
je vérifie que ça marche bien sur
Youtube sil a fait des 5 ou ouis normal
je fais juste mon petit check technique
Fab je mon petit check
technique tac tac tac sur twitch c'est s
que ça marche c'est tout
vu et sur Youtube et je vais essayer de
le récupérer leur chat à YouTube aussi
histoire qu'il soit
heureux just ils sont là il demand VO le
chat bon normalement regarde que twitch
mais je vais jeter un œil quand même
donc
bonjour bonjour ouais je dis bonjour
quand même j'essé de jeter des petits
coups d'œil j'ai un peu de batterie sur
le téléphone pour le moment je peux
aller voir aussi moi ouais ça va bien se
passé bien se passer ne vous inquiétez
pas mon père dit que Guiry notre ami le
grand
gourou j'ai pas compris la
plaque alors attends bonjour Kevin et fa
je suis en télétravail et je regarde en
même temps il doit pas bosser il doit
rien Kevin non mais c'est
pourriez-vous SVP mettre les fiquets de
mvel en bas à droite ouais écoute on va
on va commencer à le faire pour le
moment on l'avait pas fait bah vu qu'on
est que sur cette partie pour l'instant
mais ouais c'est vra dès
qu'on regarde je suis tout à fait
d'accord et surtout que suite
à alors en fait chcom évolué suite à un
commentaire de l'élite de la nation
ouais par que l'élite de la nation il a
dit qu'ils aimeraient bien avoir la
petite jauge sur la partie de de Maxime
h pour voir les coups rouges et joues
qui vont dans le blanc dans le noir tout
ça exactement
et et du coup
suite à ce retour d'expérience élitiste
bah en fait tu tout chcom qui a bossé
pour le faire quoi ils ont dit oui
l'élite de la nation l'a
demandé hop ok donc ouais ça y est je
vois le chat YouTube sur mon téléphone
en même
temps et il y a Alexandre Villard il est
aussi en télétravail il a mis entre
guillemets quoi travail télétravail
ouais toute la nuance est dans le mot
travail c'est ça h le travail la chance
enfin ne faites pas trop les malins
parce qu'on va bientôt repasser au 39h
ils vont enlever une semaine de conget
payé ou ils vont enlever une semaine de
congé payé aussi on repasse à 4 mais
c'est pas que parce qu'il y a des
directs européenne hein sinon tu pass
non mais bon pour le coup c'est chiant
mais écoute faudra bien faire des
efforts vu que le bordel que ça moi je
propose de passer au 45 heur de travail
non mais du je sais pas enfin on sait
pas déjà combien de temps ça va durer le
truc la 4 enfin le confinement ah il t'a
dit ce matin qu'astaner enfin non le
ministre de la Santé à dit ce matin que
c'était très probable quand même qu'on
non mais c'est je sûr c'est même pas
probable c'est ça va durer de mois ça va
pas durer de semaines quoi et j'ai lu ce
matin un truc qui disait que ça ça
devrait commencer à bien se passer dans
2 mois c'est même pas 45 jours quoi
c'est 60 jours j ouais mais donc de mois
tu vois avec l'économie à l'arrêt tout
le monde qui s'arrête et cetera et
cetera évidemment que il y aura des
sacrifices des trucs à faire et ok
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on dise bordel
j'ai le
droit non mais on va gueuler parce qu'on
est français mais mais en fait c'est
rien de plus logique là je sa pas c'est
pas c'est pas pour favoriser un tel ou
un tel ou je ne sais quoi c'est c'est
juste en tout cas en tout cas moi je dis
ça je dis rien dame d de de de Guiry
c'est le coup de
FME non logique mais bon c'est quand
même ton coup enfin je sais PASF bon on
veut envoyer H4 d' H6 H5 et compagnie
quo alors petit point théorie je regarde
juste euh il sembl avec les Noirs deux
coups ici jouables E6 logique réaction
centrale ou dame D6 tu bloques un peu
les pions et tuévites de te faire rouler
dessus au
centre tu vois à CH il a fallu le corona
pourir canal plus gratos et télétravail
devant blit stream le bonheur absolu en
somme et d'ailleurs vu queil y a a canal
plus gratos on peut lâcher des
abonnements sur blit stream du coup oui
ça je dis rien en plus c'est moins cher
ouais et puis il y a
FEM du
coup un mec c'est fait un pseudo Fab
chess quoi c'est fantastique quoi je
pense qu'il des pseudos Fab qui vont
apparaîtreêre n'importe quoi avec de
chacun va mettre le plus de
possible mais c'est beau quand même
canal plus gratos et tu payes Canal Plus
en que pour le rugby et le foot quoi
c'est
gratuit regarde les films français que
tu as jamais eu envie de regarder tiens
je te les offre non mais c'était pas mal
je crois qu' ouais ils ont peut-être il
pourrai mettre des bons films comme
Avenger ou je sais pas attention quo et
moi je me demande si tu aurais pas faire
des des des des séries de pion isolé
gratos et tout pend le corona quoi bah
on essayera de faire des trucs là le
truc truc c'est com on a les candidats
on est déjà bien pris quoi c'est dur de
faire plus quoi non mais je même on
pourrait offrir on pourrait faire des
Aren déjà on voulait faire une Arena à
14h si vous êtes chaud mais c'est ça
pourit être pas bê de faire un petit
touram avec un pion isolé Auer pouroi
pas quoi beaucoup plus cher que Canal
plus beaucoup plus intéressantcoup plus
de valeur dans le tournoi quoi 17 he de
VL c'est quand Mme mieux que tout le
catalogue canal plus
réuni non mais c'est vra que pour le
coup bon je l'ai
finias et non très bien excellent ouais
tu as tuas tu as vraiment progressé dans
sincèrement tu as une vraie discussion
entre Reay quoi pas progressé je sais
pas si j'ai progressé mais j'ai appris
des trucs après il va falloir que donc
quoi qu'il en soit c'est intéressant de
d'apprendre de de comprendre des
subtilités de savoir des choses en plus
et puis ça peut donner envie enfin moi
ça me donne envie en tout cas de
d'essayer de jouer des positions de pion
isolé un peu plus fréquemment parce que
avec l'impression d'avoir compris des
choses et essayer de les mettre en
pratique mais je pense ça tu vois hier
quand il y avait la part partie de
wangao contre Guiri j' analysé avec
Romain et tu vois les plans genre le fou
G2 le mettre en B3 et tout j'ai j'ai
trouvé tempo ben je veux dire c'est plan
que je trouve normalement mais si c'est
une position que je maîtrise pas trop ou
quoi je vais peut-être mettre de 3
minutes et je vais y penser là j'ai t
tout de suite dit qu' E2 F4 fou E2 D1 B3
enfin fou F1 E2 D1 B3 alors qu'il y
avait le fou en G2 et un pu E2 F3 mais
tout de suite en fait j'ai su qu'il
fallait qu'il allit là-bas tu vois ce
que je veux dire faut faut attaquer le
pion quoi ouais et même quand Wang il a
fait C3 de cavalier F4 enfin j'étais
choqué même leur dis F4 première ligne
tu vois enfin j'étais là ENF ce coup ce
cahier n'appartient pas à cette case
quo mais non mais vraiment en fait fait
progresser profondément je pense ce truc
ouais nonis par en fait c'est quand même
assez fréquent qu'on a des au échecs
après tu peux avoir un répertoire pour
ne pas les avoir justement mais mais de
pouvoir se le permettre c'est quand même
cool
ouais ouais non c'est c'est bien mais
moi je préfère jouer avec que
contre
ouais bah ça
dépend mais bon moi j'avais un
répertoire j'ai quasiment jamais en
fait mon chapitre préféré reste quand
même celui sur la pouss F4 qui est très
souvent mauvaise que M Murtas joue pour
sa plus belle partie mais le fait
absolument pas
exprès tout en fait y avait à à B
introduit dans l'utou je sais pas quoi
toi tu es con tu ne t'en rappelles pas
mais on tu la partie de ta vie par
chance par pure chance quoi tu n'
absolument rien compris tu sais qu' il
avait joué tempo très fier de lui quoi
mais Dieu merci il a fait comme ça on
peut montrer ouais on peut montrer mais
ne vous ne vous trompez pas ne vous
trompez pas sur la qualité de cette
partie s'il vous plaît
quoi dire tu veux qu'on fasse un petit
tour voir un peu ce qui se passe
ailleurs
ouais vas-y c'est une bonne idée et
mettez un petit lien d'ailleurs vers le
vers le le la série de vidéo sur le pion
isolé qui ne sera pas euh achetable par
Paypal parce que c'est trop relou
Paypal alors oh une Française ah NPO en
plus on quand on av fait la vidéo tu
avais parlé de la française pour Nev
incroyable hein ouais mais
mais fallait fallait regarder
quoi donc
une win
ok donc du coup euh tu ok vent cage 4
c'est pas la grosse line mais ça c'est
intéressant ouais on va laisser se
développer petit à petit bah voilà qui
qui se développe non mais je veux dire
la partie oui tu peux revenir un peu si
tu veux bon ok 46 des 4 D5 ça on va pas
dire k C3 bon ok une des grandes lignes
et fou B4 donc ça c'est un des deux
grands coups avec K F6 donc on remet une
pression sur le centre E5 normal au
moins ça défend pion C5 B normal
pression au centre A3 on pose une
question au fou et comme ça après F
prend C3 B prend on défend le centre
l'autre coup F prend C3 c'est c'est x 5
qui est quand même beaucoup moins jou
arménienne
et ça très dangereux comme vari c'est
très fort mais surtout sur internet sur
Internet tourno bon moins fort
mais mais là Bull 15 + 2 c'est bienout
15+ la cadence plus c'est fort comme
vari proportionnellement aant que quoi
du coup du coup B4 général les blan
pour casser le clouage et avoir du C B5
qui arrive du dame G4 des choses comme
ça c'est c'est intéressant
ouais ok bon bon faut prendre TR c'est
normal B prend cavalier 7 coup de
développement OK et ce que font très
souvent les blancs la ligne principale
c'est Dame G4 ce qui a un coup normal
dans la française parce que quand le Fou
est parti on va attaquer un peu le les
pions par là-bas donc les noirs peuvent
rocker ils peuvent faire d'autres coup
d'ailleurs mais c'est principal ro F8
aussi ro F8
possible mais en fait stratégiquement
c'est hyper sensé parce qu'en fait ça
t'évite de te faire attaquer le roi et
ton idée c'est faire B6 x
6 mais en fait il y a plein de cas de
figure où les blancs ils vont faire un
truc pas terrible avec la structure à
faire du dprend C5 à un moment mais pour
vite ouvrir le jeu se développer et
ouvrir à fond parce que ton8 comme tu
par T8 elle va avoir beaucoup de mal à
rentrer en jeu et tu peux être un peu
débordé alors pas desess direct direct
mais à un moment quoi euh ouais donc en
général les Noirs rock et bon c'est
c'est possible ou alors l'autre coup sur
dame G4 si tu veux ne pas roquer c'est
Dame C7 tu as déjà dû voir des parties
comme ça dame prend G7 tour G8 dame
prend H7 c'est prend D4
ouais j'ai dam prend5 dame prend C3 donc
les blancs font plutôt cabalier 2 pour
au moins défendre là-bas puis on prend
C3 et c'est vite un gros bordel parce
que quoi il y a c'est bizarre compe
position c'est dur de se développer avec
les blancs mais tu as le pion h passé tu
peux le pousser très vite euh les Noirs
donc do jouer assez actif pour compenser
parce que les blanc en fait ils vont te
faire du dame D3 H4 H5 en quelques coups
c'est chiant donc les Noirs vite kc6
vite grand rock et euh position vite
vite chaotique donc ça c'est faut bien
connaître pour entrer là-dedans et je
sais pas donc si NPO aurait plutôt jouer
ça ou lesent avec petit rock ou du roi
F8 enfin dur à dire toujours éil euh il
a fait un autre choix il a fait H4 donc
l'idée de H4 c'est de prendre de
l'espace àer roi euh et de pousser H5 H6
pour aller affiblir les les cases les
cases noires alors fou B5 échec c'est un
coup typique dans ce genre de situation
alors peut-être dans cette position là
j'en sais rien je connais pas euh
typique pourquoi en fait les Noirs il
voulaaiit faire quoi il voulit faire x 6
et en faisant fou B5 échec tu attires
soit le fou en D7 à ce momentlà tu
retires ton fou mais il va plus venir en
A6 et il peut pas venir en B5
facilement soit tu couvres l'échec avec
le cavalier mais il va pas soutenir le
fou
A6 donc c'est un peu ça l'idée quoi et
si je mets ça
ouais ça c'est plus rare tout fait parce
que à mon avis euh quand 3 x 6 on va
faire
A4 en proc ou H5 je sais pas un coup on
ver euh x 6 A4 et mange mange déjà le KB
doit être en PLS le fou C1 pourra sortir
vers A3 on a la tour 1 qui du coup fait
pression sur la colonne et là-dessus on
peut faire peut-être H6 ou tour je sais
pas H4 ou même du roi F1 peutêtre
propylactique d'abord et je crois que on
très peu de je c'est dur de
jouer on va laisser la partie se
dérouler après5
ouais je pense qu'il va il va reculer
son
fou ça sembla logique mais donc qui se
passe dans situation c'est que des fois
les mett le A4 pour un peu
mettre blocage il
fait après les blanc peuventer 4 même
genre d' tout à l'heure
mais bon au moins il y aura toujours ass
6 pour repousser au cas où désolé désolé
de te couper un petit peu dans ton dans
ton élan juste il y a du nouveau côté
côté mvl c'est quand même ça qui nous
intéresse ouis c'est thorique en fait
ouais mais est-ce que tu peux nous
update un petit peu c'est Dame des de F4
c'est quoi pour bloquer F4 c'est le coup
principal je l'ai 19 fois dans la base
il y a plusieurs coups NPO jou E6 dans
cette
position il y a romain qui avaitou jouer
cette position en 2012 contre ryasonf il
a joué k D7 mais ça me semble dangereux
de se laisser prendre 5 est-ce que
ryasanf avait su partir ah il sait pas
mais k D7 en gros c'est l'autre option
c'est même le coup principal ici jouer
fois E5 jou 6 fois E6 jouer quatre fois
donc j'imagine sera un de ces coup là
qu'est-ce que je
dise en fait E5 ce que veulent les Noirs
après à voir s arrivent à mettre en
place c'est qui est pu on prend dame
prend et essayer de jouer un blocage sur
case noir donc on attaque 4 il a
sûrement F 3 et après essayer de mettre
le C en D7 en le 5 des choses comme ça
ok av voir si on y arrive vraiment
concrètement hein mais je veux dire
juste c'est ça l'idée de de jouer sur
case noire contre le fot de case blanche
aussi des blancs qui est un peu mauvais
par contre si les blancs arrivent à un
moment à chasser la dame et faire E5 eux
même ils font beaucoup
mieux peut-être faut faire fou G4 parce
qu'il faut faire cl je connais pas mais
il faut pas laisser les blancs faire c
F3 chasser ta dame te faire E5 et te
rentrer te défoncer quoi voà si tu fais
tout ça ça va donc ok ça tu nous as dit
on nous dit Fab il y a une énorme
nouveauté dans on a parlé de carwana euh
ok bon
euh c'est quoi c'est une slave c'est une
slave ok DC A4 F f55 E6 ok F3 ouais ok
fou B4 ok k C4 OK ROCK ok roi F2 ouais 5
c'est la nouveauté j'imagine et 5 c'est
la nouveauté ouais je vais aller checker
ça je vais vous dire euh je vais
regarder
euh je vais regarder si j'avais des des
trucs
dessus juste pour montrer on joue pas
EU4 direct qu' il prend E4 puis on prend
E4 et damage 4
échec c'est ça le problème et euh après
G3 il y a dame prend E4 et il y a une
fourchette et après roi E2 on va
continuer par fouer4 échecs en filade et
sur roi D2 dame prend le4 et les blancs
sont danger le roi reste au centre et
les Noirs ont une grosse initiative donc
c'est en fait l'idée après qu' prend C4
rock de secours roi F2 c'est de préparer
E4 comme ça sur k prend pion prend dame
prend on pourrait jouer euh G3 et la
dame sera attaquée donc E4 euh c'est la
menace ici je pense qu'avant on jouit C5
plutôt Fab plutôt que 5 euh attends je
de chercher un truc je vais te dire ça
tout de suite je pensense cétait plutôt
C5 le coup euh sur F2 ouais
euh écoute mais je je connais pas des
masses en fait ce truc si tu regardes
dans la base je crois que c'était C5
regard dans la base mais du coup je
juste regarder je crois que c'était C5
le coup et là il fait5 alors l'idée
c'est tout ouvrir mais il doit être
super bien préparé c'est sûr car il
rigole pas et j'ai envie de te dire
c'est une grosse nouveauté face à un
Ding en difficulté fa dans ce tournoi
bah oui parti et donc je pense non mais
je pense c'est très bien joué de jouer
un truc double tu vois double double
lame un giletit le
je sais pas si c'est pas jouable
d'ailleurs le
le4 tout suite E4 il y a pas cavalier
bouffe si mais c'est un truc normal toi
tu as tris pour la pièce c'est c'est
mais il y a pas de grosse compensation
non mais c'est Jo mais c'est pas des
grosses compensations quand même mais du
coup k prend C4 si non c'est que ça joue
long terme mais je crois qu'il y avait
une partie où Baky avait battu un il y a
longtemps imp
possible r C F2 donc ok j'ai mis la base
Ctait pas C5 le coup sur F2 C5 joue
principal et 5 nouveautés a juste
complètement C5 ouais mais hyper logique
c'est 5 5 nouveautés
ok du coup je vais te mettre lil là voir
si tu parle de 5 direct ah du coup ça ça
va en parler dans la dans le débrief de
Cornetto dans le déb de Cornetto à
fond c'est c'est un gros truc c'est sûr
que 5 c'est alors pour l'instant Lila il
en parle
pas juste au début et donc je le fais
juste pour voir son évaluation mais si
mais Ding ent difficulté enfin je sais
pas Ding qui réussit plus à réfléchir
Ding qui qui chute aujourd'hui en fait
il peut l'enterrer hein parce queà 0 sur
2 tu as encore une micro chance de
revenir à 0 sur 3 non mais il a il va
parevenir en fait sais juste où il finit
dans le tournoi est-ce que combien il
perdent parti en fait la question mais
en fait si tu le bats avec les Noirs
maintenant en plus tu peux être très
heureux dans le sens où tu vas avec les
Blancs après peut-être il blindera il
essaiera de faire que des nuls et de
sortir du tournoi comme il le peut et
juste tu le tu tu tu Carana là il peut
il peut faire mal contre il est
combattive Ding parce que il aurait pu
faire une slave d'échange un truc pour
faire nul il joue quand même donc c'est
tout à son honneur de d'avoir cet
orgueil là j'ai envie de dire de pas
prendre les blancs et juste faire nul
mais euh mais en tout bien tout honneur
ça peut être quand même assez dangereux
non mais j'aurais pas fait mais
moi j'aurais essayé de faire une petite
nul non mais un moment il faut juste
stoper l'héoragie et puis tu essayer de
te remettre et puis peut-être ça ira
mieux parce que 14 rondes c'est long et
on verra mais euh non mais tu imagines
tu imagines le coup de grâce de Ding tu
repèes tu es à Z0 sur 3 les mecs
viennent te prendre la température quoi
ENF
ça c'est sûr qu' vont lui la prendre oui
mais dégage en
fait deux fois toi d'ailleurs problème
c'est qu' faudrait avoir un énorme ordi
pour comprendre ce que carwana il veut
euh parce que 5 tu peux faire 5 quand
même qui logique je pense que Mathieu a
déjà tout analyser
mais il faut vraiment un grosord enfin
oui ou non mais avant déjà je
connaissais déjà ENIT en fait j'avis
déjà dans la base bon j'ai mis stock
fish j'essaie de monter un peu les trucs
je pense sur k pr 5 ce qu'il veut c'est
F de on nous dit que c'est théorique le
5 non c'est théorique c'est une
nouveauté quoi après oui c'est théorique
oui tout peut-être d' près ma ah
peut-êre par la partie de Max ou donc il
5 ah mais 5 de de Maxime oui c'est
thorique bon d'ailleurs il a joué 6
c'est génial quoi excuse je te coupe
mais il y a romainch qui dit Matthieu
avait prévu de jouer ça contre les
viewers quoi
ch déjà nouveuté mais j'aurais pu jouer
contre
sur mais le
truc veut
c'est parce
que donc d D et peutêtre C5 un truc
comme ça pour tout ouvrir et profiter du
Roos mais du
coup
marche ouais non c'est chaud mais ça va
être ce genre de truc en fait je peux
pas vous dire exactement quoi mais ça va
ressembler à ça ça va être un truc hyper
concret de carwana est-ce que tu as
pensé à lancer des analyses de parties
sur un Cloud plutôt que d'investir dans
un gros ordi alors il y a quand même un
problème avec ça Netizen c'est que tu as
peur de te faire hacker qu'il a des gens
qui puissent voler tes prépas c'est pour
ça qu'il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui
veulent pas utiliser le Cloud
ouais bon moi ça me dérangerait pas on
peut me haer mes prépas on peut me les
haer quoi ça c'est pas très grave mais
oui pour les joueurs de l'élite va mieux
que so confidentiel
quoi non
ok intéressant je pense fa revenir
dessus mais là disons il y a beaucoup de
choix parce a même des pr 5 qui est une
option là il a tout tout est jouable
euh voilà E4 faut voir est-ce que il va
un sacrifice sur
E4 pe tu prends des4 juste
ouais je sais pas oui mais mais bon ok
tu as quand même le roi à poil et c'est
quand même bizarre mais donc il y a trop
de truc super concret pour expliquer en
fait je je sais pas je suis désolé c'est
dire ce qui va se passer non mais là ils
ont très concrètement avec des super
méga gros ordinateurs ils ont analisé
pendant au moins une dizaine d'heur
c'est juste mais Carana il a mis sa team
dessus ils ont analisé comme des fous il
a dû faire des Blitz pour se chauffer
sentir la position et faire des parties
d'entraînement et et c'est un gros
avantage de connaître la position par
rapport à Ding donc ça fait déjà un
quart d'heure de réflexion il connaît
pas et il a le cerveau ralenti pendant
ce tournoi donc c'est c'est le moment
pour lui d'avoir une surprise si rapide
au 9e coup tu vois moi c'est ça que je
kiffe chez chez Fabiano Fabiano c'est
que enin il est quand même hyper
principal comme joueur non il est très
principal il te enfin tu vois le boulot
quoi derrière tu vois ça ça prê pas
enfin elle était pas torché en 10
minutes quoi c'est je trouve que c'est
beau de jouer comme ça c'est un peu à la
Garie quelque part je trouve non non
mais c'est c'est un beau joueur
Fabiano charismatique
charismatique un peu beau mais un peu
même quelque part ouais même un peu beau
mais bonf vraiment quelque part quoi de
très loin non mais c'est je trouve que
c'est les échecs qu'on aime de voir des
coups comme 5 des grosses nouveautés
comme ça et après de voir les analyses
de Corneto et tout
dessus parce que c'est il crée quelque
chose c'est là c'est de l'art si tu veux
c'est c'est du Picasso quoi bah c'est
les échecs que j'aime ça franchement
c'est je kiffe tu vois 5 j'espère que
Mao mettra une grosse ce soir voilà pour
juste pour 5 déjà plus de quoi qu'il en
soito attends est-ce qu'il est dans le
chat Mao quand il dans le chat on lui
dira quoi mais mais mais ouis il gagne
de points quoi non s' gagne avec les
Noirs en ayant jou 5 je pense qu'il
mérite le 10 ce soir non 10 c'est dur 10
c'est
jamaisquip c'est combien de fois FO
moins de 10 fois peut-être je sais pas
ah tu peux avoir au moins 9 et demi tu
dois avoir un demi c'est grosse nouveuté
5 j'ai déjà vu des joues mett des
quadrupl avoir
non mais tu peux avoir 9 et demi non je
pas même Zizou contre le Brésil en
2006 mat de fou 7
et vraiment mériter ta grosse note gagne
contre le numéro 3 mondial avec les
Noirs en sortant cette nouveauté tu
mérites quand
même alors
j'imagine regardé on pas grand chose
mais j'ai regard ce que Racon stish tout
ça et
donc donc peut-être C de et
ouais c'est un gros truc mais sinon pour
revenir dans l'ouverture c'est juste
avant si si les gens veulent un mini
débrief donc Slav TC3
euh pardon pardon non non il a pas de
souci ouais donc despan c'est le coup
principal mais bien sûr il y des autes
coup comme toi tu jou 6 oui triangle
despr pas mal bon l'idée des Noirs c'est
de renforcer le pion par B5 d'avoir un P
de plus donc les blancs jou a 4 logique
fou F5 coup de développement bon on va
sortir le fou avant de faire e 6 normal
aussi même si même si euh un gros coup à
la mode c'est E6 et faire C5 après bon
ça dans le D Vlad justement c'est très
très ouais tu veux retransposé dans tes
Gambi dam accepté ù tu as perdu un temps
mais l'autre a fait A4 et le pion A4 du
coup est pas très bien placé parce que
le cavalier peut venir en B4 en fait
chaque fois que vous provz A4 mais c'est
pas que dans cette position c'est
toujours aux échecs ça vous donne la
case à B4
ouais donc dessus cl il a fait E5 qui
est une des vent possible l'autre c'est
juste de faire E3 il y a E4 aussi ah non
pas ici E4 c'est à la place de la 4 non
mais sur fou F5 en fait de toute
façon euh A4 fou F5 ouais euh ouais donc
ici d'habitude c'est E3 le grand coup
mais qui5 complètement
jouable pour aller récupérer le pion et
justement on pour essayer peut-être de
jouer avec F34 et donc carwana a choisi
de jouer avec E6 qui est une option mais
tu peux aussi faire juste k BD7 as plein
C7 pour
faire5 tu sais d'Ille qu'elle était le
premier nom de l'ouverture
slave non russe tu vois tck tck c'est
l'ouverture check
ok il a fait F3 bon ben il veut faire E4
et justement la fou B4 qui rendre un
truc très compliqué parce que E4 il y a
faut sacrifier la pièce dessus
et c'est le
bordel je monte les cours sur G ouais
ouais ouais mais faut pas faire ça faut
se dquer en
fait non attends on l' fait au mauvais
moment c'est pas à ce momentl non non
mais44 F prend4 normalement prend 4 pr
prend 4 i non mais je me suis
trompé mais c'est compliqué quoi enfin
c'est je ve dire que le cavalier
prendamage 4 c'est une fois qu' a eu
prend C je suis planté et là il y a
peut-être G3
il y a G3 tu prends prends tu prends
unin il fait G4 bordel
ok ouais c'est plutôt bien pour les
blanc en fait pour coup et c'est
peutêtre d prend des 4 non Jeur dit qu'
d prend des 4 ici ouais c'est plutô d
prend des 4 que damage 4 et dame prend
des4 tu fais prend 4 dame prend4 dame 2
et tu joues la finale mais bon
normalement les jou pas la finale mais
bon il la joueront un
jour mais ouais c'estqu des de prend des
de d D5 tu de ton donc du coup il a fait
qu' prend C4 rock et là sur E4 c'est là
que c'est qu' prend E4 sur on prend4 d
H4 ça on l'a déjà vu et ouais et donc ro
F2 écoute intéressant comme comme coup
qui a déjà été joué plusieurs fois et
qui est pas con c'est pour pour jouer
avec E4 justement sans les clouage tu
peux aussi jouer fou G5 F2
développer tu as le droit et donc voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on ob Sion bizarre
assez vite mais c'est explicable voilà
le cheminement pour arriver à la ouais
intéressant du coup Fab il jouer depuis
il ait fous de ouis assez vite non ou il
plus 4 non mais il va tout connaître il
va le déballer c'est et désagréable
comme
sensation juste je je mets la partie de
GR je met rapide parce que j'ai envie de
retourner un peu sur mvl quoi ah une P
ou on avait pas encore vu du tournoi ça
y est alors qu'est-ce qu' il joue avec
D3 D5 ah mais il va en déchange la
française du coup ouais c'est pas qui
qui va être content avec Dame 2 du coup
d'accord fou 6 le meilleur
ah mais c'est la même partie que Max
contre comment il s'appelle Andre Kin
ouais mais est- qu'il va vraiment
obtenir quelque chose grich bah écoute
c'est pas censé tu tu vas te prendre au
5 en général quoi il doit avoir une idée
quelque part hein une idée hein c'est
pas en plus il joue vite donc il a une
idée je sais pas où mais si joue vite en
plus ça va te mettre en PLS
quoi comment c'est possible quoi le mec
ne s'est pas
endormi il a il est encore 1 he 40
comment c'est possible quoi alors
attends Guiry ça part ça va vite quoi gu
gu gui F4 max donc il a pas voulu faire
laer5 il a fait
E6 ouais tu protèges euh B5 chasse le
fou fou prend B5 e prend D5 et le fou
qui revient en C4 attends du coup je
vais regarde
la théorie un peu donc attends juste
essayer de comprendre il se passait quoi
sur dame prend D5 il voulait sûrement
juste décaler la
dame la tour A8 est pas commestible par
qu'il a fou B7 on enferme la dame et sur
dame D3 par exemple pour repartir parce
que sinon il y a fou B7 tour8 qui peut
arriver
ok il fait tour D8 et en gros tu as un
pion de moins mais tu as énormément
d'activité donc ça c'était l'idée de Max
genre dame 2 à vrai dire le roi est pas
pas développer le cavalier non plus
c'est encore au noir de jouer tu peux
même jouer un coup comme C4 tu touvres
les diagonales tuouvrees tout et et tu
vas te développer ok c'est ça semble
dangereux pour les blancs donc encaisser
le pion en D5 ça semblait très dangereux
immédiatement prendre du pion tu touvres
la colonne et après cavalier D7 pour
obstruire la la diagonale du fou tour E8
va arriver c'est peut-être dangereux
même si peut-être jouable cavalier2 qui
est
B6
mais la position qu'on a sous les yeux
enfin de de la de la partie donc avec C4
c'est ça a déjà été joué mais c'est plus
logique de revenir en C4 avec le foot
c'est de faire fprend des 5 de renforcer
du coup le pion E4 et de tenter cavalier
F3 rock quoi ouais euh ça a déjà été
joué et c'était une partie thomasevski
NPO
2018 à vu d'œil ça s bloqué pour les
Noirs ça s blooké parce que dans la
partie je peux dire ceil y avait eu un
épo a joué fou B7 ici il protège un le
pion F3 tour D8 etchange massif en
D5 mais massif de chez massif est changé
à la fin tour
dès
vitee n
coupchang ça peutre comme
ça qui s super forme qui t une
variante
souvient plus
mon avis c'est un scénario très probable
mais bon à moins que bien sûr il peut
avoir une idée à un moment j'en sais
rien et merci à nolyn pour le sub sur la
chaîne merci Tonton merci
super donc ça c'est un peu un peu à
l'ouverture ce que je te propose c'est
qu'on prenne enfin une petite
respiration pas une pause he mais tu
vois qu'on regarde un peu le chat qu'on
lise un peu on vient de faire qume une
grosse demi-heure de théorie et voir un
peu ce que ça raconte ouais on nous dit
n incipide Cyril on va voir hein euh non
mais ça je suis pas sûr c'est juste
c'est possible
a c'est génial quoi fa au commentaires
et de nouveau une nulle rapide quoi mais
c'est beau quoi à chaque fois que tu
viens il y a des petites
nulles ça sera un bon résultat après
avec les Noirs c'est un bon
résultat maître yoyo 200 g qui nous dit
le pauvre Ding il me fait pitié quand
même bah non mais c'est triste pour lui
en fait de tu es hyper bon tout le temps
tu es tu es un vainqueur potentiel du
tournoi et et tu peux pas jouer il se
passe quoi si on pousse D4 ici question
de Black TF alors D4 je sais pas mais
mais le problème en fait c'est que tu
vas avoir un pion faible en fait gen
unon5 dame B6 bouf bouf et cavalier F3
quelque chose comme ça ouais ok par
exemple je sais pas si c'est le M
mettons puis tu roes tu fais tour D1 tu
bloques le P si tu veux tu te le fond D5
aussi faut pas oublier que tu as des
problèmes sur case noire donc avec ce
pion E5 c'est toujours chiant parce que
kg5 K4 ça peut ça peut arriver et
alors forcément ce qu'on veut quoi c'est
peut-être jouable mais ça a l'air quand
même vachement plus simple de faire le
le fou D7 fou B7 pardon t D8 et de de
juste aller aller manger le pion quoi en
D5 mais c'est un pion isolé mais c'est
un passé isolé c'est différent non mais
ça rien à voir enfin oui c'est isolé
mais mais il est passé donc c'est plus
non mais en fait si tu as ce genre de
truc tuas envie que le pion e soit E2
chez les Blancs
[Musique]
ouais une fois qu'il est parti là-bas
devant c'est autre chose quoi pour ça
que qu'il est
passé donc mais
euh non faut c'est juste hyper logique
je sais pas exactement TR qui dit qu'
qu' alternative pour les Noirs dans
cette position s'il ne veut pas tout
échanger éviter la nul rapide mais en
fait quand tu as les noir c'est quand
même ton objectif de base de tout
échanger de faire nul donc c'est pas une
question qui peut se poser dans cette
position quoi quoi donc si jamais Maxime
il veut éviter de tout échanger et jouer
le gar à fond mais ah non non en plus il
a pas de raison de le faire enfin
objectivement tu es pas mieux avec non
plus en fait faut pas se suicider he
enfin c'est mais donc il y a il y a
Albert qui je sais pas on pense que tu
trolles en fait par que E4 à6 ton
ça aucun intérêt quoi enfin c'est juste
idiot ouais au premier coup enfin c'est
c'est même pas une question en fait
c'est juste
mauvais alors certes miles a gagné une
fois contre carpof ou quoi donc s en
fait c'est pas assez mauvais pour être
perdant mais c'est juste mauvais pour
être moins bien
quoi ça fait juste pas tu te développes
pas tu prends pas le centre donc ça fait
juste pas de
sens euh BR dit quand tu espè gagner les
candidats pas sûr que viser la nulle
avec les Noirs soit un bon plan bah si
en fait bah si en général les candidats
gagn plus 3 franchement plus 4 non mais
comment tu
veux comment tu veux jouer la gagne avec
les Noirs si ton adversaire veut te
sécher et faire nul en fait tu peux rien
faire bah tu peux te sucider mais c'est
débile non mais si c'est la dernière
ronde que tu as besoin de gagner on
verra mais là pour l'instant si gérer le
tourno normalement tu essaie de gagner
quand tu peux et c'est
tout alors pourquoi pas fou e 6 en F 6
doit être jouable aussi je pense
ouais mais il est moins bien placé qu'en
B7 mais en B7 juste tu gardes la colonne
ouverte et tu tapes sur la diagonale il
est juste mieux
ici non parce que dans l'éventualité où
les blancs s'amusent à jouer avec du E5
ou quoi ton fou il est mis en B juste
ouais tu pourras faire du dame C6 par
exemple puis un moment tu auras
peut-être D4 ou tu auras un truc le
contr cette diagonale alors que le F E6
euh il va être amené à se faire taper
par du K F3 k G5 peut-être il a un F5 à
moment avec tempo enfin et puis il est
bloqué par ses propres pions donc moins
bien placé moi il n'appartient pas à
cette
case c'est bien tu réponds comme Vlad
quoi pourquoi pas fou 6 le fou
n'appartient pas à cette
case mais du coup est-ce que sur fou B7
parce que à vrai dire la noir menacer on
pourrait faire un cavalier F3 non mais
on peut mais D8 oua et alors ou d' c'est
ce qu'il avait fait oui pardon il faut
pr des C c'est là qui a tout échangé
excusem il un échange après 5 c'est la
tentative pour les blancs de garder des
pièces mais est-ce que est-ce que est-ce
que tu te sens mieux avec les blancs ou
pas je sais
[Musique]
pas bon on va
faire7 je sais pas c'est jouable ça pour
les de peut-être qu'il a une idée avec
du H4 ou des trucs mais faut voir parce
que D4 ça va arriver ok c'est peut-être
jouable ça mais c'est plutôt les blancs
qui ont le choix de jouer plus que les
Noirs ouais non mais gu ça il est pas
obligé de tout échanger en D5 comme
Thomas a
fait pas du
tout Salut Bonjour à
toi4 toujours là qui REP le 201 mais un
autre c'est comme un autre système de
départage maintenant fait tu joues un
match
donc oé de gagnerme PR parce que
avec départage dans tour à l'époque il a
été second quoi qu'il
arriveig de tout donner per s passé
al merci à J solo qui a pris un
abonnement niveau 1 merci Tonton merci
merci c'est chat
solo
j'adore hier on était dégoûté quand
c'était pas cétait chîn quoi ouis mais
bon il y a un blitz quoi dans le
truc faut que tu apprennes à jouer avec
en faitutour de
Blitz Flori salut les tontons ne peut
pas perdre contre gu quand même son seul
palmarè c'est de se faire clasher par
Magnus ah il écrit quand même deux fois
quoi tu aurais écrire merde quand
même bravo pour lauge de position sur le
petit c'est vraiment super c'est grâce à
l'élite c'est vre
suggestion su vra que c'est bien c je
trouve pour les gens qui suivent qui se
connectent tu
vois VO il tu sais quoi tu as le
droit plus
ha
non c'est s pas ou trs comme tu le sens
non mais je suis heureux de la Jae ti je
déplace versite technique de niveau
quoieas MV petit drapeau en tu es
heureux
quoi tu es
heureuxour voir ce qui se passe ailleurs
juste
pour bon il a mis le FO à4 nepo et le
con D7 il je tout tempo ouais bah c'est
NPO c'est beau quoi hier il 1 heure
d'avance
1h10 c'est incroyable il continue
toujours de faire les même trucs mais
pas mal le K DESC pourquoi pas en fait
on va voir il se réserve le droit de
faire sprender et d'avoir la pression
sur la
colonne en C6 à te bloquer moi je sais
qu'il va la gagner contre Alex NP il va
le mal autant et il va l'arnaquer
non mais là il y a un truc bizarre dans
ce qu' fait avec seno c'est dequeet plus
H4 je sais pas c'est tu j H4 en gér pour
faire H5 H6 et que ta tour coulisse par
par la colonnage quoi et les deux
ensemble c'est bizarre parce que là en
fait tu ver tuas le pion H2 tu auras
fait un autre
coupêre plus logique je sais pas on va
voir mais bon on verra comment ça se
passe il y a rien de fait mais NPO NPO
surprise de jouer la française
et écoute pour l'instant il s très
bien
Ding fou C2 dame D2 C5 temp on est
toujours là ce que je te'avais dire non
mais il va suer
enfin ça tellement le truc en fait donc
les modules il donnent avantage blanc
mais c'est des modules de merde quoi non
mais clairement avec 40 CPU ou je sais
pas quoi qui qui tourne à des vitesses
de fou donc après c'est quand même
possible que les blancs soient
objectivement mieux s'il trouvent tous
les meilleurs coups je sais pas mais
euh à mon avis l'évuation elle est
beaucoup moins haute ah non c'est
chaud donc t dis l'chiquier est pas
centré attends qu'est-ce j'ai entendu
dire les chquer il est pas centré avec
la barre qui sépare vos deux cames ah si
il est centré avec les barres qui
séparent les deux cam ah en fait il veut
dire que la barre elle est en e et to
elle dorait être entre E8 et D8 quoi
ouais par rapport à ça qui est pas
centré ouais parce qu'en fait c'est
centré différemment c'est centré sur un
autre truc on peut centrer comme ça
aussi
donc là les ch est très centré mais par
contre du CP le truc en générale vers
chez moi ouais par rapport à ça c'est
mal centré on sait pas on sait pas ce
qui doit être mieux
centré mais là du coup je trouve que
c'était mieux centré avant en fait parce
que en fait là cétait le vrai centrage
par rapport au truc complet non c'est
mieux comme ça tu fais comme tu as
envie des gens sur Youtube qui disent
qu'on l que sur twitch mais oui ça c'est
on vous avait averti en fait on essaie
de regarder des fois mais mais on lit
principalement le chat de de twitch oua
ça il faut
beouser les
chi alors merci
Vic
donc franchement les mecs on s'en bal
ouais non vraiment donc bon ça c'était
ça c'était ça et Gricha et Gricha ça ça
va faire une nulle insipide non bah je
comprends pas ce qu'il veut mais on
verra on retourne sur Max ouais
euh ouais donc car ça pas bouger NP
machin et Max ok il a fait F B7 ouais il
a fait ok ben il répète du coup et
maintenant la B est dans le compte de
Guri soit
il bon B c'est après tour des8 on verra
B mais tour il va jouer de toute façon
ouais je veux dire c'est après tour de
H8 soit il échange massivement et c'est
une petite nul n soit il joue ave que 5
et on
verra au moment je comprends pas si les
compétion suffisent s'il prend en D5
alors c'est pris en D5 pris en D5 pris
en D5 prix en D5 prix en D5 ouais tu du
Tour 8 tour 4
peut-être roi D2 qui D7 on va mettre le
cavalier en B6 on va attaquer les cases
et on va récupérer des5 en fait
ouais et il y a du tour 4 aussi qui peut
RER camali B6 mais je dire ouais tu vois
dès qu' C4 en fait tour 4 ça sera une
double attaque bon toute façon C4 dur à
faire
mais et
oui non mais les blancs si si s'il veut
se montrer ambitieux il va il doit pas
prendre en des 5
ouais on va voir on va voir c'est pour
ça que c'est intéressant de sur la
partie parce que si a tour des 8 et puis
on prend des 5 la FAB on peut dire que
la nul est c'est là que ça se joue Fab
ouais c'est là bon T8 çaêtre le coup
normal bon même peut-être jou T8 semble
quand même plus logique et ouais soit5
soit prend nul nul et donc pour répondre
aux gens sur Youtube
ouais vous pouvez vous créer un compte
twitch pour parler dans le chat après
vous pouvez juste suivre sur twitch sans
sans parler mais si parler faut créer un
compte mais c'est c'est gratuit
ouais nous on essaie de répondre au
maximum à tout après c'est difficile de
faire multilateforme de lire tous les
chats de tout lire quoi
enfin tout ouais Michel il dit on mange
quand les tontons bah écoute nous on a
moi j'ai mangé à 11h30 hein
ouais moi j'ai mangé toi aussi tu t'es
fait quoi poulet haricot non euh je fait
quoi je me suis fait une petite salade
verte bon tranquille et euh des euh les
frites
de de Patat douces ah c'est bon ça
ouais j'essaie de progresser à les faire
en fait parce que tu vois j'essaie de
les faire au four mais elles sont pas
toutes aussi croustillantes enfin c'est
c'est pas évident tuis c'est plus simple
de les les dans l'huile à la
poêle quoi je TR ou à la friteuse mais
mais bon j'essaie de faire au four pour
être plus sain quoi pas manger que de
l'huile ça tu as encore beaucoup de
réservve niveau fruits
légumes bon faudra bien que je ressorte
T ou tard hein mais bon on verra quand
plus tard
possible ça fait ça fait ça fait 4 jours
que j'ai pas mis le nez dehors mais je
te dis moi demain ouais moi que sur mon
balcon mais demain je vais faire un
petit tour à pied pour la santé du
cigare je vais pas faire longtemps je
faire 10 minutes mais je vais le faire
quand
même parce que là ça faut que je marche
un petit peu quoi bah ou bah oui pas
atopier les muscl aussi
je suis fait un peu du vélo d'appart ce
matin on marche autour de chez soi et on
se sent
marathonien ça les hommes et la bouffe
ouais bah ou on parle bouffe on parle
échecf c'est no sujet préféré
quoi pharmaen je dis pas sortir du tout
mais vraiment juste rester h des groupes
et tout mais moi ce que je vais faire
demainel TR en fait ouais que je vais
faire je fais peut-être le chat aussi un
petit peu dans un premier temps pour
qu'il change lui de
trottoir et après si jamais il le fait
pas je change le trottoir enfin je fais
comme les chats en fait mais d'ailleurs
je promenis le chien je sais plus quand
je vois un mec courir j'ai eu super peur
je suis parti en face quoi et tu as fait
le chat ou pas non j'ai rien fait bon ça
va il a le droit de courir
mais mais ça ça m'intéressait pas du
tout de le croiser quoi
ouais tu tu en sûr face h face à l'homme
et boulangerie tu es allé ou pas non non
non mais j'ai pas envie de croiserfin
je veux croiser personne en fait c'est
ouais moi non plus en fait je suis pas
la boulangerie non plus je sais pas siil
a du monde en fait ENF je suis curieux
mais tu sais j'arrive bien à regarder de
loin enfin passer pas loin quoi essae de
ouais ouais envoie un petit drone quoi
se balader ah k
7 euh nouveauté thorique pour le
coup alors on va imaginer
rock aller B6 attaque le fou
ouais il va repartir on fou bouge tour
D8 comme ça il peut mettre la a ok bon
faire 55 maintenant forcé dame quelque
part ok on peut avoir ce genre de
position et euh
écoute c'est chaud ça ça joue pour la
peine ça joue mais je sais pas si le B
c'est si bien en fait parce qu'il est un
peu loin de drit ve dire que c'est mieux
A5
non mais en F8
ou en H5 ouais voilà H5 super non mais
H5 en plus d'ailleurs très bien par
ranger
comment améliorer la position de ce
cavalier excuse fa quoi il est parfait
il est parfait non mais je crois que je
trouvais pas si mal parce que là
peut-être d F5 ça peut partir du coup
peutêtre on peut faire dame D7 disons
oui plus dur de faire F5 mais on va y
arriver on va en le cavalier on va à à
vue de à vue de Mau ça me paraît un peu
dangereux pour les Noirs enfin un peu
mieux pour les blancs pas dangereux un
peu mieux pour les blancs ouais bon faut
voir si k B c'est forcé en fait après
rock au
16e ouais mais on va voir mais Maxime
qui joue pas la enfin qui joue pas la
nul est-ce qu'il a fait K d 16 qui se
rappelait pas tour des8 est-ce que tour
des8 il a eu peur de la finale non mais
tu peux pas avoir peur de la finale B il
y a juste rien en fait
ok admettons
comment peur de quoi je sais pas qui mon
non d'accord
mais tuas pas
peur non je pas un truc mais n a pas eu
peur en tout cas et moi si je vois ça
pas fou tient les cas avec le Mura
donc le roi va pas monter pour l'instant
on a la tour pour colmater si tu fais
tour1 pour rentrer j'ai F8 t D1 tuas pas
la 7è
rangée alors j'ai l'impression que ça
doit aller quand même mais est-ce qu'il
a pu est-ce que tu peux avoir peur d'une
finale comme ça non impossible non mais
je pense pas qu'il peur juste il doit
penser que ça va très bien ou peut-être
qu'il est justement assez ambitieux et
qu'il joue pour plus que juste tout
échanger ou alors il a pensé que sur
tour des8 je pens c'est pas donc la
finale qui pouvait lui faire peur sil a
peur d'un truc mais que E5 ou quoi il
s'est dit oui peut-être quelque chose je
sais pas tour D1 genre et cavalier toute
façon tu vas bien jouer CAV un jour B
mais mais ok pe-ê s dit dans cette
position c'est plus malin de d'avoir
l'utre tour ou je sais pas mais je sais
pas enfin c'est un truc comme ça en fait
ça a pas l'air du tout idiot qui DESC
quoi qu'il en soit euh juste à voir
comment ça se passe ensuite si est blanc
arrive à enclencher E5 F5 5 parce qu'on
rappelle si la position va se bloquer
comme ça on s'en fiche mais si tu
arrives à faire F5 et que tu as dam H6 k
G5 c'est juste mat
quoi en H7 parce que oui par tuas plus
tout de case noire et et ça peut être
chiant donc faut faut quand même être
sur le qui vive côté noir parce que le
roi noir est plus
faible c'est pas
faux c'est pas faux c'est bon c'est une
partie qui est partie pour jouer en tout
cas c'est pour notre plus grand plaisir
ici 13h j'ai envie de dire premier
pointage Fab ça joue ouais euh ouais
ouais mais bon si ça joue je casse la
légende des nul en coup quoi c'est un
peu
dommage et je commence à avoir un peu
peur pour mvl sa Grunfeld elle a dû être
suranalysée ouais ça c'est sûr mais bon
c'est pas aujourd'hui qui qu'il va y
avoir des problèmes sur la Grunfeld
j'avais trouvé grituk beaucoup plus
intéressant que Giri d'ailleurs avec
C4
donc
peut-être
sur5ire4 qu alors
je pense qu'il veut dire ça ça
ça
ça dit Fabiano s'est trompé dans le
chat je pense pas mais je sais pas je
vois pas la
positiono non non mais s'est trompé de
rien c'est juste qu'il a suranalysé et
que ses analyses sont beaucoup plus
fortes que ce que vous voyez sur vos
modules non non il s'est trompé de rien
du tout il te joue tout tempo et il va
vouloir te faire des tours prend4 et tu
pourras pas prendre dufinre s veut te
des de
partout en fait je donne pas char de la
peauen hein ah ce serait incroyable
qu'il survive aujourd'hui quoi bah ce
serait charismatique même beau quelque
part non mais ça va être très difficile
hein ouais euh petite question Fab
est-ce qu'on se fait alors est-ce qu'on
s'organise un tournoi pour les reays à
14h on pourrait le faire tous les jours
des candidats euh ouais bien sûr vas-y
viens on fait un tournoi en club on fait
quoi on fait une arène ou on fait un
système suisse une arène non je sais pas
comme tu veux on l'appelle Arena fait
une Arena fait une Arena le club on va
mettre blit streams plus facile standard
on va mettre cadence on met quoi on met
3 + 2 ou 5 minutes 5 minutes ça 5
minutes vasy 5 minutes le chat YouTube
là pendant ce temps du
coup 1
he minimum de parti je mets 10 je a des
questions quoi il y a tobage 99 dit que
le covid mais fa en suur son qu'il ne l'
bah oui mais je suis bien content de pas
l'avoir j'ai pas envie de laavoir quoi
si tout le monde éit en surur comme moi
je pense qu'on il se propagerait pas
trop vite
quoi dit Philippe maer il ne prends pas
de risque voilà je prends pas de
risque il y a chevralier de la table
carrée qui te dit que le matin il y a
pas mal de monde à la boulangerie ah ça
c'est une info
ouais non mais j'ai vu enfin genre qu'il
y a des gens qui font n'importe quoi ils
achètent 10 baguettes par 10 baguette
enfin n'importe quoi je peux comprendre
ils ont peur mais mais bon après il y a
des gens qui vont arriver il a plus de
pain quoi c'est beau quoi mais j'ai vu
que pour lutter contre ce genre de truc
au Danemark ils ont fait un truc pas mal
bon c'était pour vendre les gels
hydroalcooliques ils te vendent le gel à
son prix normal genre on va dire 5 € par
contre si tu en achètes deux d'un coup
c'est 135 €
c'est pas pratique quoi pour les gens
comme ça les gens qui sont parano ils
dépense beaucoup et la pharmacie fait du
bnef bah normal tu achètes un par un du
coup normalement oui du coup tu achètes
5 € le prix normal et puis voilà quoi et
il y en a pour tout le monde et c'est
normal quoi mais du coup pour les
baguettees on pour faire pareil quoi 1 €
la B baguett allez deux baguettes 2 €
par de baguettes encore c'est possible
c'est des familles nombreux ou je sais
pas quoi trois baguettes direct on
augmente 6 € 4 baguettes 20 € 5
baguettes 50 € enfin fait un truc comme
ça
exponentiel alors si on est bien sûr que
Fabiano est pas moins bien malgré le
fait que certains modules donnent plus
150 ce que le la la profondeur des
modules sur laquelle tu regarde est
tellement faible en fait que ça n'a
aucun intérêt en fait non mais ça de
l'intérêt contre contre quasiment tout
le monde mais le problème c'est que là
face un mec qui a analysé ça avec son
équipe et qui a des ordis mais
tuimagines même pas la puissance et la
profondeur
il il sait mieux quoi et il y a il y
abeng sur Youtube qui demande salut les
tontons c'est quand le prochain tournoi
que vous organisez et comment on y
participe bah là la Reena elle va avoir
lieu dans 56 minutes mais il y a
personne qui s'inscrit s'il y a 7
joueurs je mets le lien sur
twitch ok si tu peux le récupérer
copiercoller le mettre sur youtube ouais
ouais je du coup je sur le téléphone
c'est le W live machin là ouais alors
attends je peux peut-être le faire comme
ça tu peux le faire vas-y plus peux
faire
copier par contre il faut participer au
club stream donc je mette pour
participer Francis BCH tu revi 10
minutes après ouais bon je sais pas en
en même temps faudra que les gens juste
il fent de un peu de bonne volonté c'est
V c'est dur de mettre des règles tu peux
toujours tout détourner si tu as envie
de détourner
quoi tu peux mais bon si tu es trop
longtemps dehors normalement aussi tu
peux te prendre des amendes de par tu as
rien à faire dehors quoi tu es censé de
te confiner
donc donc ok il y a le le truc sur
Youtube j'ai vu que tu avais mis le lien
ouais c'est super du coup faut juste
être si si sinon il faut juste être
aussi sur le club Blitz stream et je
vais trouver un lien alors attends je
vais faire ça parce qu'en fait je pense
ça peut ne pas être bête pendant les
candidats comme de toute façon tout le
monde YB qui demande s faut être inscrit
sur twitch alors pas du tout après si tu
veux t'inscrire sur twitch c'est juste
pas mal parce que bah il y a pas mal de
d'émissions qu'on fait qui sont que sur
twitch et pas forcément de partout par
exempleémission Fab que je mets
pas pour revenir sur les parties le soir
vers 20h30 on le fait chaque jour euh
bah du coup sur twitch le B stream de
twitch donc c'est pas idiot de d'être
inscrit partout quoi qu'il en soit ça
permet d'avoir accès à toutes les
émissions tu as les notifs tu as tout ça
mais bon après on force rien et du coup
non pour jouer il y a pas besoin d'être
sur twitch ou quoi que ce soit c'est
juste bah un pseudo chcom ça euh voilà
mais c'est gratuit aussi et il faut
joindre le groupe
blitam et dimanche en TR d'expliquer là
voyez sur chesscom français qui vous met
un petit mot pour rejoindre le club
stream c'est gratuit il vous met le lien
machin et là voilà et après vous pouvez
rejoindre le
tournoi dans un deuxème
temps dans un deuxème temps ouais je
pense qu'on le fera on le fera tous les
jours à 14h c'est pas mal je sais pas
ça' y a des gens qui mangent je sais pas
quelle heure ils mangent mais 14h ça
permet de ça vous pouvez pendant que
vous suivez Le pendant que vous suivez
les candidats C certains veulent jouer
vous pouvez quoi ouais défouler un peu
et C et qui va bientôt avir une heure de
retard à la pulle quoi bah les cloches
vont bientôt
sonnerin et Nicolas qui dit salut cavefa
premier live pour moi et d'ailleurs si
vous êtes c'est la première fois que
vous venez nous suivre sur twitch si
vous l'avez juste en dessous aussi vous
avez le lien vers la chaîne blit stream
donc pourra suivre les émissions
supplémentaires le soir à 20h30 euh
après les parties et les jours de repos
à 18h avec le débrief théorique et euh
et d'ailleurs ce soir Seb je crois qu'il
y avait j'ai vu Mazo dans le chat on
regardera de nouveau euh les les petites
euh les notes de Mazo les petites notes
de Mazo aussi le soir donc merci à toi
de faire ces notes c'est cool au moins
ça nous donne du grain à
moudre après pour comparer un peu on
verra ce que matthu en a pensé et on
espère une grosse notte pour
carwanao qui n dit de belles parties
aujourd'hui ouais c'est sympa Carana
donc qui en la grosse nouveauté et qui
qui envoie euh et Max bah c'est c'est
une petite grunf c'est intéressant on
verra il y a juste gritou c'est un peu
inpide
non comment pensez qu'il pourait pu
jouer autrement après ces de première
partie très décevante je pense
simplement Fab qu'il est en train de
montrer son vrai niveau non mais
gritchou non mais là bon toute façon la
PTR c'est dur de de faire quelque chose
mais je lui avais envoyé les fichiers il
y a déjà 2
mois il n'a pas dû deviner que wangao
allait jouer la
Petrof
donc bah wangao ouais de toute façon les
joueurs chinois il jouent pas pas mal la
p j'ai l'IM c'est ouverture principale
quoi
ouais ouon du coup gr je P ça don n moi
je pense pour c'est gr nul ou victoire
de carwana victoire de
NPO et nul dans la on reste un peu sur
MV là ça un peu avancé on va voir s le
cavalier B6 ça êre intéressant non bah
ça hyper logique qui est
je pense aussi mais juste je le sens
pas6 je sens loin de l'ro et j'ai hyper
peur de prendre5 f5age tu as peur qu'il
fasse qui fait souvent dans les grenfeld
bon il en B 5
maissk qui nous dit mal placé c'est moi
sur Twitter qui dit à faire une émission
sur twitch avec toi tu veux que je
ramène aussi oua
vas-y IR on va parler de sa prépa pour
ranté sisque quoi faire une petite
émission Z reposte 50 % du chat entend
trèslé travail vous pouvez faire un Réap
des derniers coups de temps en temps
j'ai pas vu les derniers moves bah il
s'est pas passé grand-chose écoute il
s'est passé endu mais je vais les
REM mais en gros c'est ok on est en
sortie d'ouverture et voilà Fab comme il
expliqué on est un petit peu inquiet du
du placement du cavale moi bon c'est pas
l'inquiétude de fou mais
ça peut avoir son importance on va dire
donc ça c'est juste théorique c'est une
rente un peu rare de la Grunfeld mais
bon ça arrive les blancs veulent prendre
le centre action centrale des Noirs B5
des ville fou pour affaiblir des5 et les
Noirs veulent leur gagner un peu plus
tard voilà là il sont ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs et ben on en est là
voilà donc l'idée des Noirs c'est que si
les blancs prennent en D5 ils vont
regagner ce pion en faisant k B6 t D8 et
cetera et cetera globalement les blancs
vont pas regagner le pion mais V plutôt
que
5 alors ils ont ils n pas de pion de
retard par contre donc c'est pas
vraiment regagner le pion c'est gagnerag
tout que sinon ça pouvait donner
l'impression
que pour participer au tournoi je vais
le redire on va pas le dire 10000 fois
mais alors attends il
faut
s'inscrire il faut rejoindre jeécrire
une bonne
fois cl blit
stream
puis
rejoindre puis
participer au tournoi pardon F
c'est je pense que c'est ça attends
partager
voilà j'ai mis le truc si ludv tu peux
faire un copiercollé de de ce petit de
ce micro tutoriel pour le remettre au
cas où ça peut être sympa parce que je
penseett de temps en temps pour ouais
parce qu'il il y a 500 personnes qui
vont demander comment on fait on a
l'habitude Taliana qui nous dit petite
inquiétude du cavalier pas d'inquiétude
de fou merci captaine
ovius tu veux pas organiser un match
retour ou non pas vraiment il faut
rejoindre le club ouais c'est c'est bon
bon on va voir là c'est un peu le moment
un peu le moment creux quoi B on va voir
on va voir ouais donc F6 c'est l'autre
option mais mais qu'on regarder C5 et
Si4 pu on
prend ça c'est pas terrible2 k D2 DC4 et
je sais pas
quoi non
ça mais c'est moyen pour les noouis
c'est pas terrible ça peut-être on peut
arriver à faire nul en se battant mais
c'est pas le rêve de rentrer làdedans
quand
même euh du coup
ok aussi il faut dire sur5 tu es pas
obligé de faire que4 tu peux peut-être
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre boug
la
dame pour venir en4 B bon le bouff ou je
pense je fais ça et ouais peut-être tu
fais ça mais bon prend qu 5 et prend le
4 moi ça me rassure pas trop ça F non on
n pas ravi après ok c'est peut-être
jouable
mais mais au final je sais pas enfin la
partie qu'on a vu de NPO contre
thasevski ça av juste l'air d'être
beaucoup plus simple que ça et du coup
faudra trouver quand même le bon
placement de
pièce je suis non mais c'est bizarre on
se pensait une hule rapide SK D7 rock et
tu vois ce que j'aime pas en fait dans
ce des7 Fab je vais te le dire ça tu
vois tu je vais viser dans le 1 là c'est
si tu veux là on fait faire des
fléchettes je vais tomber sur le sur le
la BLL quoi je vais faire les 50 h tu
fais cavalier
des7 tu as quand même 95 % de chance de
te prendre rock h tu te prends rock et
tu réfléchi tu vois tu as réfléchi genre
10 minutes pour qu'il ait des7 le mec
fait rock et là on est de nouveau sur du
10 minutes 15 minutes de
réflexion et ça ça m'inquiète en fait
c'est la deuxième réflexion
ouais bon c'est pas si grave mais oui il
faut non mais là juste ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on peut pas faire de coup
trop
neutre être
précis c'est pour ça que j'aime pas le C
des 7 rock et
euh et réflexion je c'est c'est
généralement c'est pas super bon signe
ça veut pas dire qu'il va perdre ou quoi
mais ça veut dire que il y a un petit
danger là mais euh juste ce que je veux
dire c'est qu' faut regarder les tours
des 8 ce que ça donne a C des7 le coup
de NPO euh parce que bon NPO ça se
trouve il a joué vite sans sans sans
savoir exactement quoi euh est-ce que ça
aura pu changer quelque chose parce que
la finale à mon avis ça va ça va
mais tu fais quoi tuis tour D1 du coup
je sais pas si tu veux
des et là al de toute façon te dit mais
est-ce que c'est pas la même
alors
c'est 5ok OK et si tu commences par 7
cavalier B6 ok tuas pas
ti tu peux mettre la tour a si tu veux
mais sur tour tu V faire 5 c'est pas la
même il perd pas son temps à faire tour
tour c'est pas très ule tu vas plutô la
mettre en ouais ou nulle part nul et si
tu fais tour à8 5
ouaisour donc c'est pas la même tu as
pas perdu un temps mais tu as donné un
temps au blanc pour faire autre chose
ouais et tour des juste dernière
question tour
[Musique]
D8 non non si je fais 5
D et que je pars maintenant
ok je venir en C6 ou ça change ça aussi
je peux venir par là je pense il est
mieux placéah le cavalier qui peut venir
soit en F5 physiquement soit déjà
contrôler la case et empêcher que les le
fasse c'est toujours bien et le fou qui
peut rejillir
aussi non ouais ouais ouais bon c'est
sûrement d'près ce qu'on voit là bon
c'est pas de la grosse analyse mais ça a
l'air ça a l'air d'être une imprécision
après il y a forcément une raison qu'on
connaît pas pour laquelle maxime a joué
de cette manière làà et on sait pas quoi
h bon tout le monde dit que Carana ça va
pas du
tout bon à moins qu'il confondu un truc
Carana mais
bon tu dis plus 250 quand même
oui bon il y a de P de
plus mais
euh enfin bon là on comence quand on
commence à laisser tourner l'ordi euh TI
escend ça redescend bon attends je Esser
d'aller choper le truc je mettre mon
ordion qui est pas hy pu je pense que
vous comprenez pas la différence entre
profondeur 23 et profondeur 52 comme
Mathie de temps en temps c'est juste que
c'est la différence entre un joueur à
2850 et un joueur à 3700 quoi presque 1
point l'écart quand même profondeur 22
et profondeur
5006 arrê de regarder les ordis ouis
mais plus mais si vous regardez des
ordis regarde ch bomb ils sont puissants
au moins je sais pas par que Ch bom il
037 ah bah oui mais bon c'est juste qu'
faut regarder ch bomb ENF je sais pas
regarder les bons sites c'est tout ENF
regarder les suites puissant qui ont des
ordinateurs qui tournent vite bom il
mett 037 sur 3 005 sur G3 et 0 déjà sur
les autes coup non mais je préfère pas
imaginer le site qui regarde parce que
là si pourri j'ai peur
quoi non mais 033 mais moi je vais
mettre mon ordi juste à moi comme ça bon
qui va pas aller merde qui va pas aller
hyper vite mais qui va monter donc je le
mets avec j'ai que 8 CPU hein sur mon
portable tac vas-y cherche
ouais non chass bom il ob il commence
par être à 0,50 mais déjà en prof 21 il
a 0,60 le deuxième coup il C 00 bah non
mais il y a rien euh et fou tris
meilleurs
coup mais bon comme il mett des 00 c'est
possible qu'en fait Ding sans s et qu'il
y ait une répétition chez je sais pas
quoi ça fait beaucoup de 00 sur les
ordis là là il est plus qu'à 046
profondeur 25
ouis ça
descend ne doutez pas de Carana non mais
c'est sûr que je pense c'est très
dangereux Ding plus de 36 minutes tu
joues tout
tempo maovski qui la prépa est
monstrueuse clairement mais est-ce que
tu vas sortir le 10 alors est-ce que tu
dégagnes le 10 en de victoire encore
gagner mais s gagne proprement est-ce
que tu dégagnes ton premier
10 d' Mo une question combien de 10 dans
l'équipe ils on 11
10 donc on peut revoir en rapide la
partie de
car tu la grosse nouveauté calier de d
de Max c'est nouveauté oui mais pas une
nouveauté préparé je
pense que tu dég 9 et
dem 10 dans qu circonstance mettre
chb profondeur 23 profondeur 23 c'est
ridicule avant il montit profondeur 35
40 chasbom qu'est-ce qu'il me font
oui mais en tout cas leur évaluation est
plus proche de la réalité quoi qu'il en
so il dit prépa de ouf puis tactique
incroyable pour le 10 bon vraiment qu'il
fasse un truc beau en plus pour finir et
finale d'entologie ah ouais non mais en
fait il va jamais y avoir de 10o non
mais ok on peut pas mettre 10 au deuxè
jour de de note quoi tu peux remettre
mais il
ans peut-être qu'il a Dégé le 9 trop
vite en
fait qu'il a déjà mis un ne en fait
ouais mais ça arrive pas mal
des c'est juste fantastique mais hier il
pas fait mauais coup de la partie bonne
prépa bon carnage bon calcul bonne
finition c'estas mis un tripl dans le
match quoi
bien
10 aussi si le joueur fait un salto
arrière juste avant un coup décisif et
un
DA ne il y a même m lo Perin qui a eu un
neu
dans K6 joué par Max on nous dit
ok on va on va on va on va retourner sur
la partie de Max ça être important je
pense que fou E2 pardon on va jouer
rapidement bah écoute par après je sais
pas ça se trouve tu peux aller ailleurs
mais fou2 c'est le coup qui nous
semblait le plus
logique et la re alors çaen est où il
des inscrits ouais j'ai on est 113
inscrits pour le moment il y a un maître
FIDÉ
brésilien le fusilo qui ah il y a Henry
qui joue
Henry h ouais chou
il joue quoi il joue la Reina quoi il va
essayer de de se battre quoi je remets
je remets lien dans le chat la preu quoi
il est bien Henri quoi
h comment rejoindre
mond non K6
voir je peux pas je peux pas jouer la
Rina et comter en même temps les gars
désolé donc on pense que ça va continuer
comme ça la parti de Maxi mais du coup
c'est un petit avantage blanc quand même
parce que le roi des Noirs un peu faible
et comme disit fa si un jour il y a F5
damage 6 G5 ça peut faire mal
ça peut faire mat et donc il faudra
toujours toujours avir ça à l' c'est un
peu une épée de Dam classe qu carier B6
assz mal placer on voudrait l'avoir
plutôt en
F5 voir même l'avoir pu le développer
vers E7 du coup pour un peu à protéger
et col maté mais là en B6 il est un peu
dans le Nans l h
exactement et oui donc je vois toujours
que les gens se plent un peu de la
caméra bah désolé ce qui était prévu
c'est que j'aille chez keV commter mais
vu les directives on a décidé de de
faire à distance et donc c'est les
alléats de la
connexion après bon tant que le son est
bon on a les coups on a les échiqués on
a tout ça ça va quoi ouais non là là
pour moi l'important c'est que le son là
il est parfait aujourd'hui et c'est
quand même ça qui qui est le plus
important je
crois non mais F ce serait bien
sacrifier pour pour nous et pour nous
tous quoi Fab aurait sacrifié sa vie
sinon comptait qu'à lui Fab serait venu
enfin tu risquerais la mort pour pour
pour avoir une caméra non floue mais bon
il ne risque pas la vie des autres quoi
fa joue solidaire voilà al que bon si
qu' lui on y va quoi tant pis gra là il
ne peut pas par pure
solidarité F5 c'est pas jouable avec
l'idée cavalier H4 F5 cavalier H4 ça
sera un peu bizarre quand Mme cavalier
H4 peut-être cavalier H4 pour jouer F5
ça peut-être problme c'est qu'il FR en
fait je pense qu'il par la
position je pense qu'il veut faire KH 4
en premier
Fab si c'est
possible
donc ça c'est ce qui devrait se passer
dans la partie on va
voir ti fouti franchement ça gâche un
peu la journée la caméra fou mais on va
prendre sur nous
ouais çale journée du coup hier je sais
pas qui j'ai troll parce que il y avait
il y avait les notifs de je sais plus
quoi un peu trop fortes et je lui ai dit
désolé d'avoir vraiment gêné ta journée
avec une seconde de notif trop forte sur
1h30 de live ça a dû être vraiment très
dérangeant pour toi bah
oui non c'est ce qu'il y avait romain et
tout c'était son premier gros live et
enin j'avais envie qu'il soit dans les
meilleures conditions quoi j'avais pas
envie que les gens tu vois ils saoulent
à troller ou quoi toi tu as l'habitude
tu connais mais tu vois romain il a pas
l'habitude et du coup je voulais pas que
ça trollle à fond comme ça donc
donc voilà donc B6
5 F2 pardon pu5 sûrement pour gu mais F
2 par contre n pas obligé de faire tour
D8 peut-être peux faire dame
6 il peut
ou dame D7 même
tiens B 5 vasy ouais mais comme ça je
suis pas obligé de faire tour D8 non non
mais pourquoi pas enfin est pas si mal
quoi non mais ok il va tenter des4 un
jour c'est logique et maintenant euh
faut voir comment les blancs s'agence en
fait on a compris le plan après encore
faut-il arriver à faire ce F5 he ouais
mais F D3 ouais on veut faire F5 si les
Noirs font des4 je pense qu'on peut
faire C4 et on va faire F5
al attends est-ce qu'il peut ê le F en
D3 direct ben non il pr oui mais
bon est-ce qu'il peut faire du coup E5
alle prend C4 on prend des6 prend des de
prend des de on récupère des 6 récupère
c'est gagnant pour il il vient jouer fou
de F non mais c'est logique ENF c'est
clairement le plus logique après j'ai vu
des gens demandaient pourquoi pas fou5
peut-être en fait je sais pas ça se
trouve il y a une petit détail 5 très
bon je sais pas mais fou 2 ça priori
pourra introdu à 6 et fou de oui mais je
sais pas qu'est-ce que ça fait qu' a 6
ou pas est-ce que tu peux dire B
il a une certaine logique
quoi est jouable écoute pourquoi pas
pour rir
veru c'est dommage la la tour à 8 là-bas
autant la bouger pour l'instant ça peut
aller
vite quand
mêmeire
GAE
4 tu su faire la gueule mais la tour en8
elle est utile quand même
ouais bien sûr mais tu sais que je
commences vraiment à m'inquiéter genre
je suis pas inquiet inquiet mais je par
là que l'ouverture d'un truc insipide où
tu te dis il y a rien ça passe à un truc
ok Maxime il est plus fort que Guiry et
il va s'en
sortir j'ai pas de grand doute mais
c'est dommage de se mettre un peu sous
pression bon après on ver enfin
peut-être qu'on s'inquiète de pas
grandchose et qu'on comprend mal auss ce
qui se passe mais mais ouais je
prendrais plutôt les blancs moi si je
devais jouer cette position non mais
clairement clairement clairement un peu
mieux autant aussi guéri bon
après dame F6 ouais mais dame F6 5 toute
façon ça change pas non mais peut-être
tu vas aller vers G7 pour protéger mais
très passif hein c'est passif la dame tu
la vois enfin elle rayonne plus
quoi en dehors du jeu les blancs peuvent
te faire à 4 à 5 je sais pas jeouer sur
la colonne B il font ce qu'ils veulent
quoi tu joues s ta
tour et ça veut pas dire que F5 marche
plus même si M que ça peut être un
problème et on D4 direct
mais bon je sais pas peut-être peut-être
peutêre conr c'est pas
mal Bou
tour8 comm comm tentative mais je suis
pas sûr que quoi qu'il en so on soit
complètement sorti des problèmes mais au
moins ça active quoi leenir vers D5 le
fou rayon tu filer un pion pour
l'activité c'est typique son style
j'aurais jamais joué ça mais
bon c'est peut-être pas
idiot c'est peut-être pas
idiot c'est peut-être pas idiot du tout
même
[Musique]
donc salut
feneec salut tout le monde salut
tonton qui demande on en est on en est
là la position que tu as sous les
[Musique]
yeux on préfère un peu la position
blanche mais peut-être que l'idée de
jouer avec des4 actif pour les noir ça
peut ça peut être quelque
chose
donc donc donc
donc on va peut-être voir est-ce que ça
joue B Gricha ça va faire nul c'est sûr
Ding bon il jou toujours tempo faut TR
CAH F
ok tempo encore marrant parce que même
les ordis à profondeur déjà
intéressantes il C H5 dame G5 retour en
F6 pour essayer de faire nul comme ça et
cavalier
F8 F il savent
pas ils ont d passer tellement de dizain
d' analyser ça ouis non c'est beau là
c'est de la prépa
c'est ha niveau quoi ça seetrouver dans
lesmission mat non mais là c'est
[Musique]
vraiment quelque chose pour l'instant
joue des bons coups il pas fait de
Conner
oui mais bon est-ce que ça va suffir
reste 26
minutes c'est fou de prendre de mettre
la pression avec les Noirs comme ça
quand même ouais qu'est-ce qu'il a de si
fort la PrP Carana bah c'est juste que
tu files de pions pour l'activité et que
c'est difficile avec les blancs de
savoir comment naviguer
quoi c'est chaud quoi ou et les
compression mais en fait on peut pas
vraiment enfin soit on se plonge et on
fait cette partie là à fond et on
regarde que ça et on analyse à fond et
ça va être relou pour tout le monde soit
on laissera les gens sérieux s'en
occuper à postéiori genre Mathieu qui
pourra bien vous expliquer mais là en
fait c'est que concret c'est que de
l'ordi il y a rien à expliquer en fait
c'est du coup par coup en fait on ailé
de pions ça marche ça marche pas ouais
c'est et et l'ordi en plus c'est pas des
ordis de
merde ordi très fort pour pour pousser
les
variantes c'est vrai que c'est une
phrase de Vlad nous a sorti Ario dans le
chat il faut commencer à gagner des
parties à la maison
h ça c'est vrai que non mais là c'est
juste trop trop dur c'est c'est trop
compliqué il joue tout tempo et non
parce qu'en fait enin si si on regarde
humainement le truc B tuas filé deux
pions les blancs il y a pas trop de
faiblesse et le roi il est pas trop
faible en gros tuas que tu vas pouir
faire fou des trois tours1 et roi G1 tu
vas solidifier avec les Blancs et que ça
doit aller maintenant c'est quoi le truc
c'est c'est un peu les pièces à droite à
gauche le r un peu exposé il y a la dame
qui va se perdre des tempos
F des 4 CIT le coup que disait
l'ordi il a fait ouais des et
euh et concrètement il y a peut-être un
truc qui va passer un
moment c'est chaud quand même he de
suivre l'ordi là pendant 5 si coups côté
Ding he c'est bien joué non mais c'est
ça que je fais bon tour C8 normalement
d'après d'près ce qu'il me disent les
ordis il va rejouer tempo je sais pas
hein mais c'est c'est le coup qui semble
être le meilleur d'prè ce que je regarde
en allement mon truc mais qui a pas UNE
PROFONDEUR fantastique donc n'importe
quel haut coup mais bon en même tempsite
ça para quand même probable quoi tu te
développes tu gagnes un tempo sur sur le
kc4 maisc est-ce qu'on sentirait pas la
présence d'un Adams ici euh moi je CIS
qu'on surtout la la présence d'un alpha
Z0 et d'un certain stock F bien connu
dans le milieu
c'est vrai qu'Adams on l'a vu qui il
boss
mais
euh c'est pas très adamesque même comme
sty
ah6 c génial il B toutes s dans la
tranche c'est
extraordinaire non mais tu tu souffles
jamais quoi tu veux te lever de détendre
un peu les gens non non jamais tu tu es
confiné à cette à cette échiqué quoi
dégage ne va pas souffler ou cracher
quelque part quoi c'est bon en plus mon
module aime pas qui
g6on il a tp29 dans le tournoi
ah toupe toupe contre CHOU CHOU quoi ça
va être beau
ça vaêtre très chaud comme tournoi
quoi c'est un gros tournoant en fait
c'estcoup commander ça en fait il y en a
marre c'est beau qu quelqu'un dans le
chat qui oui toute façon Mathieu a déjà
bien analysé cette position quoi ENF il
a déjà tout dans l'ordi quoi non mais
genre tu vois juste pour vous dire le
truc que mon ordi mais il est que
profondeur 27 il aime bien les blancs
mais il dit dam c'est je dis juste g je
même pas les coups prend le 4 puis on
prend tour
C8 D2 F prend
D5 ça dit que c'est très bien pour les
blancs il est très heureux mais dire
voyez le genre de truc bord que ça peut
être genre sur P prend il y a dam H4 et
du coup il prend pas en D5 d'Urs D1 mais
bonen fait ils vont avoir vachement de
jeux c'est toujours mal développé ça
s'ouvre dans dans tous les sens c'est
hyper dur pratique avec les surtout
qu'il a peut-être des idées très
concrètes qui sont très fortes pour les
Noirs à tout moment c'est chaud puis MOS
en moins de temps à la pendu tout
temp sur fait dame F5 ok B c'était ouens
rouge
F5 correct c'est juste pas le coup
numéro 1 maison au moins il a joué vite
mais s'il s'en sort il sera gagnant en
fin de partie dit TR mais non c'est à
mon avis mme si tu a les blan en fait le
pire c'est que tu dois juste êre
peut-être un peu mieux et sement même
pas
[Musique]
quoi rejero dans la
gueuleo justement peut-être pas parce
que comme c'est pas le l'ORD tu sais
plus
tout
o dans la
gueule tellement tempo le défonce en
fait tu es nuléussi à résister
àish Combin contre
toi plus une bonne parte vraent une
bonne partie le
me de fou
t'entit jou cont
cont c'est
horrible mais ouais écoute tour C8 c'est
c'est une option en tout
cas mais c'est tellement dommage qu'il
arrêté de jouer la première ligne de
l'ordi quoi il se prait tellement tout
tempo dans la
gueule c'est dommage quoi on dit doubbof
s'inquiète pas pour la position de mvl
ouais mais bon
après il s'inquiète pas il s'inquiète
pas quoi mais nous on
s'inquiète ouis goucho Marx qui dit euh
mentalement dit va-il craquer ouis il a
aucun mental de toute façon le sa non
mais franchement ass chaud hein ce qui
subit non je rigole mais euh non mais
pour le coup Ding en on sent qu'il est
perturbé quoi en tout cas par tout ce
qu'il a subi avec les quarantaines et et
tout ça et qu'il est pas à 100 %
il est dans le dur hein
ouais donc tourc c'est pas Grandioso moi
dans la logique de la prépa je vois bien
encore un coup
cavalier on va voir hein
ouais on va voir ce qu'il joue en tout
cas c'est une grosse prépa du joueur
italien qui qui met vraiment la pression
sur son
adversaire ça se fait marer à chaque
fois le joueur italien ouais c'est bon
quoi dès qu'il perd jur américain au
fond c'est beau quoi tu gagnes probement
ça tu es
italien pe qui diting ne particip à
aucune conférence de presse bon déjà je
savais pas euh non mais
je oui je pense qu'il est vraiment pas
dans son assiette non mais
clairement
clairement bon alors du
coup on retourne juste jete un œil à NPO
NPO qui joue tout tempempo lui
aussi pour le coup c'est pas forcément
la prépa quoi
c'est il parce qu'il je
quoi c'est vent qu'il soit pas plus fort
encore en blitz qu'il ne l' quoi c'est
marrant
ouais en fait il devrait avoir le même
niveau qu'en parti lante
quoi peut-être s adversaire joue mieux
quand tu t pas aussi quoi je sais pas il
y a un genre de de rythme qui s'installe
c'est tellement relou de réfléchir le
jou tempo ça te saoule il a rien calculé
enfin non mais en tout cas écoute il est
très confortable avec les Noirs
voilàord propose un beau coup cavalier
F6 trouvable parce que tu viens en E4
sontou non mais c'est logique mais tu
profites du f F4 mal placé il va le
jouer en plus toute façon lui c'est le
premier coup qu' regarde c'est
sûr c'est sûr qu'il voit le ça en
premier
il est tellement heureux je pense faire
un cou MK
F6 non mais c'est
ouais mais écoute NPO n pas mal on va
voir si mais même s'il fait pase façon
c'est déjà il y a pas de problème pour
le nard tu peux partir même pour jouer
grand rock si tu
envie l qui dit NPO il est fort en blit
mais que en parti lente du coup non
peut-être qu'en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
a besoin de réfléchir sur le temps de
l'adversaire ou qui a besoin parfois de
prendre son temps pour avoir des idées
qu' peut après jouer tempo c'est
possible aussi hein
oui non mais iloue il joue vite il joue
vite mais non en fait en vrai il a plus
que 1h1 il a déjà quand même réfléchi
une demi-heure quoi oui
voilà c'est pas si tempo que ça et
caroana du coup il joue non très longent
quoi mvl non plus ils sont pas très bien
au temps aujourd'hui tous les joueurs
sont un peu mal au temps et gritou là
c'est fantastique quoi d pr 5 ça mis en
PLS bah peut-être qu'il fait sa sieste
hein non mais c'est pas possible d'ussi
peu dormir par contre mais il y arrive
pas c'est ça ouais mais il est stressé
il est malade qu'est-ce qu'il a je sais
pas je crois qu'il est tout le temps
comme ça en tournoi mais enfin il disait
que la nuit la nuit de enfin pas cette
nuit-là la nuit d'avant il avait dormi
que 1 heure quoi
enfin je sais pas comment ils font pour
jouer en dormant 1 heure enfin moi je
vois plus rien
euh non mais une partie tu peux après ce
qu'il y a de pas facile c'est si ça dure
plusieurs jours
même une partie en aant fait nuit
blanche ça va c'est
pas mais tu peux encore le faire
aujourd'hui moi mon ge jeux plus faire
j'ai que 30 je peux déjà plus faire si
tu peux faire mais très vigilant un peu
mou mais tu fais gaffe tu saisuxou des
trucs es très très
vigilant ce qui ve pas dire tu vas
forcément faire une bonne partie pour
autant mais c'est pas forcément la par
contreenchaînes tu vas pas y
arriver c'estou pas dormir comme ça
je sais pas str'en
fous
domant
jeme connare
encore
peut-être un moment la dame est enfermée
j'en sais rien C7 ouais bon je vois leur
dit il raconte aussi que le four vient
vers C5 et que tu veux profiter des
cases
noir en tu as quand même deux pionnettes
de moins toujours hein mais tu as du
jeu donc fa que penses-tu pour Max après
D4 E5 de dame
C6 alors
attends
ah ilchanger les
dam on va te prendre en D4 quand même
euh juste pour savoir C4 c'était un
problème ou
pas non Madame C ouais non jeable aussi
mais il faut en fait si je peux le faire
je je serai content mais
bon
ouais mais fais voir donc c'est prend
quelun qui est plus
fort et ok là faut
trouver
BIM BIM BIM B c'est BIM non
ouais ok tu reprend des qu ou quoi pas
importe6
ou et euh bon F6 c'est une menace déjà
ouais si tu prends j'en casse et j'en
casse
mais c'est le problème ok ça va pas
prend pas
possible c'est prend alors mais déjà
c'était pas trop l'objectif mais est-ce
que5 prend ça va
mais ça c'est c'est ce qu'on veut avec
les blanc tu fais mat trop dangereux
trop dangereux trop dangereux non moi je
ça joue facilement fait c'est des coup
on peut faire en blit en Bull non mais
je suis vraiment inqui parce que
cavalier D7 B6 avant de le jouer et la
est quasiment for forcé hein une fois
que tu as fait il avait quand même 1h15
au début de la séquence il a plus que 37
minutes
h après il joue pas trop vite dans ce t
Maxime ça change de plein de tour on a
vu donc je sais pas c'est pas forcment
indicateur que ça se passe mal he parce
que il D4 c'est ce qu'on pensait en fait
du coup bah il jou dans ouis je pense
c'est bien joué des4 les autres truc il
était mal à long pit avoir un petit
désavantage à long terme le moins c'est
hyper dynamique et va beaucoup mieux
jouer gu ouais oui
voilà du coup je suis très
confiant je pense c'est bien joué non
mais en tout cas c'est un truc dans son
style mais je aucun doute qu'il jouer en
fait des
ouais non non c'est bien
ça du coup il menace le pion l'autre va
avancer doncame plus fort quand Mme faut
éviter F5 quand même
ouais
sur on prend il mettra une tour en D8 et
petite pression tu peux faire moment
ouais mais peut-être on fait pas prendre
avec les
blan cette fois-ci tu peux faire5 du
coup ex dame D7 et
C4
faire
6 Bou
bouff
reviens évaluer ça pour les blanc je
préère les
blanc parce que si tu mets le F en D3 tu
bloques le pion des4 attaqu le roi et tu
as ton 3 cont de ce côté là qui
inérali B6 un peu
triste6 je sais pas mais à voir mais en
tout cas bon faut trouver a un peu le
dynamisme
[Musique]
ou non
clairement F6 mais mais ça un truc comme
ça
5 pas mais juste MOS
tour mais ça fait moins MOS
vis-is
er 3
non4
norm ça c'est
graveieux pour les blanae pas trop ça
ressemble truc déjà perdu quoi
nose cavalier à 4 c'est3 quand je sais
pas un moment donné
ouais peut-être
ok c'est
compliqué en tout cas il a pas il a pas
complètement trouvé l'égalité encore non
non mais bon ok c'est compliqué ça guéri
de toute façon de trouver maintenant
concrètement quoi faire quoi
oui non c'est tendu c'est tendu
c'est pas si net net
hein c'est pas si net
net la barre blanche à gauche du petit
échiquier la barre d'évaluation ouais
exactement bon on va voir juste je par
curiosité je retourne sur Ding dame C7
non mais il a vraiment plus trop de
temps en plus un Ding
bah ouais moins de 20 minutes non ça
c'est chaud al cont qui joue demain
demain c'est le jour de repos
ouais donc demain on se
repose bah il y a quand même une mission
avec Mat
mat à
18h
et et sinon avant repos ouais il sera
temps de lire regarder des séries voilà
faire des trucs des trucs comme ça moi
je demain après-midi je pense
ouais moi je voulais lire ouais je vais
lire demain tu vas dormir ou pas bah je
vais dormir mais bon comme d'ab je dors
chaque jour ça
va non mais j'ai pas trop de problème de
sommeil enfin en général puis là non
plus en
fait mazovski qui écrit apparemment
intoxication sur les citrus attends quoi
durant sa
quinzaine attends attends j'essaie de
récupérer sur les citrus apparemment
intoxication en Russie durant sa
quinzaine il pense il parle de de Ding
de Ding peut-être c'est c quoi déjà
psychologiquement ça do être dur c'est
en plus il est vraiment malade pour de
bon je veux dire
ends on va voir on va voir il va nous
ouais Ding
non toxication alimentaire mais tuas
fait toi d'ailleurs bah oui mais aussi
parce que quand il devait être bloqué
qui est chez lui il a dû devoir
commander à domicile et moi j'avais une
intoxication comme ça h et comme il y a
zéro règle d'hygiène là-bas et tout
enfin zéro ça peut ça peut être très
relou quoi oui non mais bon enfin c'est
enfin c'est vraiment inadmissible en
fait non mais tu vois c'est le genre de
truc qui m'énerve en fait du fait que le
tournoi est quand même mieux h c'est tu
as tout un tas de trucs comme ça qui
serait jamais arrivé si le
truc enfin c'est ça m'énerve en
fait
ouais ben non mais oui oui non en fait
en fait que le tourno a lieu c'est qu
même spécial mais non mais ça tualement
l'équité du
tournoi non mais sachant qu'en plus ça
peut ne pas aller au bout quoi oui oui
non mais là clairement en fait tu es
juste obligé de faire la bouffe à
emportée parce qu'il t'oblige d'être en
en quarantaine à Moscou la bouffe à
emportée à Moscou bon c'est très connu
qu'il faut jamais commander parce que ça
justement tu peux avoir des intoxication
donc quand tu habites là-bas tu ne veux
surtout pas faire mais ok tu es obligé
de faire et voilà mais je c'est une
conséquence du fait que enfin c'est
c'est pas équitable parce que pourquoi
Fabiano lui doit pas être en 14aine et
pourquoi Ding il doit l'être enfin je
crois qu'à Washington il y a quand même
beaucoup plus de cas de de Corona dans
la région où weding quoi en fait ça
c'est complètement injuste en fait quand
il pensent en France quoi enfin je sais
pas non mais sur le coup oui ils avaient
peur parce que ça vient de Chine mais
c'est vrai que maintenant en Chine c'est
plutôt en quoi on vaut dire non je sais
pas mais quand Max il vient de France en
fait ben enfin si tu compares le le
nombre de cas et la population totale je
peut-être plus confiance tu viens de
Chine en
fait et et du coup en fait wangao il a
pas eu besoin de faire parce qu'il était
au Japon c'est ça ouais ah oui au Japon
tu peux
ouais bon écoute
bref on fait pas les règles non je sais
mais bon je non mais je suis un peu
triste pour Ding oui parce que il non
mais juste c'est pas normal en fait
c'est il aurait pu gagner le tournoi en
temps normal clairement enfin il avait
le niveau pour et là just il peut pas il
non PS
quoi
et qu'est-ce que je vouais
dire je sais plus bon c'est pas grave
ouais puis bon aux États-Unis quand on
parle de carwana c'est vrai qu'en plus
comme il t pas les gens et cetera c'est
c'est la h ludwiig de l ouais 5 jou mais
écoute c'est un peu le truc semblait
logique
maintenant
en plus il a fait deux quarantaines
quand même il dans il sort d'une
quarantaine en Chine il arrive et comme
c'est la loi on lui dit à toi tu dois
refaire quarantaine c'est la loi mais
quand un décret qui est passé en Russie
et que c'est la loi de faire en Russie
pour les Européens ah non là c'est plus
la loi là ça va non mais c'est juste
j'aime pas en fait ça ça me pour tout le
monde c'est juste pas normal que pour
carwana ou mvl ou Guiri tu le fais pas
alors que bon c'est quand même tu as le
décret qui a quand même été fait et pour
et pour Ding parce qu'il est chinois
mais enfin je sais pas mais c'est V bon
je pas ça me fait halluciner en fait
c'est c'est dégueu c'est dégueulasse en
fait de faire ça enfin
c'est non mais ok le truc ça c'était
juste de de repousser les candidats non
mais quand tu es occidental ça va on te
teste pas alors que tu as la loi mais tu
es chinois ah oui là on te teste je sais
pas non mais j'ai presque envie de
lâcher un mot quoi enfin tu sais lequel
hein le mot ne va pas être lâché mais
euh il pourrait
l'être c'est c'est quand même très
spécial c'est quand même très spécial
enfin bon benah d'ailleurs même Trump il
appelle ça le virus chinois quoi non
mais bon ok mais c'est moche quoi
c'est un chinois en fait donc Toupé qui
dit pour mvl qualifier une semaine avant
c'était compliqué de faire la le
quarantaine 14 jours oui mais pour
Fabien Cana du coup non mais c'est pas
MV enfin c'est pas contre mvl mais genre
dans ces cas-là tu peux dire le tournoi
commence pas le 17 mars il commencera le
31 oui ENF du coup il commencera dans
dans 2 mois quoi dans 3 mois ou je sais
pas
quand bah
oui non mais
c'est non mais c'est c'est quand il y a
une compétition quand il y a du du sport
en fait c'est comme je te rappelle
j'étais complètement fou quand quand je
regardais le France Écosse l'autre fois
ah ouais ouais VO non mais ok mais enfin
c'était n'importe quoi mais du coup
quand ça arrive en fait ça me dégoû
enfin ça m'énerve un peu en fait j'aime
pas mvl était un cas spécial du coup
mais les autres auraient pu faire une
quarantaine aussi oui enfin un cas
spécial aussi parce que rappelonsle tout
de même par qu'il faut le rappeler c'est
parce que rajabof et on voit postériori
qu'il avait complètement raison se
désiste pour une raison normale en fait
en gros toute la situation soit elle est
juste liée à la FIDE à mon avis qui
prend des décisions qui qui sont quand
même étranges mais bon c'est peut-être
pour le bien des échecs non puis en plus
il te promettait des audiences de folie
sur twitch partout on est le seul sport
qui joue oui personne ne regarde quand
même enfin il y a il y a de deux
articles sur l'équipe et un sur
Eurosport ou je sais pas où ça fait 10
lignes il y a trois commentaires enfin
tu vois c'est tout le monde
regarde bon Ding il continue de trouver
les bons coups quand même hein
ou il est bon aujourd'hui mais peut-être
que son truc truc alimentaire ça fait
mal mais en plus ça dure à vie
quoi potentiellement intoxication non
mais
non juste défoncer l'estomac ou faire un
truc qui peut être ouis moi j'ai un
problème à vie en fait à cause de ça
et Don je commence à sentir les
conséquences mais j'ai réussi à les
gérer facilement pour le moment j'espère
que ça durera mais ouais et concrètement
si c'est une grosse intox enfin si c'est
une intoxication pendant 3 semaines tu
es mal ouais parce que ton est si si
suivant quel point ça l'a fait tu es pas
très bien pendant de 3
semaines moi pour l'estomac genre je
pouvais pas manger autre chose que du
Sarasin pendant de pendant une semaine
sans rien et à partir de la deuxè
semaine je crois que je P rajoutter un
peu d'huile d'olive ou de sel je sais
plus mais genre première semaine c'éit
just sarrasin sans rien quoi ouis ouais
même pas de sel rien h après genre petit
à petit tu faouvit rajouter après de
semaines il faouit recommencer à manger
200 g de haricot vert ah ça va al et et
après tu pouvais remettre un peu tu sais
les poulet bouiles et tout après 3
semaines mais tu vois c'est
long bah 3 semaines sans haric vert
Poulin
ouis mais après quand tu as les 200 g de
harico vert et puis cétait pas 202 g tu
me connais quoi je suis une fusée ouais
donc 200 g pile poil et ça va
ouais donc
bon cétait juste c'était le petit coup
de gueule tu vois avant avant avant la
Reina de
14h
sur non mais c'est Mao qui nous aancé en
écrivant un truc tout à fait tout à fait
normal et tout à fait tout à fait
constructif mais du coup tu vois c'est
c'est un peu ch mais ouais j'étais pas
courant de C histoire
[Musique]
d'xication
donc
donc donc donc on demande c'est quoi la
cadence alors c'est 1h40 + 30 secondes
par coup pour les 40 premiers coups au
40e tu récupère 50 minutes et tu as
toujours les 30 secondes par cou et au
60e tu reprends encore 15
minutes et voilà ça peut durer
longtemps
alors euh
ouais vas-y je sais pas on va tu veux un
peu c'est exactement ce qu'on
disait et peuttre peutêre Jer la finale
oui donc c'est quoiens un peu moins bien
mais
tuuxendre je sais pas est-ce que c'est
mieux de garder les de tour quand
tufends
ou arrive vite
as pasour tu prendre des Mach
mais ça semblait être la ligne il lu
resteo reste une heure 4 pourquoi
réfléchiuttre qu' s'est levé juste les
mec non mais aussi
peutêtre moment il conna tout parur non
pluso
maise c'est 5 je crois non il peut faire
tour 5 interméire aussi ah oui c'est
vrai
donc on me demande si je suis toujours
fan de blackjck ouais bon ça fait un
petit moment que j'ai pas joué mais oui
oui c'est un jeu que j'aime bien le
blackjack
ouais bon par contre le lui m'aime Pasi
le black tu aime pas
non problème sur le petit tchiquet alors
c'est quoi le problème sur le petit
tchiquet ah ouais il y a un problème sur
le petitchiqu d des jouer machin et ça
pas mis à
jour
exact alors je peux essayer de faire
ça mais je crois que ça do être un je
peux je peux écrire he si ça avance plus
je vais je vais leur
écrire
directement
ah attends je suis juste en train de
vérifier
ouais c'est des ch qui s'ouvre plus fa
je vois bah écoute bah sinon mais juste
la la tête des joueurs ah si ser ré ouvr
ouais mais c'est pas à jour ben ils
l'ont pas mis à jour mais déjà il s'est
réouvert h
ouais B tu peux envoyer un petit message
ce n'est plus à
jour donc l'Arena qui commence il y a
combien de joueurs alors dans la re euh
il y a 187
Ray c'est pas mal hein
ouais ouais ben on va peut-être monter à
200 ce serait beau quand même petit
tournoi comme ça ppous ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'est quand même
j'ai envie de te dire le tournoi le plus
important
de cherche trouver les mission c'est en
redif sur
twitchamt de
[Musique]
la qui gche
tout je le téléphone je une seconde je
remets le
truc
tac je remets le lien j'ar dans seconde
Maisy
combien de rondes je sais pas je crois
que c'est plutôt un tournoi qui va durer
1 heure je pas combien de temps et ça
joue non stop tuis c'est AR Flac qui est
bien écoute c'est
compliqué il a plutôt réussi son
ouverture tout reste à faire je dirais
que reste probable mais tout est
possible
quoi
est-ce qu'on pense que Kana amélioré son
jeu par rapport aux autres années qu'on
voit rarement jouer et comment
trouvez-vous le niveau de Maxime alors
niveau de Maxime pour l'instant très
bien rien à dire très bon niveau et
Carana je TR pas qu'il amélioré ou pas
amélioré il est juste très bon et aussi
bon que é fin du champion du monde la
dernière fois que ça eu lieu il avait
déj der tour candidat lané il a gagné le
temp
V donc non il est juste hy bon
fA ou du prénom non je pense aussi c'est
un prénom de champion ça prénom de
champion
alors18 joueurs on dit dans le dans l'AR
2 joueste on monte dernier lien si vous
voulez jouer le petit t de la PR si ça
marche bien allez peutêtre on offrira
pas pour celui d'aujourd'hui pour des
prochains
peut-êtred pourquoi pas on Fa attendre
quelque chose il y a 44 en plus
qui est favori mais ça va être chaud he
tout le monde peut gagner c'est la Reena
les Arenas tu tu es tu joues contre des
joueurs de ton hlo quoi donc c'est très
très chaud ouais
il y a des strikes et tout non
ouaisis il a déjà un mec qui qui a gagné
une partie qui il est déjà là quoi ça va
très très vite quoi les arèes c'est
parti ah oui oui
c'est frès 10 secondes il est déjà gagné
quoi c'est beau quoi
donc on dit il est du signe des Balan ça
parle
roscope rej un à gra bon gra ça va
annulerevenirex ça un peu
évoluéchang sur C5
ça C6
ok
B5
bon moi il attaque le
fou peut faire B5 du coup le F confin A4
mais il pourra rejir un jour en C2 ouais
c'est ça et puis ça donne4 jour si tu as
besoin pourquoi pas mais c'est pas clair
en
fait mais juste pas trop de problème
pour pour
mais tout est
possible
donc donc donc
donc
c'est
halier4
6 est-ce que tu es content
bordel pas SR pas s
Fab mais si tu prends juste en C5 fa tu
gardes un peu cette séquence
rés tu peux la faire dans l'autre sens
C5 t
5 ça marche plus dans ce sens là
G3
pas BL H4 en fait Jama en fait tu j le
truc ou
G H pe
repartir tu veux faire ce truc c'est
maintenant ou
jamais va là calier
h et là tu per
la en tout cas tu gres tu vas prendre
des F5 tu faouvir
partout ça tu veux
pas non non ça tu veux pas ça tu tu vas
perdre c'est typiquement ce que les noir
envie qui se passe donc damage 4
G5 tu peux introduire ça si tu veux on
bouge et maintenant ok on n pas obl de
faire d'AM des6 non plus
alors dit d pas d'AM des6
prendre prendre prendre prendre et dame
C2 tour 1 tour
ça donne envie quand même ça faut le
voir mais ça sympa en fait sur IL5 n
c'est ça ok
bon fait n làd comme ça il méritera
peut-être ça serare une partie 8 non en
terme de note Mao ah je sais
pas aura fait une défense en fait pas
malut Pasir tout calculé mais il a pas
eu peur
jamais
c'est quand même beau sil s'en sort ça
fa peut voir bien sûr
ok ok vasy on peut all voir CIT juste
pour essayer de comprendre un peu ce qui
se passa là mvl ouais donc on par de
PR est-ce que on a autre chose est-ce
que
c'est44 on a parlé aussive de mettre F3
F5
ou on avait vu ça tu te rappelles on
avit regardé ça
Mo on a le cavalier qui éit un peu
ailleurs mais oui et et non mais en
général on dis cette structure plutôt
avantageuse pour les blancs quand même
parce que le P D4 il bouge pas et que tu
peux ouvrir le roi adverse ouais ouais
mais j'aime bien H4 H5 en
fa euh ouais ou enfin avec le fond des
TR ça c'est c'est pas le problème mais
ouais mais ouais peut-être pas F enfin
peut-être pas ou alors faut poser un
vrai problème contre F4 si on fait mince
si on fait F6
F5 propose c fou E4 HM il fou D3 il part
en F5
ouais mais je suis pas convaincu ok vu
les vent qui donne pourquoi pas faire
fprend les TR F5
alors avant de perdre le temps
ouais
ouais c'est pas con de jouer ça tuas C4
en prise et tes pions peut-être h ok ça
ça
va tu fais F6 tu Mones le roi ou je sais
pas ro qui monte F6
ok bon
peut-être c'est4 x 4 peut être un bon
coup du
coup fr il a pas assez joué de parti
pour pouir participer à ais faut jou au
moins 10 parties surcom c'est pour pas
qu'il ait des gens qui fasse des
milliers de pseudos pour pourir le
tournoi en fait donc on peut pas le
modifier faut avoir l'habitude de jouer
sur chesscom sinon pas de chance pas
d'Ina
quoi donc
ok faut 4 c'est pas mal mais bon C4 rien
dit que soit très bon mais c'est pas
bête hein ce fou4 j'aime bien j'aime
bien l'idée ben t'empêche que le Fou
vient en D3 qui te domine hein ouais et
changer plus plus d'un F5 c'est joli
c'est sympa c'est un beau truc HM mais
peut-être dur à
trouver pour les blancs mais Maxime le
verra
ouais surtout qu'en plus il y a
peut-être d'autres options mais c'est
juste une option qui est jolie
quoi
euh ok donc c'est prend sinon c'est
l'autre truc qu'on regardait beaucoup on
pense quoi 3 vit ça 3
D1 et F F3 mais c'est pas obligé en fait
F F3 c'est c'est pas forcment ce qu'il
veut max il ve peut-être dama 4 je sais
pas un truc comme
ça tu as pas peur de non mais moi j'ai
peur mais Maxim il joue l'initiative
quoi nonen oui mais je monte F je sais
euh tu pouis prendre direct ah oui
j'avais pas vu ça par contre oui
c'est pour ça que je disais ouais moi
j'ai vu dam des
pr tu peux pas ouais euh mais
peut-êtreut du coup enfin peut-être faut
prendre du fond F3 je sais pas ce que ça
change comme ça il y a pas de problème
sur D tume 6 qui
arrive pere pr du
coup
tour oui
oui c'est
chaud c'est dur à savoir exactement mais
je dans ce cas de figure là par contre
c'est jouable avec le pion
F5 ouais c'est moins solide pour les
blanc par que quand tu fais F6 du coup
tu tu auras ouais mais après c'est quand
même chaud à
décider entre plus 1 et + 1 30 est-ce
que c'est inquiétant quelle partie Sky
Bobby parce que chez Maxime pas j'ai pas
vu d'ordi qui qui qui s'ffolait trop
quoi
ouais c'est chaud c'est
compliqué
non mais je suis pas trop inqu
ENIT je sais pas comme il a joué son D4
et son truc ça me semble
plus style et moi je suis pas inqui dans
le sens où je comprends que l' préfère
les blancs ou quoi mais je me dis que
Maxime joue tellement mieux je la même
chose que toi en fait c'est tellement
son style de position que
oui c'est je sais pas je s que ça va
aller les blancs arrivent pas à mettre
le truc complètement sous contrôle et
faire ce qu'ils veulent c'est chaque
foiser ce passe et et ouais tour de V d'
4 ça peut être le genre de ressource qu'
cherche à faire ou du quel qui arrive
vers des 5 vers 3 enfin il va trouver
des trucs c'est sûr très clairement
c'est bien pour lui d'ailleurs Seb est
d'accord dans dans le chat il dit que gu
est encore dans une position où il est
pas trop à son c'est bizarre gu il
insiste jouer ce genre de truc je pense
que son problème en fait c'est qu'il va
être bien préparé jou les trucs
principaux donc il se dit oui je vais
jouer principal ENF ça correspond pas ça
correspond pas quoi oui mais tu
n'appartiens pas ce style de
partie masterpce
de un peu V une
[Musique]
ok mais je comprends il les D2 en D3
contrôler les colonnes ramener son roi
et jouer à long terme sur le pion
isolé mais ça pere faire non mais je
comprends ce qu'il veut
faire
et dire ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer bien se passer ne t'inquiète
pas bon c'est qu'il peut la jouer
pendant des
heures il va la jouer pendant des
heures
et et pour le coup Caron pas fait 5 il a
pris écheac et le roi
bougé il y a eu
H6 pas trop penser
euh c'est quoi tu prends cette case ça
change il a joué tour
d' assez vite he
pour c'est tellement le bordel ouais bon
c'est chaud hein et Mister Mister 8 qui
dit je je vous découvre les gars
franchement vous donnez envie de me
remettre aux échecs écoute c'est cool tu
pe suivre en dessous du
coup il y a le lien vers le Blitz le
twitch de la chaîne Blitz stream c'est
ma chaîne perso qu'on on fait pas mal
d'émissions avec Fab et vous pouvez
aussi checker sur Youtube on fait plein
de vidéos sur youtube il y a énormément
ouais beaucoup beaucoup de vidéos du
coup je mets le lien et vous avez aussi
le lien vers toutes les chaînes de
chesscom donc j'en profite si vous
voulez vous abo et cetera n'hésitez pas
il y a plein plein plein plein plein de
contenu du coup on essaa de passerre sur
la chaîne au 40000 abonnés après le
tournoi pendant le tournoi pourquoi pas
on est à 38900 c'est ça peut peut-être
se faire bah oui oui s'il y a des gens
qui découvrent qui qui sont intéressés
c'est c'est sympa
euh bah ouais vous êtes les bienvenus
évidemment quoi ça va bien se passer
hein alors il H6 cavalier H4 et G5 quand
tu fais cavalier H4 qui repart en F4 tu
fais G5 il rentre enfin il fait même d
pr F6 en fait mais et même s'il devait
repartir en D2 à vrai dire je pense
qu'il est plutôt heureux de revenir vers
D4
quoi
bon moi JEE juste avec l' un peu ce
qu'il
raconte ils font un truc bizarre ils
aiment bien ass
les pas le coup qui me VI spontanément à
l'esprit
mais c'est pour faire
B5 je suis impressionné par D joueur
ouais franchement aujourd'hui je suis
impressionné s'il gagne cette partie par
contre avec les Blancs et qui se relanc
dans le tournoi il aura le droit un 10
Mao c'est beau quoi non mais il y aura
pas de 10 mais si il y aura un 10 bordel
influenceele quoi sinon il metta jamais
de 10 ah mais non si ça y est il a dit
ce sera
10 Mao lché le premier 10 après 2 jours
quoi l'équipe ils ont dû mettre 25 ans
mettre un 10 mais là oui mais bon c'est
le contexte réel il te met un 10 dégage
ouis c'est ça le 10 va tomber côté Mazo
quoi d'ailleurs mettez un lien viens on
met aussi un lien vers le Twitter de
Mazo si les gens veulent lire c'est je
sais pas si c'est Ludvig peut le faire
des revu de presse enfin ça c'est c'est
ouais c'est petit ces petites notes
assez sympa à lire et ça permet de pour
pour les gens qui jouent pas aux échecs
ou quoi vous pouvez partager ça permet
d'avoir un petit un petit contreendu
rapide et
sympathique sur tter attends je vais
dire ce que c'est son twitter c'est
mazetov c'est maovski je
mais il est sur le coup t'inquiète att
il sur le
coupè du coup n'hésitez pas aller faire
un petit saut ses petites notes le soir
c'est
sympa D est un scorpion qu comme t
scorpion c'est cool du coup petit tour
des on repart
sur
c'est les ord disent sur
T pr c'est la
[Musique]
partie Ding en rémission
totale t va j à avis très plaisir pour
Ding P faire son retour juste j croya
absolument pas jeou tout le
tourno c'est fort imagine si Ding le
tourno est-ce que tu fais une statue
Ding ok je sais
pas est-ce que tu
offre l'option isolée quoi
ouis je lui offre je lui offre un un sub
à la chaîne bstam quoi est-ce que tu lui
offre un avo diamant sur
chesscom non plus non non un sub la ch
tu penses qu'il a pas le niveau quand
même
ouis B mon diamant bon on verra faudra
battre Carls pour ça quoi ok s'il bat
Carls il aura le petit diamant quoi et
le DVD ça va il a le droit à tout et
merci un utilisateur anonyme qui du coup
a offert un abonnement à la chaîne chcom
mazovski quoi
comme ça Mazo va avoir le petit pion
quoi le sub est tombé pour Mazo Le Tan
Tien et merci à l'utilisateur anonyme du
coup Mazo qui est de
partout c'est colaven qui grand il l'
pas gratos en fait sûrement si mais bon
mais pourquoi les ah tu veux dire le
diamant sur
chascam mais bon du l'abonnement blit
stream ça change rien il y a pas de non
mais bon enfin c'est le truc c'est quand
si tu es grand maître tu apprprends donc
pourquoi serit gratuit quoif bon après c
plus de 2800 Vlad a dit que tu n ça va
quoi tu tuis pas forcément besoin mais
Ding il se trouve qu'il est moins de
2800 à présent donc ah c'est quand même
très dommage quoi mais tu n'as pas assez
travaillé quoi on nous dit 70 points eto
d'écart entre mvl et carwana c'est
beaucoup quand même oui mais avec la
partie d'aujourd'hui on comprend quand
même pourquoi carwana à 70 points et l
de
plus ces prépas sont quand même assez
impressionnantes ouais mais en fait la
chance qu'il a eu c'est d'avoir déjà
joué un match de championnat du monde
donc il a appris une méthodologie il a
fait une équipe hyper compétente il a dû
avoir des sponsors il a fait une prépa
de fou pour le match Carlson et du coup
il sait faire
ouais on dit une quarantaine n'empêche
pas une prépa échec arrêons les excuses
aux adversaires de mvl mais c'est pas
des excuses en fait Meria Stark je sais
pas si tu vois le monde quand tu sors de
chez toi il est quand même pas tout à
fait pareil qui a qui a 3 mois en fait
je sais pas si tu t'en rend compte les
conditions sont très spéciales quand
même c'est quelque chose d'assez
étonnant et d'ailleurs si pas ses
conditions Maxime jouerait pas c'est en
fait on est à fond pour maximer tout ça
mais ça sert à rien de faire semblant
que tout est normal en fait mais tout
n'est pas normal sais pas tout n'est pas
normal donc situation
exceptionnelle ben tout est un peu
exceptionnel et c'est tant mieux pour
Maxime mais genre par là il faut être
objectif quand on voit un Ding qui se
tape les cor an qui a l'intoxication
alimentaire et tout et qui résiste à
carwana je sa pas on a quand même le
droit d'admirer la performance de du
joueur je sais pas non tu n'as pas le
droit un moment
donné enin tu as le droit de de de
respecter le joueur d'échec et de voir
l'exceptionalité de ce qu'il a fait
parce que les deux premiers jours le
niveau deinglen était ridicule et
clairement quelque chose qui tournait
par rond et quand tu te prends une prépa
comme ça carwana aujourd'hui en tu as le
droit d'avoir juste envie de lâcher de
de lâcher les armes quoi je trouve que
c'est quand même exceptionnel ce que ce
que Ding réalise pour le moment
aujourd'hui non déjà c'est beau
de nul ouais tu peux faire s prender un
truc tu sais que c'est nul
euh et pour l'instant il trouve les
coups et il joue il ESS de jouer
principal de bouffer les pions de
défendre bon après il peut finir et
faire une gaffe et perdre mais dans dans
dans l'état d'esprit c'est beau ce qu'il
fait en tout cas et pour l'instant il
fait belle prestation ah oui non mais on
a le droit quand même de de respecter la
la performance de l'homme quoi enfin je
sa pas c'est comme si tu as féérire qui
te fait un super match bon c'est dur de
comparer F l' d'Australie par exemple
non mais ça m' arrivé de voir féérire
mon fils c'est d'être plus en fait pour
féérire enfin je sais pas à un moment
donnéin pas ça peut m'arriver c'est que
ça m'arrive tout le temps mais non mais
en fait parfois quand les gars sont trop
forts qui te font quelque chose
d'impressionnant ou quoi ben tu as le
droit de t'asseoir et d'admirer et
d'oublier les national et cetera c'est
juste beau enfin c'est beau de voir
quelqu'un se dépasser et et de réussir à
faire ce genre de chos
ouais et tu as le droit à un moment
donné d'être admiratif par rapport à à
une performance humaine
incroyable et en plus pour la peine Ding
il a pas tant de moyens financiers que
ça pour la
peine Ronaldinho vationner au Barnabé ou
voilà
donc non mais il avait des des vieux
ordis j'ai entendu des histoires comme
ça que quand il arrivé il avait des
vieux ordis portables super l non
maintenant il a dû se mettre au niveau
quand même oui mais
bon et du coup gu qui réfléchit
làour ouais qui réfléchit non mais là
Maxime qui à mon avis il va il va il va
dominer gu tu vas
voir gu quand même il il a déjà déjoué
contre NPO il va déjouer aujourd'hui
c'est sûr je
ouais je suis assez confiant pour Max
bonf peut-être pas gagn mais je pense
que ça va bien se
passer nul ou gainof ok nul plus
probable
quoi non
[Musique]
nul je pense nul je pense que non mais
gu en plus regarde contre NPO il s'est
faitetourner
c'était quandme plus plus bord qu'
c'était n'importe quoi attends hier hier
il a fait n'importe quoi hier C horrible
quand même très mal jou entre le 35e et
le 40e il est pas en forme Guir à mon
avis il va il va vouloir simplifier
faire nul de par lui-même
quoi non pour ça bonne partie de Max et
on va voir non mais bon c'est pas
complètement
sorti on va voir les prochains coups
mais la dynamique de la partie c'est pas
si mal
il va se faire des tartines de vache
Guiry Guir va mettre sa culotte courte
et se faire tartiner
le niveau du
chat bon alors la Reina qui gagne pour
l'instant la
Reina ouais mais c'est serré ils sont à
tous à 13 points c'est chaud l'Arena est
chaude quoi il a S qui joue ouais
il
chercher il a fait
D6 c'est logique
faireion quep logi ça peut ne pas
suffire en fa trou l'exceptionnel
pour pour
justifier tour
C2 die ça c'estis ce qui se passe
ok je comprends rien non c'est compliqué
parceen fait dans même temps avec cl les
blanc tu bouches pas grand chose si on
fait juste tour assez
vite ok put
ok même
mais c'est peut-être ça de 6
d'ailleurs c'est en fait il content de
faire un 6 B5 pour seire la colon c'est
ça ouais mais bon c'est faut y penser
Bahou après si tu as analysé à fond tu
pr un peu les
idées c'est chaud
hein il a fait tour des deux d'ailleurs
dame 3 jou c'est par
ok bon on va voir re C de ça a l'air de
de bien tenir il para qu'co a fait un
truc
sympa
ah il a filé la qualité mais c'est pas
con parce qu'au moins tu joues
contre ça compte tout en fait le FO 4 tu
dis bon ben toi tu joueras plus jamais
et tu veux jouer avec une pièce de plus
sur de chiqu il a peut-être la gagn
alexenco ce serait une bonne nouvelle
bah ce serait bien pour lui et si
ça NPO du coup il serait beaucoup moins
dangereux quoi mais hyper intéressant
quoi c'est pas il f la qualité le F 4
joue plus il veut faire qu' a des4 dam
G4 F4 F5 en gros exactement exactement
euh
ok pe-être avec les fallir songer à
faire grand rock en
fait parce que petitck c'est sûr que tu
es tu vas te faire démonter mais grand
rock bon on va voir mais mais tuas le
fois 4 qui n'existe plus
quoi que les blancs sont juste mieux en
vrai donc ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
bien joué enfin c'est c'est pas mal le
plan en fait d'avoir provoqué B5 je
pensais que c'était bien pour les Noirs
moi à priori j'ai été un peu léger et
peut-être NP pareil d'ailleurs et en
fait ça un fou c'est un plot quoi mais
Maz il veut te faire tour à un tour
prend à 4
dégage ce qui fait grand c'est beau quoi
de ref une qualité le fou qui sert à
rien F prend 6 et t'envoie quoi ok ça
faudra voir ok ça marche c'est
fantastique mais mais au pire grand rock
on peut peut-être juste faire qui D4 F4
et jouer ave drit quand même
ou t
ok bon il veut faire4 en tout
cas c'est dommage que les chqu vraiment
plus jamais mis à jour quoi
ouais bon il a fait tour un pour
protéger le pion tu l'uras écrit non je
leur écrire
tiens je des tourn au passage je vais
ah je vais la réécrire je vais la
réécrire je vais la
réécrire alors je remets un peu la
partie de MV attends attends il a fait
tour D1 fou pr F3 et tour pr F3 d'accord
ah ben ça va tomber dans la finale alors
ouais ouais il veut jouer la finale je
pensais que peut-être max allait faire
dam 4 au lieu de bon c'est peut-être
beaucoup moins fort hein mais que ça
étit plus été dans son là
ça les chance de gain diminue bon c'est
sûrement nul en fait mais mais c'est un
truc mieux pour Guiry dans le sens où
pas trop compliqué
finalement ok ça rentre
làends
for on prend et donc final tour fou cont
calier en général mieux pour le fou
simplement là il y a qu' sur en plus sur
cas noir Etas ton passé tu as Moné le RO
norm ça va aller peut-être qu'il va
faire très vite F6 d'Illes il voir ça
moi je pensais peut-être qu'il ser tour
à3
ouais tour
C8 faut pas défendre passif d'ailleurs
tu peux pas mais au moins tu essay tour
C2 je sais pas oou tors d'abord ou bon
je sais pas si c'est mieux de clouer ou
de de faire tors attaquer
is mais peut-être tu tu peux pas monter
en E4 non tu peux je peux pas c'est vrai
il RO1 tu des5 un truc comme ça ouais ça
doit aller ça pour les
Noirs bon c'est quand même assez concret
quoi
ok tu masses quand même
ok çaas quand même la tête d'un truc où
tu fais nul hein ouais oua ouais mais
bon
enfin et on est obligé de le perdre ce
pion on pe pas faire autre
chose c'est qu'on fa pas on va pas en
parler parce qu'il a fait tour D3 bon ok
donc tour D8 c'est plus ou moins forcé
je pense quoi que tour C8 peêtre jouable
aussi
ok il veut faire fou D1 fou B3 ok j'ai
compris son idée il veut mettre la tour
en D3 tu fais tour D8 admettons il fait
fou
D1 il te met le fou en B3 et il monte le
roi il veut dire que le fou il protège
le pion il contrôle la diago et il
t'envoie les pions dans la
gueule peut-êre C4 F B3 5 j'aime bien ce
que dit l'ordi et attends une question
est-ce qu'on peut faire F6 au ça com ça
à simplifier
tu dois
pouvoir moi je pense c'est juste un truc
désagréable mais technique
ok il a fait tour on va voir bon
peut-être tour C8 c'est pas idiot l'ordi
est value à + 07 mais le truc c'est
comme c'est une finale c'est faut pas
trop lui faire confiance dans le sens où
ça peut être un + 07 qui mène juste à
une finale théorique nul
h ok
mais il y aura pas de victoire
aujourd'hui normalement non c'est vrai
mais nul ce serait bien bon ça va non
mais nul avant la partie on a é d'accord
de toute façon c'est juste je sais pas
j'ai espoir que ça r un truc compliqué
gu implose et là bon c'est dur
d'imploser là-dedans quand même ok mais
la vue
de de la partie avec les noirs et tout
c'est quand même non c'est quand même un
bon
résultat il a pas implosé donc
ok car il a joué
le
voir c'est
oume fait c'est exactement la position
qu'on regardait non mais ok c'est une
partie de beau niveau quand même c'est
peut-être pas tous les coups de l'ordi
mais en tout cas il a les plans et il se
bat à fond qu'est-ce qu'il fait est-ce
qu'il fait damage 3 dam G3 dam2 ou G3
G2 ça pe être un plan ça
ouais je pensais que
ouais c'est très bien pour les blancs en
fait consolider je F2 ro G de et c'est
c'est juste complètement gagnant après
enfin tu pouses au centre serait beau
quand même que Carana la perde enfin là
Maxime il prend serait quand même être
une belle ronde tu fais du con Guy si
Carana per et NP perd tu prends la tête
avecangao peut perdre aussi d'ailleurs
damage
3 bon il vair B5 toute façon une fois
qu'il a fait à 6 maintenant c'est sûr tu
dis a tu dis B bah tu fais pas 6 ça
juste fait un coup d'attente quand tu as
de de Mos
ça va quand même remettre le tour
compltement les RE c'est pas gagner
c'est pas perdu je sais
pas
[Musique]
gagne
confianceana un petit coup de
pu en plus du coup as tous lessiders qui
peasser devant ça pe ça peut vraiment
rebattre les
cartes on mais gag
très surpris j'aurais pas mis un surant
la ronde puis après le 5 PRP et tout
d'autant plus oui oui ou oui la position
mais gagne tu peux avoir un tel
[Musique]
rerement
déjà c'est une bonne chose
pourre qu' quand même pas
gagner cavalier
était
bah ouais
plutôt puis on prend je pas non mais
j'ai peur que tu Activ le fou si tu fais
c'est ça c'est ça tu libères un peu le
fou et tu pourras jamais faire C3 et fou
B3 fou
C4 non mais pr par logique puis même
pour ton fou D2 si tu peux avoir espoir
de te dire je vais le passer par E3 et
venir vers C5 ou au moins en D4 tout
tout bien
consolidé c'est jour
h il y a PR G7 aussi c'est on même pas
regarder mais j'aurais dit grand rock a
priori et maintenant prendre en te
disant que non mais là je peux pas
prendre façon même tout à l'heure
j'avais le clouage mais
ouais je sais pas peutêre ça
va il fait il a fait P prend
direct benah écoute on va voir parce que
sil fait grand dame pr G7 ça vaenir au
même que ce qu' regarda ouais je pense
en fait que si soners sur dame pr G7 qui
F3 échec intermédiaire
h et je pense tu es pas du tout content
d'avoir ouvert la colonne g et de
laisser D4 c'est
vrai et donc du coup NPO qui peut jouer
G5
euh c'est quoi puis on prend pis on
prend P on prend enfin perdu pour perd
mais mais euh ok quoi fou Fran ça va non
mais si ça joue en fait ro des7 ça joue
en fait ton roi il est pas forcément mis
en C8 parce que la colonne C ah et tu as
quand même ouvert des colonnes quoi j'en
s rien moi je prendrai les blancs perso
mais euh
j'ai5 c'est un beaucoup pas facile d'y
penser mais en fait aussi l'idée c'est
que quand tu te fais bouffer G7 tu pers
H6 c'est le P h passé là tu ouvres des
colonnes tu fais
table ras de de
l'roi non tu es content qu'il a plus les
pion clairement c'est ça donc ouais faut
y penser qu
juste les ord vois
mais et G6 tu te fais sacrifier ou pas
encore vous prend pion prend dame prend
là
7 dame C6 F7
F7 H5
H5 j'ai h tour
3 bon tuasandme une t
plus je bien croire que ça fait ça ça
fait très très peur ça fait peur non ok
G6 on sent que le sacrifice c'est ce que
les Blancs veulent mais juste si ça
marche pas g tu es quand même très
content avecard par tu tu fixes quoi tu
bloques tout tu vas cacher ton ro ux
faire G6 H5 planquer ton roi mettre les
trucs sur la colonne C tu vas taper C2
tu vas gagner c'est ça même si tu une
qualité sur c2ett tour en C4 un truc
comme ça moment ça mais ouis non si tu
peux pas concrètement non mais ok j'ai 5
jolis
coups le
trouver c'est pas fait
ok alors Maxime on a en dessous mainant
tour des 3 tour des 8 cétait sûr on voir
comment gu tente de la gagner mais
normalement ça devrait aller ah ok
Fabiano ah il a pas fait le il a fait
ouais il a fait dame G3 et B4 et B4
ouais il veut essayer de prendre la
colonne C et de vite rentrer d il veut
faire dame B3 il te gagne un tempo sur
la tour ouais mais est-ce que c'est si
grave
ouais je sais pas en si on commence àer
prendre ses pions là-bas euh ouais un
peu
il va te faire dame F2 G3 ro G2 et tour
1 et après c'est fini
c'est ça et qu' vaevenir en plus en le 3
il sera même pas si mal
quoi faut qu'il trouve mieux que ça si
trouve pas mieux que ça gros avantage
c'est chaud quel partie de
malade mais j'imagine Mathieu ce soir je
suis sûr qu'il est en train d'analyser
ça à fond ou c'est sûr non mais en plus
c'est intéressant parce que 5 faut
comprendre tous les non le
5 mais je crois que en fait on a dû
trouver B mais la qu' fallait faire mais
cé juste n
avec le
[Musique]
Pr ou alors fallait faire A6 et B5 mais
avant
de avant tout ça avant d'amer fait qui
est pas si bien placé
a priori elle est très bienelle est très
chiante elle te bloque le roi ça bloque
tout
mais il est
mal il est mal surour d un tour pr un
truc comme ça ça peut
tour au
pire même
pas mal faudrait la mettre en
quarantaine
c'est vrai bah écoute
c'est surprenant c'est beau
ouis franchement c'est beau Grisha bon
il va la gagner d'après Mao donc j'ai
envie de te dire aucun
doute Guiri gui Guiri
il fait fou il fait le
plan c'est logique quoi tu mets le F en
B3 non mais c'est pas ultra confortable
pour le noir non plus
après ça devrait aller mais c'est r pas
si simple quoi ça l'a jamais été hein
non mais je un moment de pousser
d'optimisme là après son D4
ouais c'est vrai que le seul truc qui
m'inquiète un peu c'est que on dit
Maxime très fort en finale et tout c'est
vrai mais il avait perdu une finale un
peu dans cet esprit là contre gritou qui
a vra différente ouais c'est pas guéri
aussi quoi enfin ouais c'est vrai que
c'est le meilleur joueur de finale après
Magnus sûrement
h non ça doit doit la tenir mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu désagréable quand
même le fou le jeu sur de a le fou en B3
qui va être bien benah ouis enfin on
voit quoi l'idée de de monter le loi le
fou il va être bien euh
non c'est pas tout simple du tout du
tout c'est dommage hein bon faut qu'il
trouve un truc vite peut-être le fameux
K4 k c quoi
k445 des trucs comme ça
bizarr mais çaêche
pas c'est pour faire je c faire pr il
apprend
F6 bouff
ouais ok c'est égal mais tu vas jamais
rentr en c'est acrobatique quoi enfin
peut-être mais bah c'est pas le truc que
tu vas rentrer en forceans non tu vas
pas rentrer dedans P l'ordi a sûement
raison tout et Machin mais c'est un truc
vraiment d'ordi peut-être trouvable
mais de base je préfère regarder les
ventre je pers pas le pion mais
peut-être qu'en fait c'est trop
dangereux il faut vraiment pas jouer
passif faut vite vite rentrer dans un
truc comme ça
mais le fou en B3 qui fait une focale
sur le cavalier le pion D4 faible et le
fou qui protège le pion et qui de la
majorité les gars ça ça peut être très
grave
hein le plan est très simple tu mets le
fond B3 le R 4 après tu vois on dit à 5
à 4
ouais mais moi ce qui me fait peur en
fait c'est que si tu il va temporiser en
mettant le roi puis après va bloqué la
défense de la 4 tuas un pion sur case
blanche ça en fait pe te faire fou 3 à 4
fou à tout moment pour
tein non c'est un peu pénible
c'est dire
ouais les ordis vont vou les tenir quoi
mais bon Maxime va la tenir aussi mais
c'est un peu pénible on dit Alex F G6 ah
il a fait G6 il fait G6 ok mais F G6 il
veut peut-être juste grand rock
ouais ben mais ok enfin tuas quand même
fil oui peut-être bah faut se barer avec
le fou mten tu TR non
oui mais bon c'est S 5 c'était le bon c
en tout cas mais dur à y penser enfin
moi ça me serait pas venu à l'esprit quo
c'est chaud de partout hein mais avec
mieux on peut dire après il a 10 minutes
contre 50 donc bon évidemment sur le
même problème contre nepo
et en gros pour le moment ce qui
pourrait se profilé c'est victoire
d'Alex enco bon victoire de Ding
victoire de Ding de gritchook et ok
Maxime un peu moins bien et nul de
Maxime non gritchou c'est même pas sûr
qu' enfin gritchou c'est un peu
l'équivalent de la position de gu quoi
c'est un peu mieux et il faut
travailler mais euh je vais dire un truc
Fab tu vois quand même la différence
entre un tournoi des candidats où tu as
des belles parties de partout des idées
et cetera tousour et tous les tours au
tournoi privés qui jouent tout au long
de l'année et qui servent à rien et
qu'on critique sans enfin qu'on critique
où on dit sans arrêt il y en a trop il y
en a 10 dans l'année tu as énormément de
parties inspid je préférit avoir quatre
gros tournois dans l'année même en 10
rondes où ça joue comme ça ou genre
quand tu as les candidat on avoir un
2uxiè ou plutôt que d'avoir des tournois
privés bon ok il y a beaucoup d'argent
pour les joueurs c'est bien il a fait KK
d'aur Maxime ro de tempo euh
ouais bon ok c'est bien pour les joueurs
à chaque fois bon il a tuas des budgets
de plusieurs millions d'euros et c'est
tant mieux mais je préfère quand même
avoir deux trois beaux tournois dans
l'année et que 40 tournois insipides
quoi put j'ai juste une question il y a
pas KB2 que je suis en train de me
demander KB2 tour D2 tour D2 K4 non
j'aur fait
tour C2 qui3 ouais tour C1
ok pour pas tression pour pourquoi il a
pas fait pourquoi il A3 lui en
fait parce qu'en fait tu as quand même
plus envie de jouer ça ouais mais c'est
peutêre pas qu' y a 5 de Max peut-être
qu'il vers E3 et H5 F5 un truc je sais
pas
oui en fait tu viens quand même non mais
oui oui oui oui non mais KB2 ça a l'air
juste c'est exactement ce qu'on disait
de Guiry quoi il est pas il a pas le
niveau pour
non je sais pas ENF là c'est c'est le
premier coup quoi c'est pas ce titre
n'est pas un
athlète écoute je sais pas ok peut-être
il peut juste faire nul k B2 T 2 K4 t D3
ouais c'est uneazovski dit boulette de
guéri évidente non mais c'est sûr il
réussit pas gagner en fait il peut pas
il peut juste pas gagner une partie
d'échec c'est impossible pour lui il est
plutre et euh il rate il rate quoi euh
ouais ok ça peut juste être une petite
nul àetour avec le
cavalier ave sa tour pour les finir en
C1 ou je sais pas ce qu'elle fait quoi
non écoute max il va tenir la nul c'est
bon résultat il a été un peu sous
pression il est tranquille Alex qui a
pas pris en G qui a fait
H5 mais est-ce que c'était si
simple l'autre
variante 7
aord non mais on se fait défoncer 3
déjà ah tu veux
faire pr c'est gagnant tout de
suite mais ça je suis d'accord avec toi
ça ça se sent quoi que non mais ça sent
que c'est bien mais tu vois tu dis
ouiutêtre de is minut à la
[Musique]
penduleordi D que ça gagne ouis
d'accord c'est quoi
c'est je
comprends ça gagne mais non mais c'est
le truc tuas envie de faire sans
réfléchir mais bon tu bon es candidat tu
quandme peu et tu as 10 minut à la
pendule tu vois pas de truc clair clair
parce que même l'autre variante tout à
l'heure on une tour Mo oui pas si clair
c'est bon+ 5 donc évidemment c'est fort
mais le problème de
H5
bon c'est pas si mal tu gardes
l'initiative ou
quoiéuc
mais P il va
être maisant le pion
c'est tu vas jamais jouer ça fait ça
contre toi tu peux
perdre tu peux laag mais tu peux la
perdre àure juste tu jou que pour gag tu
jamais
ouais Maxime qui va tenir la nure donc
bonne nouvelle Alex Yenko H5 il a pas
pris il aurait fallu mais ça av l'air
compliqué puis on prend dam pr et grand
mais je comprends que l'ordi maintenant
il aime les Noirs enfin tu peux avir la
même position quasiment exactement avec
un pion blanc
H4 m c'est
ça
et et du coup NPO en prenant tous les
risques avec son style dégueulasse il
peut gagner quoi c'est fou
bah c'est double tranchant comme il joue
mais aujourd'hui je dis pas qu'il fait
une partie même c'est c'est brillant son
sacrifice de qualité non mais tu joues
brillant tu joues bien l'autre s'en fout
il te laisse les trucs brillants il joue
vite et il
te4 mais le problème c'est que ouais
c'est la pendule quoi va juste de faire
du roi B8 tour C8 il va aller prendre C
de J bon du coup chez Maxime nul signé
donc très bonne nouvelle bien c'est bien
c'est bien bien attends ilort il sort
sort des trois premières journées avec
avec de sur TR c'est un excellent début
de tournoi pour le joueur français ouais
bah surtout que on disait il arrive pas
préparer il commence par tu comm
carading c'est c'est du lourd et ok de
sur TR très bien voilà très gros début
de tour en plus il a joué contre les
deux meilleurs il lui restera lexenko
nepo contre qui il a quand même des bons
résultats même si dernièrement bon il a
perdu mais mais quand même avant ça il
avait jamais perdu une partie long
contre NPO
oui à mon avis qui peut bien lui réussir
ouais bon il y a match cont mais ça peut
bien sûr mais je par là que non mais
c'est un très bon tu fais de sur TR
toutes les jusqu'au bout tu es bien quoi
tu es plus que bien d'ailleurs
normalement tu tu es qualifi quoi
ouais non en tout cas non vraiment
vraiment un bon bon début de tournoi
après il a peut-être eu les bonnes
couleurs contre les bons joueurs mais ça
c'est gen au retour ce sera peut-être
plus c'est peut-être plus chiant d'avoir
les
blanc bonne couleurç tu leses tout le
monde les couleurs on jouer tout le
monde deux fois non mais faire plus
un c'est bon en non mais je quand tu vas
faire ok s'il se remet en forme c'est
pas tout le monde qui va le battre
d'ailleurs là on voit que Carana il va
même plutôt perdre donc en
fait voir la victoire la remettre plus
en relief d'ailleurs suivant la suite du
tournoi ouis cétait une mauvaise part F5
c'est catastrophique comme coup mais
aujourd'hui Ding il montre qu'il est
quand même toujours là non mais c'est
bien que Ding en plus il est donné le
point contre Wang qui est pas le plus
dangereux
ouais c'est quand même pas
mal du coup euh
ouais non d qu' va sûrement la gagner he
il a de pions plus mais bon il a les de
pion i Il il a plus qu'un ah mais car a
fait le truc d'aller prendre le pion 1
mais on s'en fout de ce
P ce qui plus dangereux c'était s'il
arrivait à sacrifier un truc au centre à
faire F5 à ouvrir le roi le Mauvais roi
mais là s'il y a juste G3 G2 tour1 puis3
que ce soit ça les prochains coups bah
alors tout va bien puis après on va
avancer on va mettre le C F5 ou le C C4
on va faire5
D6 on envoyer ou non c'est c'est très
très
bien
Gricha mais gra il a fait le trucess
mettre les fous des de contrôler la
colonne D et avancer après il va te
faire H4 tour h il va jouer 6h Gricha
ouais Grisha là il va jouer longtemps
ouais
donc ça c'est bon euh non ça se passe
bien de partout gen les parties sont
sympas de partout ouais c'est fini c'est
nul bon c'est beau nul en moins de 3
heures dès que je suis au commande quoi
ouais c'est beau
hein du coup je mets à maisb euh ouais n
non genre je mets le le petit ah oui les
petits trucs en
dessous bon mais NPO peut gagner quand
même il peut tout faire mais
ouais
donc ma qui en tout cas on pourra pas
dire que les joueurs de même nationalité
font de la collusion non mais ça ça
arrive pas
vraimentin qui fait de la collision les
joueurs qui font pas de collision
justement ah oui non non non mais ça
joue à fond enfin il y a eu ça il y a
longtemps mais oui ça longtemps mais là
dans les joueurs modernes le font plus
HM
donc donc donc donc est-ce qu'on peut
dire que si on met caroana de côté qui
pour moi est le favori numéro 1 les deux
joueurs les plus menaçant pour max c'est
Sacha et nepo bah pe Ding he si revient
en fort en fait faudra pas l'oublier
ouais vous avez vu qu'il a dormi pendant
la ronde 2 Grisha ça annonce rien de bon
pour lui aou Grisha tu sais on sait
jamais on sait jamais
ouais est qu'il faudrait mettre la
victoire en fait ça change
rien si pour les ça change la victire à
TR points non mais mais pas pour pour ce
tournoi là ça changera rien les joueurs
essaient de toute façon de gagner et moi
je suis contre en fait en
général parce que je sais pas
en des fois tu fais tout ce que tu peux
pour gagner tu joues 6h à fond et tu
fais que nul
et je sais pas tuas pas être pénalisé
quoi par rapport à je sais pas juste un
mec qui a fait une partie de merde
l'autre il gaffe tu gagnes bon bah tu as
trois points tu prends de points
d'avance c'est
oui
oui gritou joue dans l'ombre de Vlad ne
l'oublions pas
et la re ça donne quoi la re il y a eu
320 joueurs apparemment 323 c'est be
c'est Julien
21 103 qui en tête devant r 44 ver
pierre le Brésilien qui se bat Sam Laur
qui se bat ilurut-êre Fall la faire sur
2 he c'est
chaud on va progresser chaque jour on
fera un peu mieux on prendra le format
idéal quand on
saura est-ce que Sacha est pareil sur
les dans la vie réelle un angoissé qui
abuve un café non pour la vie réelle il
est pas très angoissé en
fait ça se passe plutôt bien quoi sa
difficulté c'est vraiment les
échecs c'est beau quand même en fait je
sais pas il adore jouer aux échecs mais
ça le stresse ça le stresse ça lui
pourrit la vie mais il aime quoi c'est
bizarre non mais ça VO que c'est un
passionné il cherche
cherche la vérité c'est me ouais je sais
mais grere c'est marrant en fait d'être
autant passionné par un truc qui te met
autant mal que ce soit niveau santé
niveau tout
quoi tu vois dans quel sens je veux dire
ça oua c'est que normalement tu aimes
bien les choses qui te font te sentir
bien ou tu es très heureux et tout quoi
tuaimes pas les trucs qui te font boire
des cafés tu arrivrives plus à dormir la
nuit c'est3 ça l'air horrible ça
comme coup maintenant
il
mais bon il a comprisre allait galérer
sur spion
C2 non mais c'est ça que j'aime bien non
mais le problème en fait une menaceut
dire parce que T prend d pr c bouff tout
le matériel ou mais ça veut dire que
rien ne va
quoi r il va jouer les compensations
mais maintenant il joue plus en
tout mais bon enfin ok il va finir par
être inquiétant mais je me dis à un
moment donné il va bien il peut perdre
deux trois parties quatre parties
d'affilé te rappelle à sof Cup
oui oui mais
nepo présent dans les gros tournois en
général et dans les gros moments
F Cup peut-être qu'en fait
ouais il joue il joue quoi bon il peut
gagner il peut gagner il gagne pas ça
pas lu changer sa vie quoi candidat ça
change ta vie quand même ah surtout
qu'il est russe donc il aura un beau
paquet de tunes si qualifi pourouer
contre Carl ouais non bon après vu son
style je le vois pas gagner ce tournoi
mais ça reste que un tourno si on joue
10 fois ça serait pas lui qui serait le
vainqueur à la fin mais une fois il peut
tu veux dire qu'on peut gagner une fois
10 10 tournois gagner 10 fois un tournoi
mais pas gag 10 tournois 10 fois quoi ou
voilà non mais je veux
[Musique]
dire un tourno faut une part de chance
déjà bon de 1 faut le niveau pour le
gagner c'est tu peux pas juste être être
nul et gagner euh donc faut le niveau
mais faut la réussite que des fois quand
tu seras mal finalement tu perds pas
euh faut que les ouvertures ça te
réussissent tu tombes dans tes prépas
que les autres connaissent mal que qu'
des trucs comme ça que je sais pas il
faut ce cette petite part de réussite en
plus c'est rare que tu gagnes juste en
défonçant tout le monde de A à Z quoi et
tu Nadal à Roland Garos des fois qui
fait ou fér buon qui a fait mais je veux
dire même les équipes au foot quand tu
es champion du monde tuas des foas sué s
bien
passé fois tu montes sur scè et tu su
quoi ah mais genre je sais pas France 98
par
exemple genre le match contreitalie but
et puis dans but en la reprise de B qui
passe à du
poans c'est finias la même équipe gagner
tu gagnes pas alors que tu prends
classique
tu Lorenzo qui s'est mal
préparé bah le T ne tient pas et tu fais
pas tu fais pas de résultat quoi tu te
sabotte après sur scène tu bouscules
tout le monde et ça se passe mal quoi
voilà donc juste pour dire NPO bah il a
il peut gagner après ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on jouait le tour plein de
fois il
estah sur le long terme il gagnera pas
le tournoi quoi
mais salut Xavier quoi comment ça se
passe en
Guadeloupe pour les gens qui partent
n'oubliez pas ce soir 20h30 sur la
chaîne blit stream vous avez le lien
juste en dessous de la vidéo il y aura
le du coup
mat Guillaume qui parle de France 90
contre le Chili mais il a pas eu de
France Chili en
98 Paraguay en 8e avec le but en noir de
l en blanc mais
il a dû
confondre et si car joue le tourno il
défonce tout bah je pense que s'il joue
le tour 10 fois il le gagne pas 10
foisin non il gagne pas 10 fois mais gag
peutêre ou il serait grand favori mais
il le gagnerait pas à chaque fois non
mais c'est genre comme wikzi quoi il l'a
pas gagné par
exemple mais ou la S Cup la s il a pas
gagné non plus
ou il aurait pu he pour le coup il était
d'ailleurs c impressionnant parce qu'il
a fait un tournoiù il était pas du tout
en forme il était inspide et il arrive
quand même à faire plus de à finir pr ex
qu bon après il a perdu comp Ding la
partie qu'on avait d'ailleurs analysé
sur sur BL stream la partie de
présentation sur sur vidéo de
présentation sur Ding mais
[Musique]
voilà on nous dit est-ce qu'il y aura
quand même l'émission vendredi à 18h
ouais bah oui quand même enfin Mathieu
de toute façon l'ouverture à mon avis va
pour te raconter plein de trucs hein
même si on a déjà fait des choses les
nouveautés non ça sera pointu ça sera
c'est un autre angle d'approche ça
peut-être pas regarder la partie en
entier mais je sais pas il va nous faire
un truc bien ma c'est
sûr tu vas regarder j'imagine d'ailleurs
ouais ouais ouis je vaiser c'est
sûr et dame des4 il il y a plus 330 pour
Ding mais c'est c'est
ok il
va l'espoir de carwana
c'esting 10 minutes mais M
oui c'est ça il a Cu coup il a joué
assez vite en fait il se prend pas la
tête et maintenant c'est probable que
Ding gagne en fait il va faire dame D4
cavalier F2 roi G2 et
c'est fini quoi
exactement après faut encore convertir
techniquement mais mais le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a pas eu de trou d'air
dans les
calculs et ok ça va ça devrait bien
passer pour lui quoi donc ça ça va être
fait Grou ça va être la partie au long
cours avec la finale à mon avis celleel
qui va durer jusqu'à 18h ouais donc on
viendra dessus c'est une finale donc
onexlique les enjeux il y a un pion
isolé passé pour noir mais les Blancs
ont la paire de fou et le truc c'est que
il contrôle complètement les colonnes
ouvertes et donc gritou va vouloir après
aller envoyer ses pions et il adore
faire ça en plus monter le RO monter la
position en fait ouais et faire du H5 G5
à un moment donné et ça ça peut se
gagner vu la gritchou pour ces trucs là
c'est le seul avec Carlsen qui a une
technique où il peut vraiment faire mal
non
ouais ouais ouais il est très bien pour
ça il adore en fait longtemps il s'en
fiche il est en maîtrise et l'autre
partie c'est
celle-là à
voir je mets NIP gros favori
ouais il va y avoir un gros je penseon
peut un peu rester làdessus parce qu'il
reste 3 minutes 29 à Alpo qui a 51
minutes mais il va pas se mettre à
réfléchir quand même quoi non mais il
manquera plus que ça
quoi
doncing qui va peut-être avoir le 10
quoi de Mazo ce soir
du
coup on va voir com comment ça se finit
la partie sil convertit sil convertit
proprement mais il pourrait se retrouver
avec un 10 il menace le
10o
m face une prépa de dingue de Fabiano il
reste meilleur que lui mais c'est
impressionnant est-ce que c'est on nous
demande c'est un bon résultat par M pour
mvl oui c'est c'est un excellent
résultat oui en fait Carana qui est le
fav numéro 1 du coup ça le fait chuter
et Ding bon il a quand même con 0 sur de
alors ça va le remettre en salle dans le
tournoi mais il y aura du
chemin qui rattrape il a un point de
retard sur Max même
s' donc un point ça seend pas comme ça
gagner des parties on sait pas
enfin
donc pas plus de français dans le top 10
mondial c'est déjà pas d'en avoir un en
vrai on est nul quoi qui dit
ple c'est vrai que forcer la nul direct2
c'est
incroyable c'est vra c'est incroyable je
comprs pas non je pense qu'il a voulu
faire nul en fait je pense qu'il s
volontairement oui mais je sais mais je
sais mais c'est ça qui est très pleutre
si tu oublies oublies tu disain je suis
con c'est pas pleutre oubl mais quand
même F B3 de sauter sur la nul plutôt
dans la partie je peux comprendre mais
là c'est fou
heinou ah il a expé en conférence de
presse un truc Mao bah si tu si tu sais
ce qu'il a ah que pour lui c'est égal et
donc il a fait nul direct ok
euh ben oui mais bon force ton
adversaire à trouver qui 5 B7 quoi il le
fait enfin c'est quand ils ont drit
proposer nul quand en fait 40e 40e bah
pire le 40e qu'est- que je te dise c'est
beau quand même d'être tellement pleutre
que tu veux faire nul direct
en fait encore ton le trouve le B7 après
tant mieux on prend
puis bon ok apparemment Max a confirmé
il l'aurait trouvé mais au pire nul un
quart d'heure plus tard voilà
mais mais bravo 44 du coup qui a gagné
la re ah bravo Julien
21 du coup chaque jour il y aur une Aren
14h je pense ok quand même 3 personnes
qui sont ven jouer donc bon ouais et
puis peut-être plus la prochaine fois
parce qu'ils seront au courant parce que
là en fait c'est un peu été fait comme
ça quoi sur un coup de et AK fini 24e
c'est très bien bravo et du coup il y
aura un DVD à gagner alors on va voir on
va voir on va voir un peu ce comment
s'est passé j'ai juste peur de la gruge
mais bon normalement chesscom il il
banne dans ces cas-là
ouais bon compte sur
vous
très bien jou c'est le coup de la
partieoup person plus les candidat je
sais pas en même temps c'est quand même
long ça par 6 he avoir un petit truc
pendant une heure ou de oui c'est ça tu
peux écouter un peu
ton ce qui se
passe his de vous divertir un petit peu
pendant
quoi non tu
rest est-ce que je peux vous éclairer
sur le
Coupard non c'est le D4 de Maxime qui
est pas resté passif dans la position
qui arrive à s'activer mais ça après
c'est plutôt pas mal passé pour lui pour
le coup JOJ qui a pas une idée plutôt
intéressante de faire la moyenne sur
tous les tournois et de peêtre de donner
des points pour les 10 premiers ets le
vainqueur du truc ok mais il faudra le
commcer plus enfin des gens il vont
peut-être pas jouer tous les jours je
sais pas bon réfléchir tant pis faut
être
ouais
alors alors question de paranoïia
qu'est-ce que les joueurs peuvent s'être
mis d'accord avant le tournoi pour
apprendre une partie par arranger sur le
tournoi bah théoriquement c'est possible
mais normalement c'est censé ne pas
arriver mais après tu peux voir de
l'arrangement partout enfin au tennis tu
peux t'arranger au fout tu peux
t'arranger enfin tu peux avoir des
matchs arrangés partout mais normalement
c'est pas censé arriver surtout dans ces
tournois il y a il y a pas vraiment de
soupçon sur qui que ce soit mais
théoriquement c'est toujours possible
hein non mais après qu'est-ce que tu vas
rranger tu fais nul c'est rien
d'arranger la partie spécialement tu te
mets d'accord tu apprends pas par cœur
mais enfin tu fais de nul si tu veux
absolument pas jouer contre quelqu'un
mais mais là c'est pas le cas enfin
enfin s'il y a un tournoi faut pas le
faire c'est celui-là en fait parce que
là en fait le but c'est juste de le
gagner le tournoi
oui donc tu vas prendre toutes tes
chances tout le
temps tu peux pas ranger si la boulette
un peu
aussi est-ce que c'est autorisé non
c'est pas autorisé de d'arranger les
parties mais juste ok c'est tu peux pas
contrôler en
fait même le r peut-être arranger voilà
ah mais un coup de téléphone une petite
discussion t'arrange très facilement un
truc tu pourrais faire gagner des
paquets de pâes s'il te plaîtêtre du
papier toilette
j'ai pas compris en fait l'engouement
pour le PQ en fait Mo non plus c'est
dans tous les pays du mondeok les PES je
comprends c'est pour
manger mais c'est partout en Russie
c'est
pareil c'est marrant est-ce qu'il aur pu
donner non il aur pas pu dans les règles
même il est encore quand même assez loin
de non pour avoir W card fallait euh
fallait av rempli certaines conditions
c'est-à-dire soit être 3e de la Coupe du
monde soit être premier non qualifié à
euh à Hofman soit premier non qualifié
au
ho et euh et donc bon ben ils ont pris
alexenko euh alors après max çait
quelque part plus mérité entre
guillemets parce qu'il a il remplissait
deux des conditions sur trois mais il
suffit d'en remplir une et leenko
remplissait une vu qu'il a fait un très
bon tournoi of
et euh puis comme il est russe le
sponsor russe il a voulu prendre un
Russe voilà mais c'est pas sorti de
nulle part pour l'enko
quoi mais pour le coup il fitj il aurait
rien rempli du tout comme condition donc
juste zéro chance que ça
arrive
non
ah est-ce qu'on peut voir où est la
partie de Ding bah écoute c'était
complètement gagnant on va voir où ça en
est bah il a fait G3 dame
D4 ouais bon Carana il essaie de
l'embêter avec la dam H3 qui av évité
pour l'instant le roi F2 tour qui rejoue
F2 RO2 c'est fin mais bon il va quand
même essayer de s'arranger
quoi c'est juste fini et gritou il
envoie le truc pous les pions bon ça va
êre longue TR ça va durer bon on va
rester sur ça normalementp il va jouer
deux trois coups rapides je
pense bon après n ilut prendre son t
temps aussi à se dire bon sert plus rien
que je joue vite pour le faire craquer
il a déjà craqué quelque part et je peux
essayer d'être propre pour convertir
ouais il peut il peut faire ça parfois
juste tu tu réfléchis bien quoi après
c'est pas si simple à gagner malgré tout
la position parce que tu as qu'une
colonne g pour l'instant pas trop de
faiblesse pe tu peux perdre
H6 mais en tout cas NPO qui est plus en
danger de perdre tu peux plus perdre si
une source tu vas gagner mais après
peut-être jouer un jour avec F6 essayer
de bon il va le truc c'est qu'il a quand
même à 5 qui peut arriver un jour quoi
pour ouvrir de l'autre côté ou donc en
fait même NPO je pense ça l'arrangera
d'échanger les dames s'il pouvait alors
attends on me dit de checker SL attends
c'est Sam qui est venu attends il y a ça
il y a Sam qui est venu estce qu' on a
fait une connerie ah bon non je sais pas
on va voir ce qu'il écrit on ne sait pas
il doê en sueur Sam
B il écrit sur on le voit non non mais
je est en train d'écrire ah
d'accord ah il qu'il veut peut-être
rejoindre le truc en français
ah veut passer je lui ferai la place
bien
volontiers
attendez je envoyer un lien zoom
quoi
non mais tu peux Mme rester en fait avec
ce système pardon tu peux tu peux même
le laisser avec ce système
oui mais on va pas parler à TR c'est
bien qu'il soit
là on va voir on va voir ce que
dit attends je vais je vais directement
lui envoyer le lien en fait je vais
t'enlever à la une seconde vas-y vas-y
enlève-mi ah je vais directement envoyer
le lien
euh je
vais je vais envoyer le lien
direct
attends plus qu' bien c'est que là
maintenant ma caméra n'est plus flou
quoi gros progrès dans le dans le stream
oui qu'on l'a
enlevé
ah en fait ça attends
second c'est que il a raison il a raison
quoi nouvelle émission max
ok je crois que c'est bon et je crois
que je peux remettre ta
cam super
ouais ok du coup j'ai déjà envoyer le
lien au moins il se débrouille et puis
max il arrivera par hasard quoi ouais
quand il veut parce que j'ai déjà joué
max mais il y a très longtemps je crois
que j'ai pas joué depuis
2007 truc comme ça du coup si si si si a
Sami dans le chat et que tu veux
partager
sur sur Facebook et dire que Max VI a
parler de sa partie c'est cool quoi
ouais ou peut-être pas je peut-ê tu veux
parler de de haricovert ou je sais pas
ah ben je pense qu'il va surtout parler
de haricover mais bon peut-être peut
donner de trois mots tu parlais de
pourquoi des quat pourquoi à la fin
c'est égal de trois trucs intéressants
quoi black il mieux vaut laisser mvl se
concentrer oui en fait si c'est lui qui
demande c'est peut-être que il est
confiné dans son hôtel que il s'ennuie
qu'il passe sa journée dedans et en fait
tu peux pas rester concentré H24 dans ta
chambre d'hôtel on dit oui je dois être
très concentré je ne dois rien faire
enfin je peux comprendre aussi il a
juste envie de venir parler avec les ris
de toute façon il regarde en rediffusion
les les trucs quoi très heureux quoi non
mais surtout que demain en plus c'est
jouris de repos donc ouais il veux juste
passer discuter un petit peu et il va
pas compter pendant 8h je pense qu'il va
passer un quart d'heure 20 minutes enfin
le temps qu'il veut en fait s'il a envie
de parler 3h il fait mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit l'objectif il joue pas
demain voilà il veut venir un peu pe il
ve faire une émission
max du coup pendant une heure quoi ils
ont toutes les nouveautés ou voà ce que
j'avais préparé j'avais préparé ça
contre les res serait B qu' disent ça
quoi je va joue ça les parti pédagogique
contre les r gros prépa bon je me suis
est-ce que je sors contre Guiry ou pas
je dangé fait quoi
ok à 5 joué par
N pas
mal pr tempo bon logique en même temps
parce que tu veux les pas laisser au
noir le choix de faire A4 même et de se
donner un pion passé voir même de faire
à et afféblir toute la structure et
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire du coup roi
B7
tour8 je pense
hein je pense qu'il veut compliquer la
position à mort avant le avant la fin du
Z note h il a d calculer tu vois je tu
peux préparer à 5 mais il a dû se dire
je vais pas préparer je vais jouer le
zite quoi ouais très npesque
ouais c'est
npoesque non mvl affronte les abonnés
pépous en attendant la prochaine journée
serait beau quoi ce n'importe quoi
adverses de mvl en
S puis il joue ses prépas là pour tester
un peu se
chauffer c'est bon quand il fait comme
Mathieu quand il sort toutes les
prépas d prend à 5 il a-t-il les
Championnat du Monde desche 960 bah il y
en a eu l'année dernière c'était
organisé par chesscom et ah oui la dam
prend F7 en fait
ouais mais il veut faire d'AM à
de mais il y a pas un perpè si ben si on
dira quoi
je joue vite c'est bon t'inquiè
pas mais c'est quoi l'idée en fait a
forcément une autre
idée sera en fait juste con
quoi non mais c'est
extraordinaireou alors
juste égale du
coup
pourquoi mais ça j'ai jamais vu ça en
fait tu es un peu mieux tu peux presser
ok c'est peut-être chaud mais tu peux la
jouer pendant
longtemps et tu vas juste faire nul quoi
mais là il peut pas avoir l'idée de
faire tourger
7 ils font quoi dans ma rue là et si je
fais
tourouattends des trucs bizarres dans ma
rue c'est te dire je sais pas il y a un
truc qui fait beaucoup de bruit qui
passe quoi
mot de camion pas
merde do grand pr il do me leses
Ann
c'est beau quoi tu découvres le chat qui
pense que firouja va être champion du
monde alors que toi sais pas quoi je lui
souhaite d'ailleurs par je trouve qu'il
joue bien il est talentueux mais c'est
pas parce que tu es jeune et talentueux
qu'on va dire ah bah vas-y passe avant
tout le mondeah va mériter ta place même
Carl quand il était champion du monde en
2013 était déjà num mondial depuis 3 ans
il était pas arrivé à qualifier pour la
finale champion du monde par G pas les
candidats ou machin c'est juste on va
pas te donner le titre sur un plateau
parce que parce que tu es jeune quoi je
suis très surpris de la décision de NPO
hein moi aussi bon on verra ce qu'il dit
aux interview aussi quoi mais du coup
nul ok bon alors grichard on reviendra à
la fin ça va durer des
plombes mais déjà ça un peu modifié
parce que ah il a claqué une pièce car
euh que jeou pour Grisha ce que ça a
changé c'est qu'il a échangé un fou
quand même donc il y a plus la paire de
fou ok quand il l' a fait F4 pour le
défoncer il a juste claqué en F4 et bon
il va perdre
mais va juste gagner maintenant enfin là
c'est de plus en plus sûr mais je non
mais c'est piè tu veux faire tour G1 fou
F3 plus tris coup à jouer avant le 40e
et il a toujours pas baissé en à la
pendule et bon enfin ça a pas l'air dur
du tout à jouer quoi B tu joues que des
coups normaux tout va bien il y a pas il
y a aucun piège
quoi c'est marrant quoi est-ce que c'est
la preuve que les Russes doivent tous
faire nul entre ouais je je pense c'est
la preuve du complot russe là Fab de
quoi la N de
p je pense que là il y a le nouvel ordre
mondial qui est sur le coup enfin je
pense c'est c'est un complot euh
international ouais ouais ouais là cette
nul à mon avis ça ça prouve beaucoup de
théories peut-être la terre est plate
grâce à cette nulle
quoi
c'est les gens estiment que c'est le
prochain champion du monde bon ben on
lui donne sa qualification cadeau fait
très attention à Huracan du coup c'est
vent donnons-lui le titre d'ailleurs ah
oui on avait raison il champion du monde
il a fé le
titre non mais et ben il peut l'être
enfin c'est clairement le plus gros
espoir il joue hyper bien il est
fort donc tout ce que je sa c'est d'y
arriver mais après bah qui passe par le
chemin pour y arriver il y a pas de
raison qu'il arrive pas du coup sil est
si fort que ça il peut gagner les Grands
Prix il peut gagner le truc et puis du
coup après il faudra gagner les
candidats et puis voilà c'est pas très
dur en fait non B qui est pas d'accordus
vraiment un complot il dirait à alenko
de perdre ses parties contre les deux
autres à chaque fois oua mais il y a pas
de complot quoi non mais en fait
peut-être que ce serait trop visible
s'il faisit ça donc du coup il une
peut-être on fait un compl inversé on va
laisser gagner alexen je t'emmerde on va
laiss faire unemi contre les autres
que au MO ce serait trop gros si on pas
arrangé ouis du coup on arrange enant
des nuls et au moins c'est beaucoup
moins gros
quoi c'est beau quoi Robert interview MV
je pense qu'on va bientôt avoir MV
ouis c'est
la on peut pasambul ici non ici on pas
d'ambul l'UL ce soir
qu mais reste quand a Maxime il va venir
il va venir parler quoi oui Mo ça F ma
petite pause il pas problmeinvie un peu
parce que TR je sais pas je jamais que
c'est bon truc en a un qui parle qui
parle trè tu fas une
pauseo fa qui a kiffé
l'ambuless fastique
l'ambul il faut que l nous fasse des
nouvelles animations là pere une anim
avec mvl quoi je sais pas ce qu'on
pourrait
faire je sais
pas que je acheter du PQ non ça va puis
franchement je vais pas faire un stock
de PQ pour un stock de
P tout la h pour pour
Carana serait dans les parties en fait
vraiment le droit dans les v parti
d'appeler l'ambuless quoi à certains
moment c'est gà fa l'ambuless elle se
prend la la la la voiture de ton t Kef
quoi et en fait l'ambuless elle dégage
non mais non bravo Ding quoi je suis
très content pour
lui ça t'a rendu heureux bah
ouais enfin j'aurais été heureux que
carolana le défonce aussi pour la beauté
de sa pripa la bouté de la partie mais
se retour en situation Ding qui se remet
dans le tournoi
et cetera et cetera c'est c'est c'est
beau donc c'est encore mieux en fait
donc oui très
heureux tu nages dans le bonheur
ou bon on va pas
exagérer mais non je suis content ça va
être beau qu tu tout sourire toute la
soirée est-ce que elle sourit des
fois ouais toujours bonne humeur pour le
coup moi je suis heureux de voir un 10
de maetovic c'est beau quoi qui déjà
acheter les 10 ça me fait marrer
aussi ah du coup peutêtre après faudra
des 11 ou des 12 sur 10
c'esto plus de
fin quel scandale il y a pas de
scandale attends il y a Maxim qui
m'écrit attends sur Messenger du coup je
eny le est chaud c'est bon attends
attends
attends je pe rester secondes lui dire
bonjour féliciter machin a pas de souci
mais mais après
je tu lui donnes 200 g de haric vert
ouais attends il va venir cool non c'est
sympa de sa part is franchement c'est ça
passe crème Maxim
franchement il fait plaise c'est
la
il va te remplacer
quoi c'est bon prochain enfant de
s'appelle Ding bon dans 9 mois passer le
temps av passe le temps à fond quoi
c'est pour ça j'ai remarqué hier entre
8h et 8h30 il ne répondait plus quand je
lu
écr des choses beaucoup plus intéressant
à faire
ma ça va
salut
pas alors ça prépa du coup pour la
partie tu as bien suivi euh 200 g de
ricover aujourd'hui ah non
malheureusement euh à l'hôtel euh on
prend ce qu' nous donne en tout cas le
midi le soir je me fais un peu plaisir
généralement euh mais le midi c'est
c'est eux qui font le menu en gros et ça
mange pas donc là ce midi c'était quoi
c'était soupe un minestron donc genre
euh soupe de légume et des des haricots
mais blancs ouais donc euh ouais c'est
Paso c'était du cabillo
euh pomme de terre sauté et euh et deux
petits brocolis pour faire oh c'est
presque c'est presque du Poé pas quand
même ouais mais c'était pas trop gras il
y avait pas trop d'huile dans les pommes
de terre sauté ah bah il en faut un
petit peu un petit peu mais c'était
léger quoi c'était léger donc et cette
game alors tu veux nous raconter en la
montrant tu veux nous raconter au RAL em
enfin je sais pas comme tu veux fais
comme chez toi enfin tu es un peu chez
toi en fait quelque part ouais non mais
là bon après alors justement j'allais
j'allais checkquer le moment où je me
suis planté dans la prépa mais j'imagine
qu'il y en a un parce que on a pensé que
c'était le cavalier des7 mais on sait
pas
ouais enfin bon après on veut pas on
veut pas dévoiler les secrets hein
mais des parties avec tour D8 bon ouais
ouii non mais après bon c'était pas
dramatique donc je sais pas mais non ça
av pas l'air d'être très grave juste à
la fin il a pas été un peu pleutre de
faire nul comme ça euh
ouais B alors le truc c'est que en fait
après tour des2 déjà je peux je peux
prendre en D1 oui non mais je voulais
dire après k C4 ouais ça mais est-ce
qu'il doit pas plutôt faire fou B3 ouais
mais K a 5 F2 et là je voulais même k
prend B3 ouais puis on prend F6
exactement ok tu avis tout calculer on
prend F7 r F3 tour B8 ouais oua euh non
euh si si R F3 tour B8 ouais ouis euh ou
je me trompe bon peu importe mais on
avait vu une ligne un peu dans ce dans
ce sens là avec l'ordi et ça faisait nul
en force ouais
ouais bon c'est peut-être pas le plus
simple he euh après oui dans certains
cas en fait parce que si je mets
directement la tour en B4 on sait jamais
il y a du G4 F5 avec le rang E4 c'est un
peu désagréable ah voilà euh oui non
repr prend F6 bien sûr 4 et là tour 8
oui bien sûr çaou prends et tour 2 tour
2 tu rentres bon tu avais tout vu en
gros ouais non après on voit pas tout
hein mais on je ça sent que il y a pas
il y a pas de drame après ce qu'il
aurait pu faire à la fin c'est jouer
tour tour
E2 tour C2 je veux dire après k C4 tour
C2 k E3 tour C1 alors déjà k prend D1
évidemment c'est nul mais je me suis dit
bon là j'ai k D5 quand même k C3 ouais
on av pens à ça tu atttaques le pion il
fait G3 tu mets le K en C3 tu pousses à
5 et tu le tu le manges quoi bah r G7 F6
déjà je vais commencer par faire ça
peut ça c'est pas c'est un truc que j'ai
envie de faire généralement dans cette
position après en théorie je peux
souffrir un tout petit peu mais bon
après la finale de tour aussi elle doit
être nulle donc j'étais pas sûr de
comment faire euh mais comme j'ai vu je
pouvais d'abord jouer au k C4 et tu vois
tu gagnes de temps euh de coup pour le
40e et en plus tu tu proposes la
répétition quoi
ouais il s'est jeté dessus
quoi ça je sais pas mais
mais c'est cool mais raconte-nous un peu
comment tu te sens comment
commenter comment ça comment tu es
arrivé à éctherinbourg comment ça se
passe pour toi si tu es bien installé
bien établi euh
ou alors bien installé bien installé bon
c'est je cache pas que je vais me sentir
un un peu seul là pendant les il me
reste deux bonnes semaines à me sentir
un peu seul mais après j'ai pas mal de
soutiensin de toute façon de la part de
tout le monde que ce soit en France mes
potes ma famille voilà je reçois des
messages et cetera j'ai réussi à trouver
comment m'occuper aussi donc ça c'est
important ouais re Netflix j'ai pas mal
de j'ai pas mal d'échec à faire aussi
parce que bon malheureusement j'ai pas
eu j'ai pas eu le même prép les autres
enfin je dis malheureusement et
heureusement parce Queen fait tu arrives
pas un peu plus frais que les autres du
coup genre j'arrive beaucoup plus frais
j'ai l'impression ouais ouais tu es pu
toute fa ben en fait oui on voit la
différence tout de suite par rapport à
l'année dernière où j'étais je traînais
ma peine
euh sur toutes les fins de tournoi sur
euh parce que après c'est physique c'est
aussi psychologique quoi quand tu es pas
chez toi pendant pendant 6 mois sur les
7 derniers c'est à un moment tu c'est
dur c'est dur de
tenir donc ouais donc et puis là j'ai eu
un break de 2 mois j'ai fait un peu ce
que j'ai voulu je me suis fait des
petites vacances et cetera et puis au
final bon ben j'arrive évidemment moins
bien préparé que les autres mais bon
après plus Étienne et et mon on fait on
fait du bon ta jusque là donc ça ça on
touche du
bois
donc du coup ça c'est pas trop vu jusque
là que que j'étais moins bien préparé
que les autres voire pas du tout à part
contre Fab un petit
peu et encore ouais encore c'est quand
même passé tranquille au final oui
c'était pas c'était pas un drame quoi
mais après on sent qu'il est bien
préparé qu'il en veut même si il est il
a dû pousser un peu le bouchon
aujourd'hui fais voir ce qu'il donne là
juste il est ouais il va la perdre ouais
il a complètement poussé le bouchon mais
après c'est vrai c'est tentant parce que
que Ding qui prend tellement de temps et
une position qui a l'air quand même
prometteuse mais là ouais il a il a
poussé le bouchon et puis en plus oui D
qui avait perdu les deux premières donc
forcément envie de ça lui a donné envie
de le taper
ouais fallit arriver à la ronde d'avant
c'est pas de chance quoi ouais c'est pas
de chance et donc ça ouais là-bas et sur
place du coup vous êtes en quarantaine
ça se passe comment VO on n'est pas
vraiment en quarantaine déjà on peut
sortir dehors si on le souhaite pour
l'instant il y a pas trop de cas en tout
cas officiellement en Russie bon il y en
a sans doute un peu plus que les 150
officiels
mais notamment ici à ycaterine B il y en
a a priori aucun il y en a quelquesuns à
Tumen à perme qui sont pas loin ouais
mais
euh de toute façon on se doute que ça va
finir par arrivriver mais bon pour
l'instant pour l'instant on n pas
confiné alors après moi je je je donne
le bon exemple au français donc je sors
très très peu de l'hôtel
ouais euh donc sans doute même moins que
les
Français le troll ça ça commence à
troller ça commence à troller nous on
est vraiment bloqué hein chez nous tu
verras quand tu rentres c'est un peu
spécial ouais enfin j'ai j'ai vu
quelques quelques trucs qui qui me
faisait dire que bon tout le monde me
sentait pas concerné par par les mesures
malheureusement
euh mais oui je parle pas de toi je sais
que toi tu es un poép tu as compris ah
moi je suis un pop je suis pas sorti
depuis 4 jours je veux pas sortir avec
c'est bon ah j'ai 12 kg de pâes à la
maison ENF si jamais si jamais c'est
juste il te manque juste l' antiatomique
quoi ça c'est ça tu l'as pas encore
construit tu as pas eu le j'ai pas eu le
temps mais tu sais que biy est bien
établi aussi pourir parler à
B donc si tu j'étais chez lui j'étais
chez lui bon malheureusement
personnellement j'encourage pas pas à
faire tout ce stock de course mais
bon mais by by il est très équipé aussi
ouais oui mais bon enfin si tout le
monde avait suivi son exemple ça aurait
causé quelques petits DRAM non mais
c'est beau quand il est venu chez moi je
lu fait acheter des lentilles je sais
pas si les a acheté jou très important
aussi prendsant moins 6 kg
quoi voilà donc bon blague à part
euh donc ouais non je suis très peu
sorti de l' bon là pour la journée de
repos je vais quand même sortir un peu
parce que sinon ouais non et pour la
prise de température du coup ça se passe
comment il vous mett un truc dans
l'oreille ou non alors c'est le bip
frontal quoi enfin tu vois ils ont je
sais pas comment ça s'appelle le
thermomètre il met sur le front et ça se
passe non il le met pas sur le front tu
vois il te le bip sur le front mais à
distance ah et ça prend la température
ça ouais mais c'est les trucs qui font
dans les aéroports notamment d'accord et
et du coup toi tu tu es en dessous de 37
tout le temps quoi c'est
ouais c'est bah alors après j'imagine je
sais pas comment ça marche mais je crois
que tu dois
rajouter un certain peut-être 0,5 degrés
à la température que le truc donne mais
jusqu'à présent oua j'ai jamais j'étais
entre 361 et 365 quoi enfin ça va voilà
j'ai jamais fait le j'ai pas fait le 37
ans de Fabi qui a causé qui a causé
l'intervention quand même du président
de la Russie et du président de la fil
sérieux ah ouais quel truc de ouf non
mais bon toi tu es toi tu es un athlète
quoi tu on att on attend le premier 38
avec impatience ça va finir par arriver
tu
penses un 38 je veux dire sur un tournoi
de 3 semaines joueurs
ouais va pas y avoir un mec qui va
choper un peu de fièvre à un moment bon
surtout qu'on est quand même en hiver
donc ouais ouais moi je pousse depuis le
début du tournoi mais bon ça enfin même
depuis une semaine et demi mais mais ça
ça c'est habituel chez moi donc bon les
premiers tests sont tous revenus
négatifs euh mais ça finira forcément
par arriver ouais et gritou c'est Gricha
qui va le prendre en premier c'est sûr
il est tout le temps malade pour les
temp de toute façon ouais
enfin pareil moi je tousse tout le temps
mais mais j'ai déjà chopé alors pas pas
le coronavirus évidemment mais j'ai déjà
chopé un truc avec les symptômes
complètement similaires l'année dernière
ouais mais çaen était t-être ind
différent il y a plusieurs
corona non mais je sais en fait je
l'avais chopé à Vegas donc je pense que
c'était la clim je sais pas qui m'
envoyé un virus un sal virus quoi
vraiment j'étais quasiment 3 semaines
cloué bon évidemment j'avais j'avais pas
été très bon j' j'avais pas appelé le
docteur parce que parce que je le fais
jamais tuavais fini en pneumonie et tout
j'étais pas bien bon pneumonie non mais
j'avais une tou super sèche pendant 3
semaines ça faisait mal au poumon et
tout bon ouais j'étaisécrit dans le chat
mvl le patient zéro quoi ça y est on l'a
trouvé ouais le patient zéro
exactement SAF que je suis pas allé en
Chine depuis donc pas sûr du coup euh
pour revenir un peu sur le tournoi tu
joues qui là dans les dans les rondes à
venir euh ben écoute je crois que je
joue Sacha donc ça va être un duel de
malade ouais ça envoyer du lourd à
chaque fois vos parties ça envoie du
lourd ça va être du très très lourd euh
donc Sacha et tu es blanc noir tu sais
j'ai les blancs ouais tuas les blancs ça
va tu vas PIR le mettre sous pression et
comment comment on peut comment on peut
te soutenir t'aider et tout est-ce que
ça te fait plaisir quand on t'envoie des
des messages pour les gens qui parce que
tuas tu as plein de tu as plein de
supporters là tu en as plein d qu' si on
dit attention que Ding était pas en
forme que tu as gagné parce qu'il a fait
une gaffe ou quoi on se fait défoncer
par le chat de toute façon on peut rien
dire quoi tu vois on a on a peur quoi on
est
où non mais après oui on peut enfin vous
pouvez tous m'envoyer des M essage ça
oui ça me fait plaisir après je réponds
pas forcément pendant le tournoi je
réponds pas non mais ça on sait que si
les gens ça fait juste plaisir de
t'écrire à les max on kiffe ou quoi ça
ça te fait un petit t encouragement quoi
ouais ouais non bien sûr bon après de
toute façon tu répondras pas je n'en ai
rien à de ton
encouragement tiens je vais te bloquer
d'ailleurs toi àe non mais non non pour
pour que je bloque quelqu'un faut
généralement faut faut le
chercher faut le chercher encore et
encore quand on m'insulte parfois ça me
fait rire attention mais faut bonne
humeur faut pas que j'ai perdu mais
ouais tu sais que c'est c'est les
tennismanans qui ont des problèmes avec
ça d'ailleurs ils sont obligés de se
barrer Twitter je sais pas si tu avais
lu ça c'est les gens qui perdent les
paris sont très énervés et il les insult
ouais mais c'est ils sont complètement
fou alors moi au contraire une fois il y
a quelqu'un qui m'a
remercié non ah que tu gagné et que j'ai
gagné ouais j'ai gagné
euh
euh en fait en fait j'aiis gagné à
Bidjan la section Blitz du Grand chest
tour ouais et il y a un mec qui m'a
envoyé son bat il av quand même paré 2
balles quô à 14
c'est en même temps quand à 14 je trouve
c'était assez value pour du Blitz mais
bon ouais il y avait de la value mais
par il il était content
ouais 200 balles 200 balles ouais be
Paris il a pris 2800 balles grâce à toi
quand même
2600 ah oui 2600 parce que mais enfin
oui 2600
oui parce que c'était pas à la côte
anglaise c'était côe française ouais je
crois du coup c'est génial quoi discion
de connaisseurs Fab est-ce que tu as des
questions pour Max non pas spécialement
mais ben c'est très bien enin tout ce
que vous avez dit quoi c'était cool non
je juste le encourager max à fond c'est
cool c'est bien là pour l'instant yes
merci en course
ouais tu es en course tu es chaud quoi
tu veux regarder jeter un coup d'œil
avec nous tu veux te barrer euh manger
des haricot non je veux bien regarder
vite fait de toute façon là je vais je
vais manger à l'hôtel ce soir donc ben
écoute ça avec plaisir du coup Ding
c'est combien ah en plus le 40e est
passé ah
oui il reste un coup mais c'est au noir
oua
ouis bon va falloir penser à à jeter
l'éponge bientôt je pense parce que il y
a juste zéro contre
jeu donc ça bon d'accord c'est gagnant
et et Sacha Mazo nous a dit dans le chat
il y a ou alors là on s on s'est marré
un peu avec Aniche puisqueen
fait on s'est dit que c'était à peu près
la même position la même finale que
anich avait eu contre moi sauf que anich
il pensait me mat donc du coup il devait
se dire il était déçu d'arriver dans
cette finale alors que Sacha c'est tout
ce qu'il espérait quoi il espérait que
ça que ça que ça depuis le le coup
numéro 1 et donc là bon il est vraiment
en train de presser après je pense
queobjectivement c'est c'est plutôt
proche de de
nul va il va il va bien presser quand
même ouais bah après faut qu'il fasse
attention parce que il lui reste h coups
à jouer alors certes c'est des coups
plutôt faciles mais il faut toujours
faire attention dans ce genre de
position que de pas laisser une chance
au noir
de
de de se dépétrer quoi bon encore une
fois bon alors par contre aujourd'hui il
s'est pas réveillé à
15h54 parce qu'en fait quand je suis
arrivé à la salle il était 15h54
exactement et je me suis dit merde
j'arrive je suis déjà mon échitier Sacha
vient tout juste de se
réveiller mais
donc mais donc du coup non là c'est
aujourd'hui il est arrivé à l'heure on
sentait que il était plus réveillé
qu'hier et puis là par exemple c'est un
des trucs que je disais il faut qu'il
fasse un peu attention donc prise prise
si joue G5 il y a qu' qure
échecs
ah c'est joli ah c'est ce genre de truc
où tu vois tu as manque de temps tu peux
tu peux le rater comment tu as vu ça
vite
non il y avait l'ordi qui
l'indiquait d'accord mais bon sinon ça
c'est toujours impressionnant et du
coup il peut est-ce qu'il peut faire le
plan d'IER l'ordi qui disait fou1 FO 2
je crois ouais bah fou B1 c'est c'est un
bon coup ouais très très très très bon
coup je pense qu'il peut le faire c'est
son style de remettre son fou là pour
aller attaquer le pion enfin je le sens
bien quoi juste en fait je pense
toujours que Vlad on tellement tout le
temps ça du coup j'ai l'impression qu'il
va faireou très le style ça oui bah
après c'est le style de tout le monde
hein c'est même le mien c'est dire non
mais il va mais mais Sacha tu l'as pas
senti avoir un petit coup de de baisse
là après ce qu'il a raté contre Alex
cnco ou il s'est psychologiquement il
s'est bien
remis après on a on a un peu
d'expérience on a un peu de bouteille
donc bon c'est ben d'ailleurs tu vois il
prend G6 et c'est bizarre parce que
maintenant sur fou je pense que tu as tu
vas voir du G5 peut-être bientôt avec
les Noirs c'est bizarre d'échanger les
pions si
vite et voilà
tu es un po pas quand Mme P pas au
commentair quoi direct tu nous as dit le
piège et il va le sécher et faire nul
ouais après ça pousse encore un petit
peu tu t'as F prends 4 mais
bon voilà le chat en suur face à ton
expertise ouais bah c'est c'est Vlad qui
est en suur là surtout ouais mais VL mon
avis il arrêté de regarder les parties
de gritchou
quoi le con le con a encore raté quoi un
moment Étienne aussi il arrêté de
regarder mes
parties pas bien
ouais tu le mets mal tu le mets mal tu
le mets mal mais Sacha ouais mais vous
êtes vraiment copain parce qu'il a il a
dit je crois dans la conférence de
presse que s'il devait reste en
quarantaine avec un joueur ce serait toi
et du coup il non mais il lui faut un
compagnon de
picole un petit peu de votre cas on a
fait fait hein il avait raconté cette
histoire après un Grand Prix feed on
avait été évidemment sérieux tout le
tournoi et fin de la partie euh il me
dit on avait fait nul en fait il me dit
euh bah il y a evlad aussi d'ailleurs et
puis il me dit viens on va on va à Dubaï
donc non si c'était Dubaï ouais pour
boire un coup euh résultat on est arrivé
heure en retard quasiment à la à la
remise des de toute façon si VL dans le
coup et Sacha à mon avis tu beaucoup
mieux que riasf quoi mais bon l'année
dernière j'ai pas eu ce luxe parce que
je jouais tellement souvent que que je
buvais pas même à la fin des tournois
bon là si si je gagne le tournoi je
cache pas que la dernière soirée risque
d'être
belle j'imagine j'imagine à moins d'un
confinement généralisé et du coup c'est
vraiment ton meilleur entre guillemets
copains sur le circuit Sacha
meilleur copain non parce que après en
plus bon il parle très bien angl et tout
mais c'est vrai queon
euh bon il est souvent aussi avec les
Russes puis après bon il y a pas enfin
pour moi il y a pas vraiment de copain
enfin tu vois c'est des gens avec qui tu
t'entends bien et je m'entends très bien
avec Sacha mais après oui c'est pas euh
voilà on est on est très loin d'être
intime par exemple ouais mais bon sur le
circuit c'est un joueur que tuas enfin
c'est un des joueurs que tu as pris le
plus quoi voilà oui clairement non mais
il est sympa il est sympa il est marrant
ah oui ça c'est clair ouais j'ai vu ils
ont fait un petit film disais que tu
devais faire cavalier D8 échecs et qu'
prend B7 quoi parce que beaucoup plus ah
oui non et ouais oui puis que un coup
plus stylé mais oui mais c'était pas ma
meilleure idée de toute façon
cavalier k D6 k prend B7 de toute façon
en fait si j'avais vu k D8 je l'aurais
jouer parce qu'en plus ça te laisse
l'option avec6
oui mais bon c'était c'était compliqué
encore wangao il le voit le cavalier4 ou
pas ah bah j'imagine oui j'imagine qu'il
le vérifie mais il se passe quoi du coup
l'ordi il te dit de faire fou pran puis
on prend mais tourux hein ouais
ça c'est nul he puis on prend F3 je
pense que c'est nul tu fais qui tu
fais F bouffe là ouais et exement c'est
ce que je voulais tour C5 ah ouais bouff
et bouff ouais ça c'est nul
ouais estce qu'après tu ramènes leur en
C7 tu peux perdre G6 sans problème ça
c'est trivial
ouais ça l' est devenu ça c'est trivial
bon lui faire et l'autre il abandonne
pas non mais bon au d'un moment
abandonne enfin tu as perdu tu as perdu
quo sens que tu as envie de te marrer
depuis tout à l'heure nonon ça
dépcore fait je sais pas pourquoi il
joue là
je sais pas abandonne quoi
ouais mais bon
après après aussi c'est dur d'abandonner
contre quelqu'un qui a pas montré des
grandes signes de forme alors bon là il
fait une bonne partie Ding encore un
moment j'étais pas fan de ce qu'il avait
fait mais ouais c'est dur de de jeter
leséponges et puis bon c'est un comme
dirait Tart cover tu as jamais gagné une
partie en abandonnant
ouais tu peux toujours espérer qu' gaffe
B il a passé le 40e du coup avec les
Blancs a là tour C2 ouais ça risque de
faire mal ouais ouis ça va rentrer
Telata mais Fabiano il va être mal non
j'imagine quand tu sors une grosse prépa
comme ça et que tu et que tu rates
complètement la partie ça fait mal
psychologiquement plus mal qu'une autre
défaite ou c'est pareil une défaite fait
toujours mal hein donc mais là sa
nouveauté il avait dû se la préparer se
la garder se la chérir ouais mais après
il savait qu'il y avait une part de
risque dans sa nouveauté c'est
clairement un truc très très risqué qui
peut très mal tourner donc
ouais après c'est sûr que quand on
obtient une heure d'avance à la pendule
beaucoup de jeux
bon tuas une question que les gens se
posent souvent est-ce que tu regardes
les autres parties pendant la tienne
genre quand tu joues est-ce que tu
jettes un œil aux autres parties et ah
bah toujours ouais ça et tu réfléchis un
petit peu et tu tu passes un peu de
temps
quoi
oui bien sûr
euh est-ce que non ça va V je regarde un
peu dans le chat hein s'il y a s'il y a
des questions intéressante mais je vois
rien oui oui non parce que je voyais là
dans le chat justement la à propos de la
de Arian la femme de Levon donc ouais ça
c'était une nouvelle terrible bon j'ai
pris des nouvelles avant le tournoi donc
euh donc ouais
euh a priori elle va elle va un peu
mieux mais c'est sûr que bon c'est un
c'est un c'est un choc
FA elle a eu un accident de voiture
c'est ça ça vrai et du coup j'imagine
que les joueurs de haut niveau
s'inquiètent quoi un peu euh oui bah
bien sûr bon après c'est vrai queon on
na pas que ça à pensé mais c'est V
c'était quand même une nouvelle
choquante donc ouais euh c'était normal
de de prendre des news dans ces momentsl
ouais c'est sûr c'est sûr mais c'est
vrai que là là il y a plein de vous vous
devez vous isoler essayer de de vous
concentrer sur les échecs mais ça va pas
être facile il y a tellement de de
nouvelles bizarres autour entre
guillemets oui ça c'est sûr ouais que ça
doit ça do pas être facile et vous gérez
ça comme comment tuévit de lire les
sites de news Twitter et cetera pour
pour pas trop savoir ou tu t'informes
quand même au contraire pour te dire bon
ça va plus ou moins bien et genre une
fois par jour et j'y pense plus essay de
gérer ça comment
euh tu parles là du corona coron ouais
euh non mais je me tiens informé je te
dis je vois je vois ce qui se passe en
France bon aussi je m'informe auprès de
ma famille notamment de mes potes pour
savoir un peu comment ça va quand même
euh après c'est vrai que sinon quand je
suis dans ma bulle de préparation oui
j'essaie quand même de de faire
abstraction de tout le reste et puis
pendant les parties aussi c'est c'est
peut-être ça le plus compliqué c'est de
se dire c'est de rester justement focus
pendant les parties mais jusque jusque
là ça se passe bien et les autres
joueurs tu les sens un peu impactés par
ça ou pas du tout
euh ah clairement il y en a qui sont
impactés alors notamment wangao alors
bon il s'en sort bien dans le début du
tournoi
mais mais voilà on sent qu'il avait pas
envie de jouer à la base
ouais mais il est ouais genre il a peur
pour ENF on sait pas vraiment pourquoi
quoi s'il a peur pour lui pour sa
famille pour
ouais mais encore une fois lui il est
pas rentré en Chine depuis maintenant
plus de 2 mois donc ouais c'est ça
bouleversé les plans de tout le monde
notamment de Ding Len évidemment qui
s'est retrouvé qui n'est pas
sorti pendant 2 mois et demi sortir
dehors pendant
2 nous attend mais 2 mois et demi bah
quasiment non il est en quarantaine
ouaisj c'est ça qui est je crois je
crois qu'il habite d'jou enfin je suis
plus sûr euh bon bref il habite il
habitait à 500 km de l'épicentre de de
l' est pas loin ouais euh donc ouais il
est pas sorti après une fois arrivé à
Moscou bon il on fait faire un stop
pendant de semaines aussi donc ouais je
pense qu'il est juste pas sorti c'est
c'est chaud quand même
ouais c'est chaud de 2 mois et demi
c'est chaud franchement c'est chaud
franchement c'est chaud et euh
ouais de toute façon c'est ce qui nous
attend Fab il a
fait Fab s'est caché c'est bon
ah est visionnaire il nous disait non
mais moi d je peux me cacher je me cache
il plus che c'est C pleutre ça mais
depuis janvier je
t'inquièteçon ouais après oui il y avait
des raisons quand même d'être
mais pas des Gibraltar quoi ah oui c'est
ça
ouais jejà non mais arrê le tournoi
gbraltar il y avait avait des joueurs
chinois
donc je ne veux pas jouer contre un
chinois prévu de faire forfa non F non
mais je t' qu pour dégoûter ronde 2 jeou
une chinoise
quoi c'était beau ça mais le tourno de
can moi je suis pas allé voir une seule
fois je suis resté éloigné quoi au bout
d'un moment pleutre
mais bon je fais quand même très
attention c'est les Italiens après jeis
même plus voir M mes grands-parents quoi
c'est fini
quoi non ouais non en Italie c'est chaud
ce qui se passe ouais non c'est c'est
vrai en Italie c'est ouf en Italie c'est
ouf c'est ouf mes grands-parents là ils
étaient mon grand-père il peut plus
aller en Italie et tout il sent mal quoi
ouais bah ouais mais d'ailleurs euh
c'est vrai que c'est c'est un peu ce qui
nous pas Ener si on n'est pas
raisonnable nous aussi donc
ouais ouais ouais non il faut mais toi
d'ailleurs quand tu vas rentrer à mon
avis tu auras tu auras une quarantaine
obligatoire à la fin du tournoi hein tu
seras c'est possible voilà je sais pas
comment ça va se passer mais j'imagine
sur ton vol retour ils vont te ils vont
te donner un papier et tout tu pourras
plus rien à tester sur l'honneur plus
rien quoi sera obligatoire
ouais ouais oui bah après quand même
j'espère que la quarantaine je pourrais
la faire depuis chez moi quand même mais
oui tu pourras mais j'imagine
une peut-être on t'apportera de la
nourriture quoi t'inquiète pas ouais
après de toute façon c'est pas sûr que
le tournoi soit fini donc
ouais c'est quel chose que que vous avez
intégré genre les joueurs vous êtes là
en mode oui B là oui pour le moment on
joue on touche du bois et puis parce que
bon une fois que tu commences le tourno
tu as vraiment pas envie d'avoir à le
reprendre dans 6 mois ou dans 1 an ou
dans enfin et d'ailleurs enfin il y a un
truc prévu s'il y a un joueur à le
corona ah ouais c'est c'est reportter
tempo ah d'accord ok il y a Pasok et
genre s'il y a quelqu'un qui a de la
fièvre à 38 il se passe quoi genre le
matin 10h c'est chaud c'est chaud on
sait pas euh c'est selon la viis des
docteurs mais ça peut ça peut reporter
le truc pour soupçon de Corona quoi
ouais et ça ça peut être juste un ou
deux jours le temps qu'il est les le
négatif quoi
B en fait là déjà on est tous négatifs
sur le premier test du bon 14 15 mars
donc là on a un autre test qui nous
attend dans maintenant 5 jours euh voilà
ça met 3 4 jours à à obtenir les
résultats après c'est pas les h joueurs
en fait c'est tu as les joueurs
évidemment tous les médias tu as tous
les volontaires de l'organisation les
arbitres ça fait une cinquantaine de
personnes je dirais h si c'est reporté
c'est Rajab qui joue non non ça c'est
fini
hein
fait bah d'un côté il avait raison de
l'autre en fait il est il a fait son
truc sans concerter sans se concer avec
personne et une fois qu'il s'est retiré
du tournoi c'était définitif cl c'est un
peu bizarre que soit pas concerté avec
wangao d'ailleurs pour essayer déjà de
faire un truc à deux voire trois joueurs
essayer de trouver des alliés s' avaient
été trois ça aurait peut-être beaucoup
plus de fois ça oui puce que après bon
peut-être les rus ça aurit été délicat
mais
notamment Fabiano je pense
que quand tu es enfin quand tu es
Fabiano que tu es favoris
du tournoi tu as pas forcément envie
d'avoir à gérer ce genre d'incertitude
euh d'ailleurs Ding bon Ding Len c'est
un peu différent parce que lui il était
déjà en quarantaine euh bon une fois que
tu as passé la quarantaine tu as
peut-être envie de jouer bon même si
même si là ça se passe mal mais bon
encore qu'il va gagner aujourd'hui hein
attention au verdict définitif après
deux parties oui il peut là il est
complètement il se relance complètement
dans le tournoi avec la victoire
aujourd'hui ouais ah complètement ouais
et ce que j'allais dire oui par contre
aussi ce qui m'a semblé un peu bizarre
sur sur la letre de rajabov
c'était en mode pourquoi wangao n'est
pas en quarantaine bon ça je comprends
pas c'est-àdire que c'est pas son
problème c'est soit tu mets tout le
monde en
quarantaine enfin bon ok Ding pu qu'il
venait quand
mêmeon ça c'était obligatoire mais
pourquoi tu mettrais plus Wang en
quarantaine que par
exemple biano qui était euh qui a
partagé son temps entre les US l'Espagne
et l'Allemagne bon
[Musique]
ouais non mais c'est sûr que après donc
voilà c'est un peu bon c'était un peu
bizarre mais sinon bon dans les faits
oui ça ça se défendait clairement que le
tournoi des candidats pouvait être porté
il a bien failli l'être même après mais
il peut il peut même il peut même comme
tu le disais être être ajourné je sais
pas je pense que ce serait le bon mot
j'imagine journée parce que de toute
façon même si après même si même si ça
jouait pas aprèsdain de toute façon les
on est bien d'accord que les résultats
restent là pour le moment les résultats
restent oui tout à fait donc tu
reprendrais à 2 sur TR quoi quoi qu'il
en soit
euh pas dire si ça s'arrêtait maintenant
tu aurais 2/ TR il y a pas de
ouais 2 sur TR oui oui 2 sur TR
c'est bien enfin oui oui non mais de
toute façon là encore une fois he les
parties elles sont pas pour elles sont
pas pour du beurre hein de toute façon
ça c'est clair
par que bon la probabilité à mon avis
que le tournoi finisse par être àjourné
est assez forte ça dépend aussi de
l'évolution de la situation en Russie
face au
corona j'ai j'ai lu ce matin sur les
médias rus pour la première fois Poutine
il a commencé à dire solution est sous
contrôle mais nous nous interdisons
aucune mesure quoi ou quelque chose
comme ça ouais et c'est la première fois
genre avant il était tout le temps en
mode c'est sous contrôle il y a pas de
souci c'est les Européens qui font de la
propagande pour dire que il y a des cas
chez nous mais en fait non et il comm à
dire bon c'est sous contrôle donc en
fait c'est rien de grave mais mais à
tout moment ouais mais j'ai l'impression
quand même que la situation est moins
moins grave qu'ailleurs mais bon après à
terme ça peut si s'il font rien de
spécial ça peut devenir
comme comme dans surtout que bon leur
système
de de santé est quand même plus que
douteux quand même je parle pas à Moscou
je parle dans ouis dans les
plus éloigné hein je pense enfin j'étais
mieux placé que moi pour le dire mais
ouais ça peut ça peut êre mais c'est FCL
quoi ça peut être un peu spécial ou ça
peut bien se passer ou bien se passer
t'inquiète pas mais ouais ça peut être
un peu fol cl mais non à Moscou en vrai
c'est bien mais dans les dans les
régions ça peut être un peu un peu
spécial c'est ça ouais et pour la source
c'était sur lenta. rue pour les gens qui
visent en
russe j'adoris sur Twitter j'ai un truc
comme ça la source t'inquiète c'est mon
tonton qui travaille à la CIA voilà quoi
genre la source la source t'inquiète
quoi c'est beau quoi
ouais alors ok ça va faire nul du coup
je bien tour C2 prend et tour
C5 ouais bon après tour F ça mange pas
de pain quand même ou toi tuaimes pas
donner de pion bah ça dépend quel pion
mais le pion F3 j'ai envie de le garder
quelques coups Maisie fais tour H7 tu
fais t C2 tu veux jouer r G3 c'est ça
mais tour F5 h
ouais il y aura jamais de mat et
non mais non ça c'est toujours sous
contrôle ouais nul facile quoi
ouais tu peux jouer genre tour
hg7 ro H8 tour
D7 mais là maintenant tu commences par
tour
G2 H3 et maintenant r G8 comme ça tour
D8 tour
c'est si on veut c'est un peu folcl mais
quand même tu sens que tu es pas en gros
gros danger quoi non tu es pas tu pas en
danger le truc c'est que tout fait nul
aussi donc moi je pensais la faire comme
ça
ouais après faire échec et faire des tu
es trop évolué en fait un vrai po pas
quoi bah vouis moi je suis primitif je
vois le pion en F3 j'ai envie de le
garder toi tu le sacrifies pour faire
perpétuel je je guirise la situation
quoi peux pas luter je guéris j'ai
l'ordi qui confirme mais j' avais pensé
sans sans l'ordi pour la peine mais
après c'est vrai qu'en voyant que ça a
confirmé c'était plus facile et l'autre
ou il joue toujours que il est là oui
oui B tour C2 comme tu l'as annoncé
cavalier6 quoi peut-être il ne le verra
pas est-ce que toi tu le verrais je
pense que oui
ouais bon après on sait pas quoi ser
peut-être sous pression mais normalement
il faire quoi il faire dame 3 ou dame
n'importe où dame mais toi tu bois la
pression oua il y a pas de souci les
Français boivent la pression en général
hein de toute façon et Roland Garos
décalé tu en penses quoi
euh bah décalé c'est normal euh après
bon j'ai vu qu'ils sont appropriés un
peu une place dans le calendrier au
hasard mais d'un autre côté ça se défend
tu as envie quand même que les grands
SHM
soient soit s'il y a des tournois qui
soient jou cette année ce soit ces
tournois là après aux dates auxquell ell
sont Roland est décalé c'est pas du tout
sûr qui se passe parce que même en
admettant que la situation soit résolue
en France ce serait étonnant qu'elle
soit résolue dans tout les pays et donc
tu aurais plein de joueurs qui
pourraient pas défendre leur chance
c'est quand
même donc tu penses tu penses qu'on va
vivre une saison blanche en fait on
a'ura pas de tournois oua ouais je pense
c'est fou quand même bah enfin moi je
vois pas la NBA reprendre
euh là à mon avis les les prévisions les
plus Optim c'était juin ouais c'est
chaud et puis bon alors on parle pas
même pas du du foot ù là il voulait
reprendre genre en en septembre non aût
voir septembre Fab je sais pas ENF ils
espèrent jouer j'ai vu le Gret il dit
j'espère finir pour le 15 20 juillet
mais bon lui il est fou quoiis ça y rêve
mais je pas mais j'avais vu des
prévisions où genre bon il reporte
l'eurau ça c'est à qui ouis et il
voulait
ouais là Fab va abandonner je
pense est-ce que vous avez vu la petite
phrase de Magnus en parlant de la finale
de Max il a dit the French school of
suffering en évoquant les positions
selon lui pourri que Max a jouer en
finale je sais pas j'ai pas trop
souffert
aujourd'hui c'est le moment où j'ai le
moins souffert quand j'ai réussi à
obtenir la finale
oui pu en plus ça pas duré très longts
ou
cal c'est pas encore s Japon il sont en
train d'adiquer le truc quand
Mme même problème tu peux as trop
d'athlètes en plus tu fais venir des
athlètes du monde
entieréer les spectateurs du monde
entier aussi non tu peux pas non mais
moi je suis pour faire saison blanche
temp tempsil faut c'est plus important
que
SP va sauver bon nombre de Paris long
terme donc il faut et et pour les échecs
en fait tous mes Paris long terme là
j'étais catastrophique genre au début de
la saison j'avais mis par exemple
Stephan curry meilleur marqueur NBA euh
au bout de 5 matchs il se blesse pour 6
mois bon j'étais pas très bien pe le
fameux OL vsom aussi
ouais mais ça encore bon ça ça je suis
prêt à le payer mais non j'avais des
paris bah Lyon champion de France hein
je l'avais pris en début de saison
j'uris un peu mais
bon ah Benoît perère numéro 1 français
aussi ça voilà avec la mon c'est direct
mon fils invaincu pendant deux tournois
et F B Joko pour la première fois enfin
bon
c'est sil veut s'il cherche à savoir qui
est qui a lancé sa saison mon fils
c'était
moi mais heureux c'est un joueur j'aime
bien donc très très content voilà mais
bon bref du coup du coup euh du coup oui
pour moi ça sent quand même la saison
blanche ça semble
compliqué tu pense qu'il vont annuler
les les grandes chais tour et cetera
aussi pour les échecs ah c'est très
probable ouais et euh du coup c'est tu
vasê ah mais ça va être une année
compliquée alors bon pas pour des
joueurs comme moi quand même on a un peu
de réserve mais pour beaucoup beaucoup
de joueurs hein ça c'est clair que
beaucoup beaucoup de tournois vont être
annulés la source de revenu principale
notamment les ligues sont annulé donc
ouais
ça ça va être compliqué et du coup
est-ce que ça veut dire que le speed
chess cette année ça va être une grosse
compète sur CHC genre est-ce que ça va
prendre plus de valeur ah bah ça on
verra c'est possible ais je veux dire en
tant que joueur est-ce que du coup si tu
as pas joué depuis 6 mois que le gros
truc qui enfin ce speitch gros truc ça
me c'est un peu difficile de dire ça
comme ça parce que c'est pour moi c'est
une compétition amicale voir
semi-amicale mais est que là du fait
qu'il a pas de compétition à côté genre
tu vas dire enfin vous allez vous dire
plutôt ok c'est un truc prestigieux du
coup cette
année on verra on verra aussi parce que
par exemple par contre le match si le
tournoi va à son terme c'est possible
que le match pour le titre est quand
même lieu puis que ça ce sera en
décembre c'est déjà prévu en décembre
prochain euh ça par contre c'est pas du
tout sûr que ce soit décalé d'ailleurs
c'est aussi pour ça je p que la FIDE a
voulu absolument jouer faire jouer le
tournoi c'est parce que ils savent que
si le tournoi joue il y a une chance que
le C soit pas du tout décalé et bon
c'est c'est en quelque sorte aussi
uneben parce que tu as aucun sport qui
te fait concurrence en ce moment ouais
malheureusement on a du mal à
transformer l'essai pour le moment mais
je vi pas en terme de bon tu avais quand
même pas mal de monde qui suivait le
truc en Chine bon
ouais petits signes mais bon c'est sûr
que bon ça pour le moment tu parles
chinois à pas mal de monde mais
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi par
contre que si les candidats va à son
terme que pendant ça confine pendant de
3 4 mois c'est sûr qu'il y a beaucoup
plus de gens qui vont se mettre aux
échecs et et ouais ouais bah oui c'est
une grosse opportunité pour le SIT en
ligne bon et pas que pour
Netflix même si Netflix ils sont pas mal
et même Amazon j'ai vu la la Bourse de
New York ils perdent pas grand-chose
Amazon il rasent bien aussi tous les
tous les commerces en ligne tous les
choses qui sont ouais mais Amazon encore
bon à terme la question c'est est-ce que
amazon va pouvoir continuer à délivrer
leur service si il y a un vrai
confinement les livreurs ils pourront
peut-être pas juste pas livrer être au
compte cont de personne c'est quand
même c'est le livre qui livre à domicile
quand même bon je sais que généralement
il dépose dans la boîte au lettes mais
bon ça ça fait forcément pas mal de
contact à un moment selon les mesures de
confinement c'est pas sûr que peut-être
qu'ils auront des livreurs tu vois genre
full full combinaison ou a des robots
des robots ouais ou des robots ou en
drone ou tu vois enfin ils vont ouais je
sais pas
ouais les drones ouais mais bon après il
faut aussi qu'ils aient les stocks parce
que pour délivrer les trucs fa faut le
livreur mais faut aussi ah oui bien sûr
il il faut faut le fabriquant oui c'est
vrai que c'éit
la question en Chine tu av tout le
matériel informatique enfin tout les
composants électroniques qui étaient il
avait des pénuries qui commencent à se
faire sentir ouis bah c'est clair que
c'est une situation très très bizarre
mais bon là on parle de tout ce qui est
crise économique bon c'est pas le plus
important le plus important c'est quand
même que que la crise sanitaire se calme
après évidemment bon la crise économique
il faudra faire les comptes après mais
et puis que tu battes aussiarou cette
année en speedest quoi tu vois par que
bon les candidat c'est bien et tout mais
on a enfin envie de battrearou quoi on
en a marre quoi attends mais j'arrive
même pas à le jouer là j'ai perdu con je
te rappelle quand même j'étais pls total
ouais mais il y a 10 jours tu te Rapp
avant juste avant sache que tu les
candidat mais bon on a sué quoi il nous
a fait malarou en plus il fait le
malin du coup il faire quoi F6 ou il y a
un problème leise
rien faire stir le fou et puis voilà
quoi
ouais bon allez moi je vais vous laisser
puce que j'ai pas mal de truc à faire
ben merci d'être venu en tout cas ouais
franchement tu es tu es au-dessus de
tout tu reviens quand tu veux tu es un
peu chez toi en fait j'envie de dire
donc n'importe qument tu tu nous ouais
c'est bon je m'installe je mets je mets
mes chaussons et puis
même même en chaussette ou pied nus
c'est bon comme tu veux ouais par contre
par contre si tu as pris de la on si
j'ai le corona je suis je suis interdite
ah là tu es interdit et si tu as mangé
du poulet rôti avec plein plein d'huile
dedans avant pareil hein faut enlever la
peau
ouais donc ouis mon petit mon petit
doigt me dit
que que si quelqu'un va poster mon repas
de ce soir il m'a il m'a déjà demandé
des
photos tu nous montreras ça on ira
mettre un petit live sur insta du coup
si c bien diététique comme il faut ah
non ce sera pas diététique pas trop en
tout cas pas trop bon du coup bon
appétit à toi et euh encore merci de ta
gentillesse et ta disponibilité euh bah
bonne chance quoi allez Maxime yes merci
à bientôtia à bientôt
ciao on Perre Maxim et on va retrouver
Fab du coup qui va revenir à la CAL non
j'étais pas parti trop loin de toute
façon mais non mais cool Maxime quoi
ouais franchement il est crème he
franchement Maxime va chez La Grave les
mecs hein 200 g de haricot vert des
pouces bleus partout bon il y a pas de
pouce bleu mais peu importe quoi
ouais c'est sûr que ou non les pouss les
pouss sur les gens qui regardent sur
Youtube et bah voilà non mais vraiment
cool Maxime j'espère qu'on l'aura de
nouveau et vraiment sympa d'être venu il
a passé longtemps il est passé presque
une HE ouais is franchement non mais en
plus très sympa répondre à toutes les
questions cétait c'était bien quoi ouais
ouais non mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr
que c'était
topis pas mal de choses sur fait le
tournoi a des chances de s'arrê que les
parties jou sont acquises plein de trucs
comme ça
ouais non c cétait super super on a
vraiment de la chance d'avoir un
champion français comme ça
ouais sympa ouais qui qui qui
qui aide à populariser tout ça qui vient
répondre vraiment sympa
ouais ouais non vraiment audessus de
tout là dans l'os quoi qu'il arrive ou c
une bonne
nouvelle commenc quand
même cétait
s je pense pas que çare très longtemps
aujourd'hui non mais bon c'est
bien j'imine
j'imaginecepte pas cette défite peut le
comprendre hein non mais après écoute
tout façon c'estra que en abandonnant tu
gagnes pas il va perdre c'est tout mais
bon tu peux espérer un miracle je sais
pas quoi juste il y avait une question
j'ai vu dans le chat s'il y avait pas k
PR4 au
F7 un peu avant je sais plus quand mais
tu au 43e et juste non parce qu'elle y
prend le problème c'est que sur dame
prend des 5 et elle en finale
ouais et si F5 pour que le cavalier bon
on s'en fiche on prend la dame quoi
enfin je voulais dire le coup avant mais
c'est pareil pe rorte ouais donc non il
y avait pas de K PR4 en fait jamais
quoi bon ben écoute c'est en train de
c'est en train de bien se passer quoi on
va laisser les parties se terminer he il
y a plus grand enfin on a on a quand
même fait largement le tour des parties
hein on a dit tout ce qu'il a à dire
l'une est l'une est l'une est nulle
celle de gritchou y a rien à raconter
non mais c'est F7 F5 roilà et perpè par
exemple direct c'est un dro partout h
ouais ça serait très bien ça en fait
comme ça au moins ça finit vite et il
tourne pas pour rien
ouais et de l'autre côté euh bah on l'a
vu quoi il y a une pièce de plus c'est
c'est fini quoi enfin
oui oui non mais là il y a pas grand
chose à dire juste on peut discuter
comme ça avec le chat ou peu importe
mais peut-être je remets des liens vers
la chaîne Youtube l stream où il y aura
le résumé de la partie de Maxime donc
euh je je le mets euh euh je vais mettre
je vais mettre les liens si vous voulez
suivre la chaîne twitch elle est elle
est juste juste en dessous je vais
mettre le lien aussi dans dans le dans
le chat ce soir il y aura l'émission mat
à partir de 20h30 h donc du coup je vais
vous mettre ces liens là c'est quand
même des liens j'ai envie de te dire
assez utiles donc si vous voulez voir
plus d'échecs et puis en plus on peut
arriver sur Youtube non ce serait cool
Fab de faire les les les 40000 abos là
pendant les 40000 abonnés
ouais c'est un beau un beau chiffre quo
YouTube du coup vous avez aussi tous les
réseaux sociaux chesscom les 40000 vont
arriver tt ou tard
après le plutôt le mieux mais
ouais c'est sa pas que ça va arriver
c'est quand quo ah c'est sûr que ça va
arriver donc j'ai mis les deux liens du
coup
ouais 40 abos sur Youtube c'est fort ou
en français ouais même même même sur
twitch en fait montr blit stream sur tu
Rapp le petit graphique C genre même
même maintenant c'est une des 10 plus
grosses chaînes twitch d'échec au monde
oui oui oui oui ça j'avais vu oui c'est
quand même c'est parce que ouaisit on n
pas anglophone quoi donc peu de gens
parl c'est la première chaîne non
anglophone ouis c'est audessus des
chaînes espagnoles et cetera donc c'est
quand même pas mal non mais c'est très
bien
évidemment
donc
donc donc bon ça jeis pas s'il y a des
questions dans le
chat
et mais c'est pas ce soir ça sera
mat je lui ai dit que c'était plutôt
bien de venir sur cette partie mais je
crois qu'il su avec l'ouverture mais je
lu dis mais tu peux faire light oui
toute façon tu l'mission de demain pour
te faire chier avec
l'ouverture
dommage non mais juste je pense
cararwana il a il a fait une
partie je sais pas comment dire c'était
opportuniste qu'il l' a fait c'est je
sais pas à quel point c'est sérieux
l'ouverture sa nouveauté
mais c'était une tentative vu qu'il joue
un joueur qui s'est dit ok il peut-être
pas trop en
forme je tente je tente de le battre
donc c'est un côté risqué mais euh mais
c'est intéressant bon ben c'est retourné
contre lui hein mais mais c'était pas
pleutre quoi Mo doncas j'ai des infos
moi je pense il a
mélangé bon alors est-ce que tu vas
faire l'ouverture à fond aujourd'hui et
du coup tu feras les ouvertures machin
tu fais l'ouverture un peu plus light
aujourd'hui la partie et tu te dis je
garde l'ouverture à fond pour
lesmissions mat sur les ouverture de
demain ah mais ça c'est c'est ma K c'est
lui le maîre à bord quoi et pour les
jours de repos à 18h bah il y aura
l'émission
mat mais il est en panique quoi c'est
génial en fait c'est l'émission twitch
et tout avec les R qui vont écrire UL et
tout
quoi stress pas ma avec de la nation ce
soir demain sur qu le coup plus précis
au 24e coup
quoi non même Maxime en fait c'est
marrant parce que voyez nous on est un
peu troll avec on bien déconner ou quoi
mais Mme Maxime ça se voit qu'il a bien
déconner aussi alors queme éé numéro 2
mondial etit parti des favoris de des
candidats quoi ouais et vous voyez aussi
qu'il est marrant il est troll et tout
les échecs les gens qui jouent au échecs
on est pas des gens comme sais c
ceiérieux de la chaîne c'est pas des
mecs en costume un peu pompeux mais en
fait les joueurs d'échec la plupart on
est comme ça on est pas des mecs en
costume semi pompeux quoi on est plutôt
des mecs drôles non Fab bah
oui çap enfin c'est comme partout dans
la vie quel que soit le métier quel que
soit le la classe sociale ou
quoi voilà c'est représentatif qu mais
c'est pas parce qu'on joue aux échecs
que tu es forcément hyper sérieux et que
tu tu peux jamais rigoler quoi sérieux
pendant que tu joues et puis à côté bah
c'est la vie quoi bah oui non la plupart
des gens sont comme ça on Mathieu quand
même beaucoup de gens de mon niveau qui
passe B qui était passé il y a longtemps
mais qui est souvent sur le chat Mathieu
il est très cool Fab très cool mvl très
cool enfin je sais pas tous les gens qui
passent sont très
cool the
Gang romain il était très
marrant non non mais ça va tout le
monde non mais romain il é en général je
m'entends bien enfin tu vois les gens je
connais dans les échecs c'est c'est soit
soit ça peut être des amis mais après tu
as pas tu as pas 12000 amis non plus
mais des connaissan des gens avec qui je
passe des bons moments quoi ça manque
d'un gros salot quand même mais c'est
peut-être en fait Vlad qui remplit ce
rôle de grand méchant de la chaîne je
sais pas en fait moi Vlad je vois comme
le grand méchant quoi genre vous êtes
tous nul vous n'ppartenez pas la
position
je sais pas c'est genre le Rous très
méchant non ouis mais non mais je pense
c'est comme dans en fait je sais qui
c'est Vlad dans Batman c'est double
face en fait tu sais pas c'est pou
gentil méchant na tu es
nul très fort c'est tu sais jamais en
fait c'est comme double Phe en Batman tu
vois un peu le
persooup il veut te tuer mais mer c'est
P fait tu te bar c'est ça c'est un grand
méchant gentil on sait pas en fait
en plus il a l'accent il a tout quoi
c'est un personnage complexe quoi un peu
divl c'est un méchant dans Gon non je
c'est le plus gentil de la chaîne mais
jou quand même un rôle de méchant c'est
sûr bien ce que je
dire moi le méchant qui me ou peut-être
c'est nous nous cachons derrière la voix
de Vlad pour lancer des commentaire quoi
c'est peut-être ça en fait le méchant de
la chaîne ah oui qu'est-ce qu'il est con
ce tu sais qu' il encore tout oublié
quoi regarde sa partie contre wangao il
n'a pas vu cavalier prend le4
oui il a il a échangé en G6 et fait
G5 même Maxime en commentant sur ta
chaîne avait vu tempo pour te dire la
différence quoi qu'est-ce que je dois
boire pour pour jouer comme
ça non excuse il y a aucune quantité qui
me fait jouer si mal que quoi
ouais donc Ding prendre un F6 donc qui
prend un pion de plus là au passage bon
déjà qu'il avit une pièce de plus doncon
c'est juste le ramassage scolaire quoi
mais c'est beau quand carwan est au fond
là de pas abandonner c'est sûr qu'il est
complètement au
fond je sais pas enfin oui non mais là
bon ça devrait pas trop tarder l'abandon
mais c'est beau quoi Sacha qu' veut pas
faire nul
ouais bah je sais pas pourquoi ça joue
là aussi les 4 C sont passés ils ont le
dro de proposer non
ouais et du coup marrant quoi mangao qui
s'en sort si bien en aant si peu envie
de jouer quoi
ouais c'est marant fort mentalement les
Chinois quand même les
deuxou je P le génie du mal en fait on
dit pourquoi on l'appelle Sacha son
prénom en fait oui en fait Sacha c'est
Alexandre c'est ça
oua c'est le même prénom en
fait donc c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça c'est pour ça Vlad
c'est un peu le jafard dans Aladin is je
pense
vous avez bien vous avez bien cerné le
personnage quoi en fait Jafar est
peut-être très bien quofin on le montre
sous un mauvais angle dans
ce dans ce que j'aimer ce que les gens
appellent un dessin animé
quoi mais
non en fait Jaffard peut-être très bien
quoi enfin genre la princesse très
mignonne bon voilà enfin il est chaud
quo il a pas envie de se faire raser par
un par un gars qui qui vole des pommes
dans un marché quoi au B d'un moment non
enfin soit sérieux quoi
non mais c'est juste un mec sérieux en
fait jafard enfin très bien
quoi enin genre faut comprendre jafard
quoi demain c'est repos il y a rond 4
c'est repos exactement c'est repos c'est
trois trois parties repos trois parties
repos trois parties repos juste à la fin
s'il y a une fin euh il y aura même
encore plus de repos mais
ouais on va reposer encore plus ah c'est
il y a Reny Stam qui redemande le qu
prend 4 c'est le dernier truc
intéressant de la partie tu peux
remontrer mais j'ai déjà vu la question
du coup on y a répondu en fait
mais je remontre comme ça sans redire
parce que j'ai un peu la
flemme du coup non ça marchait pas en
fait rien de
[Musique]
marcha il dit peut-être ouais c'est vrai
que il dit peut-être que le sultan
gérait mal les crises internationales du
royaume dans aladin et Jafar voulait
prendre sa place beaucoup bien meilleur
gestionnaire quoi B non mais genre voilà
il y avait un problème d'épidémie genre
dans le royaume je Cour ne fait pas de
quarantaine il en suur et voilà il ve
juste mais j'ff un C il se dit bon bah
si bah oui très bonne g très bon
gestionnaire très bonne gestion de crise
ce con d'Aladin voilà ENF il est venu il
fout la merde et enfin on te montre
jamais ce qui s'est passé après quoi en
genre on parle quand même d'un idiot qui
qui qui vole sur un tapis enfin genre au
d'un moment gen faut être sérieux 5
minutes quoi le mec a une espèce de
lampe on sais pas ce qu'il fait avec il
vole sur un tapis enfin d'où il a ce
tapis on ne sait pas
is c'est un délinquant un peu quoi mais
non mais c'est un délinquant nous
parlons d'un délinquant en genre au bout
d'un moment soyons sérieux sur sur ce
dessin animé
[Musique]
quoi soyons
sérieux un petit
peu donc
[Musique]
c'est beau qu'on doit regarder tous les
dessins animés Disney avoir un œil
critique dessus
pendant pendant cette cette quarantaine
ça va être l'occasion de tout revoir en
fait
en fait c'est Sarkozi qui veut passer le
délinquant àadam
carch je crois qu'on part loin les mecs
ça part très loin B ouais mais bon enfin
ça fait 4 jours qu'on est enfermé au
bout d'un
moment imagine dans de mois quoi
c'est en de mois ça être n'importe
quoi bah ouais mais bon
mais j'ai vraiment envie de sortir de
pas avoir mon papier d'attestation que
quelqu'un m'arrête et de dire mais
bordel j'ai le
droit tu peux le dire m avec le papier
quoi ou oui c'est vrai as d'autant plus
le droit quoi mais ser de faire un film
Instagram quo une story qui B j'ai le
droit mais non tu n'as pas le droit
quoi Peter qui demande c'est quoi le
plan simple pour Ding pour gagner
changer les pièces c'est le plus
simple
gen fait parce que tuas pas envie
regarder ce Pass Touro Mme pas grave tu
vas mettre d D4 pour
G7
pu mais sin le plus simple de chez
simple tu
FA
rien pas piè je sais pas ce qu'il
fait juste pas de
coup non mais c'est juste abandonnable
je sais
pas pourquoi car nabandonne pas
simplement il til c'est
tout til avoir une bonne prépa il a dû
mélanger Matthieu expliquera tout ce
soir ça très très bien expliqué
si MRE la pression à
fond c'était mieux quand c'était
fable pas de
chance mais c'est bizarre ce truc d'
sation de sortie en fait tu demande de
toute façon tu peux te la faire toi-même
facile enfin je vois pas le
non ça ser à rien en fait mais je sais
pas c'est peut-être pour que les gens
prennent conscience en remplissant le
truc qui doit avoir une bonne raison de
sortir mais ouais genre parce que TUC
sur l'honneur et du coup ça mais bon
ouais en fait je sais pas trop non c'est
espérer que les gens
[Musique]
a sens CIV dire ouais je pense c'est
ça
Marc and quelle heure la mission de
math
20h30 la miniature elle est fantastique
avoir les châons dessus ah il y a les
châons je me
doutais tu es heureux
non bah ouais d'ailleurs des animaux ne
les abandonnz pas quoi VO tiens on va
faire son làdessus
quoi non mais j'ai vu il y a une vague
d'abandon là
la SP en PLS parce qu'ils doivent fermer
leurs truc et puis ils peuvent plus ils
peuvent plus les accueillir ou quoi et
les gens les abandonnent ilent oui il
peut avoir le corona je veux pas
l'attraper mais bon SAF qu'il l'attrape
pas en fait les chats les chiens non
c'est pas leur problème en
fait donc prenez soin de vos animaux
quoi vous pensez quoi de ce net sur
chararger qui ne fonctionnerait plus bah
j'en sais rien fress mais j'ai lu
quelque part je sais pas si c'est une
fake new si c'est vrai qu'il pourrait
limiter les débits bah là on serait mal
euh ouais on est mal
te rends compte obligé de l des livres
quoi arrête parle pas juste quand on te
met quand on met des trucs gratuits
tombe
maloi après il peuvent juste limiter la
qualité des
débits gen de P regarder en HD mais en
70 non mais même si tu mets tout en 720p
maximum les débits tu vas les baisser ça
va bien se passer
donc on sa pas non mais bon là au Carana
faut être sérieux
quoi mais même Grou en fait enfin non
mais ce ne sont pas des gens
sérieux c'est quand même
spécial bien se
passé
ce qu'
dit je pas mutation et que
R c'est c'esti ce
TR tell
ceè coron la
pare
pasè
ça il prennent par un infrarouge moi
j'étais très mécontent d'autres idées
que tu connais quoi pour bien être sûr
quoi
ais c'est que là on sait pas c'est pas
ce qu'on regarde
quoi non mais ça a duré moins longtemps
qu'hier hier C à peu près ça jusqu'à 18h
mais mais il pouvait gagner au moins mon
ouais bon c'est vrai en
fait
il y a de chiens testés positifs en
Chine du Sud mais de toute façon faut se
détindre c'est pas plus virolent que les
20 autres virus déjà en circulation ici
bon je suis pas du tout sûr
mais tour D6 bon allez fait faites nul
quoi enfin il y en a
marre non mais c'est très frustrant de
regarderfin les deux parties sont très
frustrantes à
suivre B3 quoi
allez quoi au fond B2 B1 qui l'oublie
quoi non
B on va voir non Fab la mauvette oui non
pour jouer aussi longtemps une telle
position faut vraiment que qu'il y ait
un problème non
oui je sais pas je comprends pas
mais
c'est
inatable ce que tu
veux
pr ok là tu rends compte quand Mme
beaucoup mieux
fin
tu vas quand même
gagner non non ça c'est pas nul ça c'est
gagné en blanc et la nul c'est l'autre
il plus que les tours les pions
ouais est-ce que si on enlève le
cavalier d il est encore gagnant je
pense que
oui si quoi le C2 ouais bah oui en fait
là on a une pièce de plus un pion mais
bientôt deux bon s une pi sera quand
même toujours de de plus
quoi bah oui
enfin mais dame C3 qui D6 pr pr enfin
ouais faut peut-être enfin c'est
peut-être pas le truc le plus propre
quoi au final non en plus il me dame pr
F2
h bon ben on fait pas dame C3 puis
voilà tu as 3 de du coup nere très
bien bon écoute je sa pas on va pas néer
cette position comme des fous quoi il
fait3 très bien B3 moi je vais faire la
même chose en bougeant le roi mais
bon ils ont dépassé les 41 coups ouais
ouais
ouais on est au quoi au 46e 50e je sa
pas j' pas à lire 50 50e coup déjà ok
les autres ont fait nul finalement ah
bravo très bien
quoi non c'est toujours difficile les
gars les fins enfin là c'est aujourd'hui
c'est pas des fins de partie passion
parce qu'il y a fa quoi enfin on a
l'habitude non non moi c'est pour moi
c'est des parties très normales en fait
oui tu as tellement l'habitude de cour
des trucs pareil non mais c'est quand
même incroyable il va avoir une victoire
il y a pas eu qu nul sans qu'il se passe
rien quoi
ouais la victoire ouais de Ding ouais
mais Ding qui va complètement se
relancer
et sinon B2 t
B3 B8 on peut faire B5 je
crois pe faire plein de choses mais
prend2 c'est sympa aussi est-ce que même
ça c'est ça garde l'avantage ou pas non
non non maisends B2 tout court ah oui
qui est sympa en
fait que Y a ça en l'air mais bon juste
penser à dam B5 non mais on peut tenter
une petite arnaque comme ça mais sil y a
plus il a plus rien à faire quoi bah non
non c'est mort je remets les liens du
coup j'en profite pour que les gens
s'abonnent la chaîne ouais bien sûr
venez donc aussi la chaîne twitch de BL
stream très intéressante j'ai mis tous
les liens soir 20h30 mat qui va revenir
sur les highlights de la
journée sur les
highlight du
coup on a encore 1700 quand même hein
quoi qu'il en soit il y a quand même du
monde malgré c'est bien malgré tout je
pass une longue pub du coup je fais un
peu de tu vois histoire de faire quelque
chose
c'est vra non mais on aime bien la pub
normalement ouais mais là en fait on
fait pas de pause on a pas mis de pub on
commencera peut-être samedi qu on a fait
100 pub
début du coup on va enchaîner quoi pub
toutes les 15 minutes quoiamamam non
mais peut-être fait cé plus intelligent
quoi j' du fait
que il y a plus rien à voir quoi en on
attend vraiment juste sert la main
est-ce qu'il se sert la main est-ce
qu'il se sert les coudes qu'est-ce
qu'ils font
quoi mer j'ai vu NPO etou Ctait très
heureux de de se faire un check avec les
coudes
ouais moi je preris le X comme dans H
quoi x
ouais
ouais pourquoi pas bah c'est B sans le
claque avant d'ailleurs juste
x ils ont serré les non les cou C qui
disen qui dit trop de C H je suis pas
mal en
culturage à la fin ils ont oubl ils sont
serré la main pleutre mais c'est trop
heureux de faire nul
oui non mais en vrai s'ils ont déjà été
testés le 15 en réalité normalement il y
a aucun problème
oui non mais juste ça peut s'incuber 15
jours quoi mais est-ce que tu le vois si
son en train de s'incuber ou pas j'en
sais rien si tu es symptomatique tu vois
rien sin non ou quoi j'en sais rien je
crois que tu vois quand même Jean Kevin
il désolé h mais désolé Fab mais h c'est
pour bon ben laisse-moi ne pas d'accord
quoi je sais pas tu as le droit de pas
aimer moi je te dis si
quoi après je sais pas quel âge tuas
aussi hein c'est peut-être parler une
autre génération parce que H c'était fin
des années 90 début des années 2000
donc donc c'est autre chose quoi
peut-être fait B2 tour
B3 c'est quoi h ben cétait une série
série canal avec Eric et Rams jamais
entre autres
quoi mais oui mal il a peut-être moins
de 12 ans donc oui il peut pas tout
comprendre c'est sûr
[Musique]
quoi menace bien1 il
apparaît mais je crois que j'ai rarement
vu une partie de ce niveau jouer jusqu'à
une position aussi ridicule
ouais ouais c'est alors ok il veut il
veut faire un 4 quoi mais en fait il le
fait dans quel monde je sais pas il fait
rien même
ça bah oui non je sais pas je sais pas
je sais pas je sais je sais plus quoi
dire en fait je pris de cours pour pour
les commentaires de la partie en fait
préfère parler
de en fait normalement on regarde jamais
ce genre de position mais je pense
j'aurais fait
ça
puis 6 et puis on y va enfin pasigé
faire tout de suite on va éviter le dame
machin non il essayer un truc comme ça
encore mais il pourrait nous arnaquer
encore nous non mais si on réfléchi il a
pas d'Ar Blitz oui ça je suis sûr mais
j'en sais rien peut-être je réfléchis à
fond mais déjà tu reprends B2 voilà
enfin je fais je te laisse pas ton pion
faire F4 oui mais bon en fait tu menaces
rien tu pr 4 peut-être
mais par exemple qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui peut arriver il y a pas de menace il
y a rien on cache un peu le r on fait G4
et puis voilà quoi pe tu ta tour en F8
pour être
tranquille puis G2 puis G4 TR ou tu moi
je me blinderai bien et puis je ouais j'
G4
quoi non c'est la partie hein pour le
moment on su complètement
hein oui bon c'est pas très grave he
enfin plus Ding il est pasent quoi ENF
il réfléchi un peu il joue quoi non mais
juste j'en parlais hier avec Romain et
je disais que les échecs vraiment qu'il
fasse quelque chose qu' on a passé genre
2hes final les de dernières heures
c'était ennuyeux et là en fait
aujourd'hui tu as le même problème et ça
nuit quand même largement au truc c'est
comme si au foot tous les matchs c'était
décider dans les 45 premières minutes et
les 45 dernières minutes serv à rien et
Romain il voulait arrêter enlever les
rajoutant en 40e en fait juste les envoé
puis c'est fini en fait non mais on joue
en 1h30 plus 30 secondes et c'est fini
ou c'est ce que je réclame moi depuis
moins encore mais là pourquoi pas comme
ça mais ça sert à rien oui ça sert
absolument à rien bah si ça sert à
montrer au public que les échecs son en
nu c'est de la merde en fait oui mais
trucès cont productif ENF c'est non mais
tu as un truc très bien de base en fait
juste tu produis tu tu pouris ton
produit en rajoutant du temps qui sert à
rien ah mais bon tu mets sur SK au
manettees alors forcément ah oui c'est
que c'est
pas mais
[Musique]
euh c'est juste bizarre en fait non mais
surtout qu'on pourrait même jouer plus
rapide que même les parties de semi
rapide je suis pas sûr que le niveau de
jeu soit bien moins bon non mais si tu
veux jouer long tu peux jouer long aussi
qui disait avec Ran rigur si tu veux
garder un truc long tu fais 2h plus 30
secondes et jamais de rajout de rien oui
Non Non mais voilà oui bon 1h 30 2h
comme vous voulez ça c'est pas le
problème non mais tu veux mettre un
petit rajou 40e parce que les j
l'habitude et que tu veux les
déshabituer petit à petit mais tu mets
pas une heure non plus tu mets un quart
d'heure ou je sais pas tu fais un petit
truc tu peux faire 1h 45 et 15 minutes
au 40e si tuux si si jamais c'est
vraiment important de donner le R
et puis petit à petit les joueurs
s'habitue et puis après tuen mets plus
du tout mais
euh mais oui Non Non mais enfin à un
moment là la Fed il voulait juste faire
1h30 et 30 secondes j'ai joué tellement
de tournois avec C cadence en Espagne
puis un moment c'était même un peu en
France ou quoi je sais pas pourquoi ça a
changé de mode ils avaient même organisé
une coupe du monde une World Cup avec
cette cadence c'est une très bonne
cadence tu veux faire du long et je sais
pas pourquoi ça disparu en
fait que les finales complexes sont
injouables dans votre système mais c'est
un jouable tout court B en fait de toute
façon ils font des conneries tout le
temps
donc je sais pas enfin les finales tu as
qu'à les connaître et puis ça demande un
peu de feeling et puis voilà quoi
dans ce cas je pense vraiment bien jouer
faire que de la correspondance au moins
la tout est bien jouable ouais on joue
que en correspondance avec l'aide des
ordis bon là forcément ce sera bien joué
mais mais
ouais
ouis
non mais les joueurs il voient pas
profondeur 32 quoi pour calculer
profondeur 32 faut peut-être le temps il
y a aucun humain qui calcule profondeur
32 en on pense différemment on pense pas
comme des ordinateurs en fait non on
fait pas de la
profondeur non mais là c'est quand même
un peu ridicule non quoi non ce qu'on
est en train de regarder
oui oui bah c'est comme si on devait
commenter un match où il y avait
[Musique]
15-0 ça mais où tu as le droit d'arrêter
le match mat quoi mais non tu tu ESS oui
je prends qu'un 16e but
quoi non mais ça tu sais plus quoi dire
mais c'est pas grave enfin peu importe
on va on va regarder la fin on discute
avec le chat ça va on est on est bien
quoi
mais qui va gagner quoi c'est ça on se
demande on sait pas on a
jamais gagné une partie en abandonnant
mais c'est aussi pour ce genre de cas
que ça peut servir d'avoir des cadences
un peu plus
courtes donc il pourrait faire comme au
Shogi aucun rajout temps et quand il te
reste plus qu'une minute ça y est quoi
tu tu as une minute par cou après c'est
vrai que c'est pas con hm
hm bon il y enfin il y a plein de peu
importe on peut trouver plein de schémas
plein de systèmes sympas mais de penser
à réduire la cadence toute façon c'est
une bonne idée non mais juste ça un peu
le ah 1 heure plus une heure moins un
quart d'heure une demi-heure ok peu
importe mais le le principe de base sur
lequel on est tous assez d'accord c'est
faut faut faut diminuer les cadances euh
si salut quand c'est sur chcom les tipis
sont bien pour vous ouais mais le tipi
en fait blit stream ça change pas j
cosmique dans tout les cas dans tous les
cas c'est c'est le même quoi et du coup
plus marrant de donner pendant
lesémission Blitz au moins il y a le il
y a la petite petite musique quoi et on
peut te remercier comme il se doit parce
que là il y aura ni la petite musique ni
rien quoi c'est dommage mais merci à toi
en tout cas non mais après carwana sil
joue c'est juste qu'il a peut-être il
voit une varant d' il y a une petite
arnaque possible mais écoute rien
l'empêche de tenter c'est pas le
problème moi ce qui m'amuse c'est que
d'un côté on te dit oui il faut
absolument maintenir les candidats parce
que quand il y a la crise du corona ça
permet de favoriser les de
populariserchc bla bla ça c'est un
discours que j'entends et pourquoi pas
mais du coup ENF je sais pas prend les
mesures à côté
aussi cam qui pour le spectacle je suis
d'accord mais pour la recherche de la
vérité on trouve des nouveautés plus en
correspondant c'est parties longues
qu'en partie rapide je pense mais les
parties nouveautés tu les trouves
pasendant la partie tu les trouves avant
la partie donc en fait la maison ou que
tu es une minute à la pendule ou ou 40
he en fait la nouveauté de toute façon
tu l'as trouvé avec un ordinateur chez
toi donc ça change rien
avec les prépas di milieux le temps de
jeu est problématique mais pourquoi au
contraire les joueurs sont mieux
préparés donc ils sont capables de jouer
plus vite oui en fait tu as besoin de
pour jouer 40 coups si tu as déjà joué
35 coups avec par cœur quoi c'est ça qui
a beaucoup changé par rapport à l'époque
de carpov Kasparov qui devaent réfléchir
à fond sur les chiqu là ils connaissent
les plans ils connaissent beaucoup plus
de choses on peut jouer beaucoup plus
vite
qu'avant on t'entend mal bah écoute
c'est pas c'est pas ce que la console me
dit peut-être tu m'entends mal moi je
t'entends bien possible mais si Fab
m'entend
bien sais qu'il y a pas de souci bah si
l'adversaire connaît pas la Pra c'est
son problème enfin tu as le droit
d'avoir un
montage c'est comme si on dit oui il a
servi trop fort c'est problématique pour
le receveur bah tant pis
çaarrive trop fort non mais comme a dit
Vlad tu as le droit de gagner une partie
à la maison enfin c'est bien si le gars
gagné à la maison parce qu'il a beaucoup
travaillé c'est un point fort aussi
c'est comme
ça arrive assez souvent d'ailleurs enfin
on entend bien et F est plus fort en son
ouais moi je met un peu plus fort en son
parce que parfois je gueulle aussi mais
on peut pas on peut pas tout les mecs
c'est pas enfin on peut pas tout régler
parfaitement c'est c'est pas possible en
fait to je seraai à côté de Kev on
aurait plusin je rappelle c'est ce qu'on
avait prévu de base quoi que j'aille à
qu'on fasse mais là tutais ils ont
peut-être raison tu ESU peut-être un peu
plus fort que moi mais on peut pas dire
entendre mal non plus quoi
non mais tu peux dire désol non c'est
pas dans ce sens là tu as tellement
l'impression que les gens écrivent tout
le temps que il y a qui va pas ça qui va
pas en fa c'est très dur à
régler juste là oui F était genre 5 ou 6
décib plus haute que moi je t'ai baissé
de 3 décib
merci non fait ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
ouais du micro mais là j'ai envie d'être
assis un peu plus loin pour te soulager
le dos non
mais pour le côté pépous
ouais c'est le côté
pépous non mais ça
ça ça me met un peu ça ça me rend un peu
salé en fait quand est parti dur comme
ça et en fait c'est trè jour d'affilé
ok quand tu as regardé des trucs comme
ça inpid trois fois pendant 2 heures au
bout d'un moment bah tu c quefin tu
prends tout à fait ce que je veux dire
juste premier jour là tu ton premier
jour tu vois c'est tranquille quand
c'est TR c'est trème jour quand même où
tu te tapes un truc comme ça et c'est
frustrant en fait h parce que ça fait
c'est troisème fois ça fait 10 ans qu'on
le dit ENF au bout d'un moment non mais
comme d' c'est pas la faute de Carana
qui lui chance de sa chance et bon il la
parti dur à 8h elle pe dur 8h mais c'est
comme c'est l'organisation
oui oui c'est pas du tout contre Carana
ou contre les joueurs là pas du tout
c'est juste tu as des soucis récurrents
des trucs qui vont pas et c'est jamais
changé
Etok c'est pas dur en fait oui c'est
juste tu dis bon on va jouer un peu plus
vite cette fois voilà et en plus même
les joueurs sont d'accord c'est ça qui
est marrant quoi mvel je pense tu lui
demandes il va pas te dire
[Musique]
non non body je comprends quoi quand
vous dites entendre mal entendre faut
pas exagérer je vois tout à fait le truc
de décibel C c'était plus bas de 3,2
décibel
que juste dire on entend mal c'était
quand même quelque chose un petit peu
exagéré quo inaudible en fait c'est
carrément ça je lâche le mot
is céit juste un petit peu
exagéré
donc ouais plus 7 ou exactement le
potiron
ouais plus 7
alors question pour toi après ton
dernier livre dégag La kalashikov
travailles-tu ou prévois-tu de faire de
prochain livre d'échec je peux répondre
pour
toi vas-y non je n'écrirai plus jamais
de livres beaucoup trop long et ça ne
rapporte rien en plus les gens de toute
façon les télécharg sur internet je ne
veux plus faire h ouais voilà en gros
par contre j'ai fait des DVD voilà ah là
oui non mais ça m'a l'air moins moins
piraté déjà en fait pour le coup non
c'est hyper chiant quand tu es quand tu
es auteur et que 2 semaines après
l'apparition du livre il y a déjà le PDF
qui circule sur Internet les gens qui
s'y ruent dessus qui
téléchargent chier tu as passé juste 6
mois à bosser sur un truc ça va
quoi donc euh non je dis pas je ferai
plus jamais mais bon ça m'a un peu passé
l'envie on va dire et les DVD j'ai fait
sur plusieurs ouvertures donc il y en a
deux en duo avec Sébastien Maé qu'on a
fait chez chess bas un sur l'Est
indienne un sur le dragon accéléré et
j'en ai fait deux chez HES un sur la
défense française et un qui est fait
mais qui est pas encore sorti mais qui
le sera dans les mois à venir sur la per
et moderne
voilà ils sortent quand ça dépend deux
le temps tu vois qu'il mettent tout
[Musique]
en enin je sais pas comment comment dire
faut juste qu'il fasse la qu' grave les
DVD qui ah mais il les vendent vraiment
en DVD euh ils font les deux tu peux
l'avir en physique ou en tléch al
atttion fa désolé ton son est devenu
très mauvais ah merde d'un coup ah non
là ça va mieux mais c'était c'était mais
cétait devenu difficile audible c'est
téléchargeable ou ou physique les
deux donc tuas tu as deux options ouais
bon après maintenant en général les gens
prennent pas le DVD physique mais c'est
ça reste une option d'ailleurs oui c'est
vrai que les DVD physiques c'est de
moins en moins parce que même les ordis
genre mon portable j'ai pas de lecteur
DVD non non généralement c'est plutôt
des clés USB maintenant donc non non
c'est c'est possible
euh est-ce que pour les d vous allez
dans un studio d'registrement spécifique
ou en vous-même eny les vidéo alors ça
dépend chess bas on était chez eux donc
ils ont un studio et cetera
euh les autres avec K chess je je
faisais de chez
moi il y AVC keV on voulait en faire bah
écoute quand ça ouis ça va pas être
facile ouais quand ça sera possible je
viendrai à can on se mettra bien et puis
on en fera ah non là ça va être
difficile mais je pense que c'est une
c'est bien en fait de faire de la vidéo
maintenant
et pour les Liv que en lis encore
beaucoup je sais pas beaucoup mais oui
moi j'aime bien les Liv mais aussi faut
dire
génération j'aime bien les
livres
coup
ou même F5 C sûrement pas
mal tu simplifies bien
quoi puis tu pousses ton
pion et F
B7 non je vais continuer à la
jouer non mais c'est désespérant de voir
ça c'est n'importe quoi bon 5
jouet non mais c'est fou
c'est do vraiment ti mal c'est pas
possible
carwana m vous gager cette partie c'est
vrai même
carwana même car même
Navara non mais là c'est je sais pas
ça faut le faire tester au corona à la
fin de la
partie est-ce qu'il y a une est-ce qu'il
y a un monde où les Noirs échangent les
dames il font une forteresse sur case
noir GG ouais non il y a pas de monde il
y a rien
qu je pense que quasiment tout le chat
là gagne ça la contre
Carona bizarre he qui son en PLS
ouais
ok c'est pas grave hein il rester 11
rond il est pas largé dans le
tournoi mais euh mais on verra non mais
après enfin je dire je peux comprendre
hein des fois en tant que joueur tu
joues par inertie tu es uneement foutue
et tu joues les coups comme ça tu es tu
t'autopunis quelque part enant ça tu es
trèsvé de toi-même parce que était con
parce que tu as tu as oublié ta prépa tu
as mélangé un truc tu t'en je sais pas
tu tu te punis quoi bah tu punis tout le
monde là oui mais les gens sont pas
oblig de regarder bon nous nous oui mais
tant
pis non mais c'est vraiment enfin bon je
veux vraiment pas à carwana là pour la
peine c'est vraiment vraiment les
cadences qui sont n'importe
quoi bon Ding qui prend bien son temps
il a
raison mais en fait tu gagnes pas plus
de points en te
précipitant donc c'est normal de bah
d'être précis ENF tuas une victoire au
bout du là tu as juste à te pencher pour
pour la gagner mais juste faut pas te
trébucher n'importe
commentoi mais non mais fr c'est pas une
question de journée de repos c'est une
question que c'est enfin c'est c'est
ridicule quoi c'est ridicule ce qu'on
est en train de voir enfin c'est c'est
regarder quelqu'un faire caca quoi en
gros non mais
vraiment
c'est je sais pas j'ai pas les mots
quoi je sais pas juste ça m'étonne de
regarder ça tu vois ce que je veux dire
je suis étonné d'avoir cette position
oui c'estd qu'en fait quand on analyse
les parties on fait les vidéos YouTube
s'il y a une position qui est même trois
fois moins gagnante que ça on dit déjà
bon B ça ça gagne c'est bon on regarde
même pas là jamais non j'ai regardé ça
fait déjà quand même 45 minutes qu'on
regarde ça hm hm je sais pas c'est quand
même
euh c'est quand même spécial
quoi à un moment donné euh c'est c'est
je suis pas énervé par par quoi que ce
soit c'est juste que je regarde un truc
et je me dis mais mais comment ça existe
quoi ça ça me paraît euh ça me ça me
paraît hallucinant
de je sais pas il doit y avoir un
arbitre comme à la boxe quoi non tu n'as
plus droit de jouer dégage
C technique on dit non tu peux plus o on
te non mais en plus si si jou tout
tempo je comprends mais il réfléchit à
fond
machin c'est fou
quoi après vous pouvez couper et revenir
s'il a jamais il y a
du nouveau non on peut pas
malheureusement j' faire quoi couper
revenir non non jusqu'au bout mais c'est
pas franchement juste on peut discuter
on parle pas de la partie c'est pas
grave ça en
fait ouais c'est le fait même que le
truc existe en fait tu vois qui met en
PLS en fait c'est c'est ça puisse
exister et que ça fait je sais pas
depuis le temps en fait
que ça met vraiment
pls depuis le temps que c'est censé être
changé en fait je sais pas
pourquoi en
fait
bah
donc ça existe ça
existe ouais ouais ouais non non ça
existe ça existe après c'est non comme
je dis en fait les joueurs jeen veut pas
du tout en fait Fabiano quoi c'est juste
que un jour faudra réfléchir
à prendre des mesures qui sont simples
pour que justement ça existe plus mais
comment l'empêcher à partir de une
position perdue bah il suffit juste de
réduire un peu les cadences en fait et
du coup tu redonnes pas aux gens 3 heur
de jeu à partir du 40e tu leur redonne
je sais pas moi 45 minutes non mais le
truc on dit pas qu'il faut forcer le mec
à abandonner il fait ce qu'il
veut qui était dit c'est juste que là au
lieu qu'il a un rajout d'une heure après
40 coup il y a pas de rajout donc en
fait là au lieu qu'il a 45 minutes son
20 minutes ils auraient 2 minutes chacun
et ça se finira quoi et donc on pas ça
pendant 3 He à regarder on peut voir
cette position mais ça durerait 4
minutes et ça serait fini
quoi c'est ça
ouais imaginez Ding per ouais bon ça un
peu
compliqué
non ben peu importe en
fait c'est j'aurais préféré le voir
perdre après 4 minutes que
ça pendant des heures pour qu'il a une
gaffe et un tour à
chite si tu imagines l'époque des
ajournements le monde évolue bah oui
justement il évolue ça on est d'accord
le
monde
évolue toute la nuance est dans le mot
monde je
crois non mais là ça ferait quand même
très longtemps que ça aurait dû évoluer
ce
truc il attend l'annulation du
tournoi
du
coup nous écrit en
anglaisi il
écrit qu'il écrit j'arrive pas à lire le
chat a trop de
messages est-ce qu'il des majeur en
Chine non pas de Grand Prix Fed n
Championnat du Monde euh féminin si mais
pas chez les hmes mais bon du coup après
ils font des des tournois le Shenzen je
crois qu'il est pas mauvais mais c'est
pas c'est pas un tournoi majeur Majeur
c'est quand même un bon
tournoi ils ont fait une fois aussi le
comment s'appelle le M game là je sais
pas quoi
ouais h TU non mais c'est impossible de
de que l'arbitre arrête hein c'est un
troll il suffit juste d'avoir des
cadences plus courtes en vrai et puis
c'est oui non mais l'arbitre doit pas
arrêter d'ailleurs une partie tu les
gagnes tout seul mais mais oui là tu
vois en j'im mieux que 2 minutes chacun
quoi
Mo par contre mais il réfléchit quand
même tellement à fond mais mais il est
pas du tout en confiance enfit il sait
dans quel état il est mais enfin
ouais mais il y a pas de problème lu non
non mais pas de souci il y a pas de
souci hein après peut-être la technique
de mtas ilve si longtemps pour que
l'autre
abandonne je remets une pub
Vy on va mettre des pubs de
partout allez h la petite pub qui fait
plaise vous avez déjà
joué
contre
ouais
attendsce j'ai j'avais un truc j'aV une
option dans un moment qui était
fantastique mais que j'ai plus c'était
de mettre 10 minutes de pub quoi et du
coup j'avais très envie Contin à troller
dans le chat le mettre 10 minutes quoi
B dégage tu regarder 10 minutes de pub
vous êtes quantaine se termine tes
prochains tournois serontù bah je devis
aller aux ÉtatsUnis cet
été c'est mort he Fab bah oui à mon avis
aussi non mais à mon avis mon prochain
tournoi il est pas prêt d'avoir lieu en
fait en France peut-être mais ce que je
veux dire c'est imagine nous on endigue
la crise mais mais c'est encore le
bordel en Allemagne et que c'est encore
le bordel je sais pas où comment on fait
donc je peux plus aller jouer à
l'étranger en général les joueurs tu
peux plus naviguer comme tu
peux et cetera et cetera quoi
donc donc en fait très compliqué mais
bon tant pis enfin on verra on
t'adaptera en fait c'est tout ce qu'il y
a à
faire qui a pas de pu ouais mince pas de
chance obligé de regarder ça
quoi
donc tu vas où aux US bah écoute je
crois que je vais pas y aller mais
j'avais prévu un truc sympa je devais
aller un peu à New York j'avais mon vol
de 25 juin euh ensuite je devais jouer
le tour de Philadelphie le world open
après après quelques jours à Vegas et
puis aller au Canada faire un tournoi
vers vers Toronto puis passer une
semaine à visiter un peu le Canada
remonter vers Montréal et puis un vol
Montréal Washington et je tour à
Washington c'est un beau parcours j'ai
déjà réservé plein de billets j'aià
réservé desbinb j'ai djà fait plein de
trucs et euh bon jeement la perte s mais
c'est comme ça quoi qu- que je te dis il
y a pire en fait ça me fait pas plaisir
j'aurais adoré le faire mais écoute il y
a une vraie crise sanitaire il y a des
vies en jeu donc bon tu peux perdre
trois billets d'avion voilà c'est ouais
j'aimerais bien que que le corona
disparaisse qu'on trouve le le vaccin
que tout a mieux j'ai États-Unis que ce
soit que ce soit un super été on fera
différemment c'est comme ça il les vie
seront pas
remboursés alors je pense qu'entre la
France et les États-Unis j'ai bon espoir
mais les vols interusa les vols le
Philadelphie Vegas rbnb qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent faire ou pas j'ai déjà vu des
gens qui gueulent parce que ils sonont
pas tout rembourser j'ai vu sur des
forum ou sur Twitter genre en fait ah
mais oui le confinement commencé que le
15 mars votre réservation é du 14 au 21
donc c antécédent au truc non tant pis
pas de chance non mais là je pense pas
parce que je sais pas non on verra non
mais je pense j'aurais pas 100 % des
frais avancés ça c'est c'est comme ça
mais tant pis j'aimerais bien les avoir
les 100 % mais ou même j'aimerais bien
même que qu' ce soit pas nnulé et y
aller mais mais je pense juste ça va
durer très longtemps en fait et donc des
trucs
plus plus grave que juste faire des
vacances ah c'est génial joue quand
mêmeer jusquau
mat c'est
extraordinaire en attendant le point Mo
positif c'est qu'on voit un truc qu'on
voit jamais aux échecs
ah une partie complètement foutue c'est
enfin ça peut arriver qu'au candidat un
truc pareil non c'est
rarissime h j'ai vraiment pas souvenir
d'avoir vu quelqu'un jouer aussi
longtemps
mais euh
[Musique]
ouais là il paraî qu' zidat rembourse
pas oui je sais pas enfin bon tant pis
enfin j'ai pas pris Z pas les ÉtatsUnis
non plus hein mais mais
bon est-ce que tu peux jouer comme ça tu
prends un risque ou pas si tu fais
ça ça a l'air d'être bien ça quand
même non ça c'est gagnant B tout est
gagnant je sais pas il te met plus un
échec non mais ouais va tuas pas besoin
de faire ça je pense il il va jamais
faire ça
ouais mais sur H faire3 fa un
échec fait de
échecs fais TR échecs merde il a gagné
al tu
souffles me prendre TR 4è échec fait qu
échecs donc
mais est-ce que tu penses que ça
dénote fibrilité mentale côté carwana
est-ce qu'il a pas de mental bah déjà il
a perdu la partie donc c'est qu'il a pas
de mental déjà déjà il est zéro
mentalement mais peut-êre moins un
niveau mental d'ailleurs du coup et je
pense qu'il va se faire défoncer par
Mazo en
note je sais pas
euh je sais rien j'en sais rien
est-ce que tu perds des notes si tu fais
enfin si tu es relou comme ça Mazo il te
sanctionne bah Mazo il fait ce qu'il
veut il est M bord en fait non mais je
sais mais est-ce
que est-ce que tu penses que Mazo va
sanctionner une t attitude ouais tu peux
tu peux tu peux je pas on verra je
serais très attentif au contrerendu
genre il te met zéro il te dit tu as une
très bonne préparation tu ne te
rappelles de rien tu lis pas tes
fichiers
on me demande pourquoi Saint-Étienne je
sais pas quoi non mais moi je suis
supporte de Sainté c'est pour ça à
Saint-Étienne et donc bah là je sais pas
je crois qu'il va de tout
donc pour la partie si laevoir pouvez
passer
voir 20h30 il va tout vouser comme il
faut
ouais il a vraiment un ESP je pense
qu'il cque juste mentalement honnêtement
les gars non mais aucun
est-ce que ljou a déjà joué contre ISAM
demande iron ouais ouais benah ISAM
mdoui outre le jouer c'est un très bon
ami en
fait il m'a il m'a coaché pendant un bon
moment parce que je suis allé jouer à
Montpellier en 2003 et donc ISAM habit à
Montpellier il a joué très longtemps
dans le club il est habité il a fait ses
études avant de partir au Qatar
entraîner et là maintenant on joue
encore ensemble au club de cliché donc
on se voit de temps en temps
euh j'ai joué euh ouais j'ai j'ai eu à
jouer quelques fois en tournoi mais fa
ça y est il a abandonné
ok bon stage décision et euh et ok bon
mais je sais pas pour moi surprise quand
même enfin là bon ça fait un moment
qu'on qu'on voit le truc se diriger mais
avant la ronde j'aurais jamais pensé à
une victoire de bon du coup Fab parlons
peu parlons bien on peut faire un petit
point classement ouais bah max en tête
execo avec wangao et nepo
ouais et euh carwana du coup en
embuscade avec Sacha et trois joueurs à
à mo-1 donc d quand même il se relance
donc je suis content pour lui
ouais il peut à mon avis si s'il fait
juste de sur TR dans le prochain truc il
sera 50 % après 6 rondes ETF 50 % après
6 rondes tu es complètement dedans en
fait hein complètement
donc c'est bien quand même de voir Ding
sur Lancer c'est aussi bien de voir
carwana freiner ouais et c'est vrai que
le trio de tête après trois rondes Fab
il est quand même un petit peu
surprenant pour le moment c'est des
outsiders c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais bon ben on a on a notre max
national dans le Lot donc tant mieux
quoi ouais non on est plutôt bien àti
mais donc NPO le mvl russe mvl le NPO
français il sont là
devant bah le le NPO le népo chinois
quoi enfin je sais pas mais wangao quand
même surprise de le voir de sur TR non
mais je pense qu'il est lui-même surpris
quoi il sa pas enfin le mec ne veut pas
jouer au Pr première intermédiaire il a
de sur TR quoi F serait beau que voir le
score des autres à la fin oui ils sont
tous à de sur TR il faut faut que tu
ailles un petit peu plus vite dans le
deè deuxème truc donc ça va être bien
cool à suivre prochaine partie mvl qui
aura de nouveau les blancs contre
gritou on connaît gritchou on connait
mvl c'est une partie qui risque
d'envoyer du très lourd à mon avis pas
de nul hein pas de nul rapide non ça non
ila peut-être nul à la fin mais ouii
mais non mais nul rapide je pense qu' en
aura très peu tout au long des candidats
est-ce que c'est pas les trois de mon
équipe ah non j'ai gritchou moi j'ai
gritchou wangao mvl franchement première
intermédiaire c'est pas mal moi j'ai
quoi j'ai wangao Guiry et Ding oh oh
comment tu es mal bah ça va gu pardon
Ding fait son retour dans le tournoi
quoi ouais mais bon fait
gu contre renchou avec
carwanaenko Isou Isou
quoiou qui a sacrifié qui a voulu
prendre carwana à tout prix tu dégages
non mais bon on va pas entr à
carwana en plus moi a 50 % après TR
rondes voilà mais non mais la défite du
jour c'est vrai que ça va pe lui faire
du bien mais on verra comment il se
remet après tout ça en plus mon équipe
Jech à 90 balles hein je suis pas elle
est pas du tout optimisé au niveau du
fric quoi enfin j'ai vraiment pris les
joueurs que je voulais ouais mais toi tu
es bon même sans un gros budget c'est
c'est ta force ouais c'est vrai
queavevec le budget que le budget genre
tu avais pris carwana Ding et gritu
enfin dégage mon équipe est beaucoup
plus forte que la tienne quoi vas-y
balance tes mignons moi je m'en fous
j'ai 90 je je fin devant non j'ai une
belle équipe enfin je suis très heureux
de mon équipe là enfin bravo l'équipe du
coup euh bah écoutez on va se retrouver
du coup ce soir à 20h30 on va vous faire
le petit résumé ouais et euh et du coup
je vous mets une petite pub désolé de
mettre un peu en parté tout à l'heure
avec la personne qui qui disait qu'il y
avait des problèmes de son il avait plus
ou moins raison donc merci à vous
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve bientôt
enfin ce soir et après après-demain
ouais à après-demain avec moi quoi après
attends après-demain avec toi oui ou à
la vidéo YouTube ah oui mais la vidéo
YouTube ou ça c'est autre chose mais je
parle sur le chesscom fr le twitch quoi
exactement bon je remets une pub de
sortie pour ceux qui veulent regarder la
pub allez hop k k k j'ur faire un petit
Kiri k k tu as le droit allez h